Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: done
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark how can you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman
Caption: what we're doing is we're talking to
Caption: people all over the world because we're
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success
Caption: it drives us to challenge the way things
Caption: are to pursue what seems insurmountable
Caption: to keep going when others would stop
Caption: ambition is how a global manufacturer is
Caption: using ai to empower employees with
Caption: disabilities ambition is how a company
Caption: managed an overnight transition to
Caption: remote work for 100 000 teammates
Caption: ambition is how a children's hospital
Caption: built an app to reduce stress for
Caption: families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together
Caption: now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: the call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very premium accent
Caption: so the berry completely makes sense as
Caption: for the thing no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with um hello kitty
Caption: riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king for the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and
Caption: we try to inspire each other by learning
Caption: new skills adding new challenges and
Caption: taking them and i think it's very
Caption: inspiring you better be better
Caption: personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow
Caption: but i also get a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top line
Caption: of testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better um i think that's really
Caption: important and i think it's going to be a
Caption: driving factor
Caption: going forward in
Caption: the it industry in general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: night
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: this is office nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our focus
Caption: i've always wanted to join scott
Caption: hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark can you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends
Caption: what we're doing is we're talking to
Caption: people all over the world because we're
Caption: stuck in our focus
Caption: i've always wanted to join
Caption: someone
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you
Caption: want god
Caption: oh
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off whatnot zero it's an identity
Caption: platform fast easy logins just what the
Caption: boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now
Caption: folks know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: oh yeah
Caption: i'm excited i'm excited hello
Caption: hi everybody
Caption: welcome to ddd perth 2022 uh
Caption: oh my gosh i'm so excited honestly there
Caption: are so many people amy was just saying
Caption: to me holy moly this is a bit bigger
Caption: than last year
Caption: yeah i think there's a few more people
Caption: this time back just a few we said a
Caption: thousand but
Caption: i'm not entirely sure we expected it to
Caption: feel this big
Caption: well when we said a thousand we're like
Caption: yep that's great that's great of course
Caption: we didn't hit a thousand we hit 1200. so
Caption: you know
Caption: it's great yeah
Caption: so
Caption: let's get started please ddd perth
Caption: wishes to acknowledge the traditional
Caption: custodians of this land the war jack
Caption: people of the nongao nation and i would
Caption: like to
Caption: extend a special welcome to robin
Caption: collard who will be doing our official
Caption: welcome to country just before keynote
Caption: in a little while thank you so much for
Caption: being with us robin yes
Caption: so for those of you who are new to a ddd
Caption: which given how many people we have is
Caption: probably some of you it originally
Caption: started in the uk in 2005 and has been
Caption: in perth since 2015 so i think we're
Caption: coming on eight years now the idea is
Caption: it's low cost it's on a saturday because
Caption: we've got nothing better to do on
Caption: weekends there's an open submission
Caption: process and it's a democratically chosen
Caption: agenda so i'm sorry if you don't like
Caption: the sessions that are on today you chose
Caption: them
Caption: so our purpose is to provide an
Caption: inclusive not-for-profit conference for
Caption: the entire perth software tech community
Caption: we we try to do this in line with our
Caption: values of affordability accessibility
Caption: inclusivity and openness how'd they do
Caption: amy yes
Caption: yes
Caption: so we've got a lot going on today but
Caption: thankfully we have a guide there is a
Caption: handbook on ddd perth which is available
Caption: on our website you can also find the qr
Caption: code on the back of your treasure map
Caption: which you were handed when you register
Caption: so that has a whole lot of information
Caption: including links to the agenda
Caption: information about the venue
Caption: and
Caption: this year we have an interactive map so
Caption: if you find yourself getting lost
Caption: that can tell you what's going on where
Caption: so like i said this conference is sold
Caption: out we have a lot of people on the wait
Caption: list and we also have a number of people
Caption: watching online we've done this this
Caption: year as a little bit of a test thank you
Caption: to everybody watching online who is
Caption: feeling a bit unwell and so you decided
Caption: to stay at home a big welcome to people
Caption: as far as manjump in our south west
Caption: melbourne and canada who are watching
Caption: online as well thank you for joining us
Caption: look we have 57 amazing
Caption: awesome spon uh speakers here today it's
Caption: absolutely huge isn't it yes and those
Caption: speakers are not just from perth so
Caption: we've had the speakers come from
Caption: interstate and internationally as well
Caption: so we've got some amazing
Caption: presentations that are going to be
Caption: happening today
Caption: all of this of course
Caption: is able to happen because of our amazing
Caption: sponsors which we'll hear a little bit
Caption: more about afterwards we have 22
Caption: sponsors so we have 22 companies that i
Caption: decided to support ddd this year which
Caption: is awesome
Caption: so it really is a truck uh track buffet
Caption: today with nine tracks if you missed
Caption: something don't worry uh you can watch
Caption: it online
Caption: after the event or maybe you can
Caption: find somewhere to sit and
Caption: watch it during because of those live
Caption: streams
Caption: amy
Caption: that probably leads right into
Caption: everyone's favorite word covert huh yes
Caption: the covert policy so our covered policy
Caption: is available on our website
Caption: and you will find hand sanitizer all
Caption: around the venue at all of the booths
Caption: and plenty of stands
Caption: there are strict room capacities because
Caption: of this so unfortunately there is no
Caption: standing room in each of our sessions if
Caption: there's something you really want to see
Caption: make sure you get there early and if you
Caption: miss out maybe pop into one of the other
Caption: sessions or hang around and check out
Caption: some of the sponsor booths we do ask
Caption: everyone's covered safe we've got mass
Caption: available if you would like one
Caption: and you may notice if you've been to ddd
Caption: in previous years and our catering is a
Caption: little bit differently to
Caption: uh to accommodate this back do you want
Caption: to talk a bit about catering yeah so of
Caption: course we uh we hope that you are well
Caption: fed today we have tea coffee hot
Caption: chocolate available all day the first
Caption: two coffee cuts
Caption: will finish up around two-ish and but we
Caption: have coffee available and coffee carts
Caption: available until four
Caption: you
Caption: morning tea look the same
Caption: lunch well hopefully everyone's got
Caption: their lanyard and we will talk a little
Caption: bit about how our pre-patched lunches
Caption: are working today uh please do clean up
Caption: after yourself though there's heaps of
Caption: bins around 1200 people we really need
Caption: to make sure that we don't leave stuff
Caption: hanging yes okay so have you got a
Caption: lanyard show me your lanyards you should
Caption: have a little sticker on your lanyard
Caption: and that little sticker probably has a
Caption: one through two a six on it and that
Caption: will correspond
Caption: to what you ordered when you registered
Caption: if it doesn't
Caption: please check your ticket before you come
Caption: to the help desk
Caption: if it still doesn't match
Caption: then please uh at lunch time come to the
Caption: help desk and we will help you there's
Caption: plenty of food
Caption: but
Caption: yeah so
Caption: if you don't have a number
Caption: that means that unfortunately you didn't
Caption: make the cut off
Caption: but i am still going to feed you so uh
Caption: if that is the case please do come to
Caption: the help desk we've got plenty plenty of
Caption: food available for you we do apologize
Caption: if your first choice is not
Caption: available
Caption: now once you've worked out what number
Caption: you've got we've also scattered this
Caption: food around the the venue at lunch time
Caption: so there's a bit of a preview here on
Caption: where you might be able to find your
Caption: food otherwise this information is
Caption: available on the interactive map if you
Caption: get a little bit lost as well we'll have
Caption: a bunch of volunteers who will be
Caption: hanging around to help direct you so
Caption: they'll let you know where you can go
Caption: and find your food
Caption: as we said today is really not possible
Caption: without our amazing sponsors we have
Caption: three platinum sponsors here with us
Caption: today and we'd like to just give a
Caption: really special shout out to them so
Caption: thank you
Caption: so much to telstra purple a long time
Caption: supporter of this conference really we
Caption: couldn't we couldn't do it without you
Caption: the same goes for microsoft my goodness
Caption: uh such a long time supporter uh thank
Caption: you for bringing this conference to life
Caption: and we also have a new platinum sponsor
Caption: with us today mantle group now you can
Caption: find all of these sponsor booths
Caption: out in the main foyer area
Caption: we really encourage you to go have a
Caption: chat
Caption: to our sponsors all of our sponsors uh
Caption: because they are the reason that we're
Caption: able to put on this entire conference so
Caption: our gold sponsors my goodness so many
Caption: we have a lot of gold sponsors which you
Caption: will also see out in the foyer so we
Caption: have gold sponsors out in the booze we
Caption: have a lot of amazing gold sponsors who
Caption: also helped us to put on the events that
Caption: we do today so at some point today make
Caption: sure you go and have a chat to the
Caption: sponsors see what they've what they've
Caption: got a little bit about the the companies
Caption: but most importantly check out what swag
Caption: and what prizes they're giving away so i
Caption: mean i said that there's a track buffet
Caption: there's also a bit of a prize buffet
Caption: going on in perth uh today at dd perth
Caption: now we've also got a number of other
Caption: sponsors we've got some fantastic silver
Caption: sponsors and thank you from the bottom
Caption: of our hearts for you
Caption: to support this conference it's so
Caption: important to us
Caption: we also have three coffee cart sponsors
Caption: we've got some juice and we have an
Caption: amazing quiet room experience for you
Caption: brought to you by keystart we also have
Caption: some fantastic childcare too don't we
Caption: amy yes we do which we're going to talk
Caption: a little bit more about that later
Caption: so for those who haven't been to a ddd
Caption: perth event before we take our code of
Caption: conduct very seriously because we want
Caption: to provide a harassment free experience
Caption: for everybody so there's information
Caption: available about our code of conduct on
Caption: the website you can find the link in our
Caption: website menu
Caption: but
Caption: it comes down to if at any point today
Caption: you have any issues or concerns if you
Caption: feel unsafe or unwelcome there are
Caption: several ways that you can get in touch
Caption: with our team to report it so that we
Caption: can make sure that you have a good
Caption: experience at ddd back how can they get
Caption: in touch with us so first of all you can
Caption: visit the volunteer desk you can visit
Caption: our help desk you can find anyone who is
Caption: wearing one of these shirts today and
Caption: they can help you out you can also
Caption: direct message us on twitter and there
Caption: are a number of us including me who will
Caption: be monitoring that channel and uh there
Caption: are about four of us amy and i are two
Caption: of them uh another is i think in seattle
Caption: and and matt now treasurer uh pay
Caption: attention to info
Caption: dddperth.com so you can email us as well
Caption: and we will respond
Caption: as well as we can we also have an
Caption: anonymous reporting tool amy yes we do
Caption: so if you go to our code of conduct page
Caption: you can find all of these ways to get in
Caption: touch as well as an anonymous reporting
Caption: form if you would like to stay anonymous
Caption: so
Caption: speaking of
Caption: issues we also have a
Caption: well we have a bunch of people uh here
Caption: today who don't wish their photo on
Caption: social media you can find these people
Caption: because they've got a red lanyard on if
Caption: you are
Caption: tweeting if you are
Caption: making a linkedin story if you're doing
Caption: anything today please when you are
Caption: taking photos pay attention uh to who's
Caption: in your photo if you see a red red
Caption: lanyard please take another photo that
Caption: doesn't have them in them quite simple
Caption: uh but
Caption: uh you know i've i'm not quite sure if
Caption: we're going to trend on twitter this
Caption: weekend there's a few global events
Caption: going on yes
Caption: but we're going to give it a red hot go
Caption: so that is our hashtag
Caption: please
Caption: make some noise and uh and let's see
Caption: what we can do
Caption: yes
Caption: so a little bit of housekeeping our
Caption: agenda anybody who's been keeping track
Caption: we have had quite a few changes to our
Caption: agenda this year which is great because
Caption: this year we also made the decision not
Caption: to print it
Caption: uh which is excellent because most of it
Caption: would have been out of date anyway our
Caption: agenda is available on our website so
Caption: make sure you keep an eye on whether or
Caption: not the session you wanted to see is
Caption: still happening and is still in the same
Caption: room
Caption: as with most events if there is a fire
Caption: follow the exits in the event of a flyer
Caption: we will also defer to the wonderful pcec
Caption: staff which will i'm sure calmly direct
Caption: us
Caption: where to go much more calmly than me
Caption: this is a new smoking venue you can find
Caption: designated smoking uh places outside the
Caption: main doors towards the train station
Caption: we also ask that throughout sessions you
Caption: keep your phones on silent so as not to
Caption: interrupt the presentations but also
Caption: probably the speakers may call you out
Caption: if it does go off that's embarrassing
Caption: and keep your lanyard on there are
Caption: several other events going on at the
Caption: convention center today so if you do not
Caption: have a lanyard on we may assume you're
Caption: not supposed to be here and ask you to
Caption: leave more importantly you don't have
Caption: your lanyard on you won't get lunch
Caption: today
Caption: so
Caption: okay moderated panels we have two we're
Caption: gonna we're gonna hurry this up because
Caption: obviously we've got so much content as
Caption: always we have two moderated panels
Caption: going on at lunch today our lunch is
Caption: extra long
Caption: you can find that info on the agenda
Caption: which is on the website
Caption: you can also scan this qr code if you
Caption: have any questions to ask our panelists
Caption: ahead of time and you can upvote the
Caption: questions that are existing
Caption: this link is not exclusively on here you
Caption: can also find it via the agenda yes you
Caption: can
Caption: and twitter right yes
Caption: we'll get it on twitter
Caption: we talked a little bit about our quiet
Caption: room the this morning as well uh we have
Caption: some amazing sponsors and if at any
Caption: point today you're a little bit
Caption: overwhelmed because we're back at an
Caption: in-person event and it's probably going
Caption: to happen we have not one but two quiet
Caption: spaces available to go to so if you head
Caption: directly out of the theater you will see
Caption: a
Caption: hidden hallway with a red carpet this
Caption: will lead you into a foyer this is a
Caption: really nice chill space you can have
Caption: some snacks sit down have a chat with
Caption: some other attendees take a break
Caption: if you would like something that's a
Caption: little bit quieter you can then go
Caption: through the doors into a low sensory
Caption: room keep in mind though if you are in
Caption: the outer foyer people might be in the
Caption: room trying to stay nice and quiet and
Caption: relaxed so try not to talk too loudly so
Caption: that space is available if you'd like to
Caption: take a break away from the rest of the
Caption: day
Caption: child care yes so child care one of the
Caption: changes that we did last year was to
Caption: make our child care free and we had a
Caption: lot of people
Caption: take us up on
Caption: that wonderful opportunity to be child
Caption: free this year we have sold out our
Caption: child care and so apologies to a number
Caption: of people who did miss out we have over
Caption: 30 buddy budding technologists here with
Caption: us today a really special welcome
Caption: actually to our coding workshop students
Caption: our coding workshop students and this
Caption: coding workshop is being hosted by she
Caption: codes thank you so much
Caption: they are joining us for the keynote and
Caption: the lock note today and in between
Caption: they're going to be uh learning to be us
Caption: i think so yeah so it's really exciting
Caption: to have so many young
Caption: people here today excited to learn more
Caption: tech
Caption: now we've got a lot on today so it's
Caption: going to be really awesome but
Caption: i know how you're feeling it's going to
Caption: get to the end of the day and you're not
Caption: going to want to go home because we want
Caption: more thankfully
Caption: we have aft something happening after
Caption: ddd so it's there's going to be food
Caption: there's going to be a various range of
Caption: beverages there's going to be board
Caption: games which are obviously the best bit
Caption: and i'm sure there'll be some good
Caption: conversation going on so this will be
Caption: outside until 7pm if you would like to
Caption: hang around and continue chatting with
Caption: some of the amazing people we have here
Caption: today
Caption: okay enterprises prizes prizes prizes
Caption: everyone's favorite thing okay so we
Caption: have so many prizes today almost all of
Caption: our sponsors have some
Caption: level of swag or prizes available on
Caption: their booth uh and then we also have a
Caption: number of prizes that we are going to be
Caption: giving away just before or just after
Caption: the lock note sorry oh and a wooden
Caption: spoon fantastic okay so there are three
Caption: different ways that you can
Caption: get a prize
Caption: number one you need to provide feedback
Caption: to our all of the sessions and the
Caption: conference itself and these feedback
Caption: links are live on the agenda and on the
Caption: website uh it's so important for our
Caption: speakers to really hear from the
Caption: attendees how things are keep it
Caption: respectful guys and girls
Caption: to make the event bigger and better
Caption: every year
Caption: is thanks to the feedback that we get
Caption: from people submitting here
Caption: if
Caption: you don't want to submit feedback or if
Caption: you want to put in another entry to win
Caption: some of our amazing prizes
Caption: you can fill out your treasure map which
Caption: will have been given to you at
Caption: registration with your lanyard if you go
Caption: around and have a chat with all of our
Caption: sponsors today they will be able to
Caption: stamp your treasure map once it's filled
Caption: in you can write your name on it make
Caption: sure you write your name on it otherwise
Caption: it doesn't matter you won't win anyway
Caption: and put it into one of the boxes that we
Caption: have available at the help desk now the
Caption: the third way is speaker pose bingo and
Caption: this is new this year uh you will note
Caption: that we are a little bit active up on
Caption: stage this year we have a lovely little
Caption: grid of a number of speaker poses you
Caption: can find this linked on our blog and
Caption: also tweet it out right about now
Caption: or you can take a photo if your camera's
Caption: that good
Caption: mark off take some photos mark off when
Caption: you see these particular poses
Caption: up on stage today
Caption: take your phone across to help desk get
Caption: it validated and enter this prize door
Caption: as well
Caption: speaker post bingo
Caption: speakerpost bingo hashtag
Caption: and make sure there's a photo to prove
Caption: it because pixar it didn't happen so
Caption: keep an eye out also noted this does
Caption: have to be from multiple different
Caption: speakers so you can't get one person who
Caption: just does a lot of really amazing photos
Caption: this is to be at least four different
Caption: speakers and
Caption: this cannot be staged if we see a whole
Caption: lot of photos of speakers beforehand
Caption: doing poses that doesn't count
Caption: okay fantastic thank you so much for
Caption: your attention uh now we would very much
Caption: like to welcome robin collard to the
Caption: stage for our official welcome to
Caption: country
Caption: peace out we'll see you at the lottery
Caption: my goodness me what a hard act to follow
Caption: good morning my name is robin collard
Caption: and i'm in young yoga of the wajap clan
Caption: here
Caption: in perth or borulu as noongar people
Caption: know it
Caption: i am one of many custodians
Caption: and traditional owners of this land and
Caption: i'm humbly honoured to perform this
Caption: welcome to country for you this morning
Caption: i would like to acknowledge with the
Caption: highest respect
Caption: elders
Caption: yogas and juke our women and sisters
Caption: marmon
Caption: our men and brothers
Caption: mort any family who may be here
Caption: and of course our british the leaders
Caption: who made this fantastic event happen
Caption: for you today
Caption: there are three principles that are
Caption: really important for our people
Caption: our connection to land
Caption: our connection to family and our
Caption: connection to our knowledge our
Caption: traditional knowledge
Caption: that is
Caption: carries our stories
Caption: and our ancestors have walked this land
Caption: for many many thousands of years
Caption: we stand on their shoulders
Caption: because they have managed to keep our
Caption: stories
Caption: our knowledge
Caption: and our language alive through many
Caption: traumas through this history
Caption: we are survivors
Caption: i stand here in perth
Caption: on this beautiful land right next to the
Caption: swan river
Caption: and we have some very special places
Caption: that are close to us here in perth
Caption: matagara
Caption: kardagara yelagonga mayamaya
Caption: i mentioned matagara because marked in
Caption: means
Caption: your leg
Caption: so the place of the leg or where the
Caption: water comes up to the top of your leg
Caption: is just down the river
Caption: and this is where nunga people in the
Caption: very
Caption: early days would cross over
Caption: from one side of the water to the other
Caption: because the water only ever came up to
Caption: the top of your leg
Caption: and that is all of that space around
Caption: harrison island a very sacred women's
Caption: space
Caption: and birthing area
Caption: for our people
Caption: i also mentioned kardagara or king's
Caption: park because the word nunga word for the
Caption: head or the top of is cart
Caption: so you're standing at the top of the
Caption: hill
Caption: looking out over the water
Caption: and into the distance to other special
Caption: places here in noongar country
Caption: court
Caption: now
Caption: i acknowledge the stories
Caption: the noongar creation story for the
Caption: rainbow serpent of how this land was
Caption: made and how the our culture is still
Caption: strong and our stories
Caption: still continue to be
Caption: this is the creation story for this part
Caption: of our land
Caption: just as there are creation stories
Caption: across the world
Caption: for our indigenous cultures
Caption: we listen to the many stories of this
Caption: land
Caption: we're here called bharti the magpie
Caption: wadong the crow
Caption: jitty jitty
Caption: the willy wagtail
Caption: whether the rain is coming
Caption: and cleansing the space
Caption: or whether it is the wind that blows
Caption: gently on our faces as we walk this land
Caption: the stories are there it's whether we
Caption: listen
Caption: whether we listen with our hearts
Caption: to hear those stories
Caption: we listen to the many stories of this
Caption: land gilbert
Caption: this is the
Caption: season of jilba
Caption: it is the time of fertility
Caption: the newborns the new swans coming out
Caption: the new dolphins that are waiting to be
Caption: named that have been born
Caption: and in fact called body season
Caption: we know that this is the the month
Caption: for the attacks because they are looking
Caption: after their young
Caption: and they are very fiercely protective
Caption: how the world has changed
Caption: with covet
Caption: we can team in from across the world
Caption: we have to learn to trust
Caption: and work from home
Caption: and have that flexibility
Caption: and even nana's like me know all this
Caption: technology
Caption: and i have 14 grandchildren to teach me
Caption: what i don't know
Caption: so there are opportunities there for you
Caption: to come up with new ideas and new ways
Caption: of working
Caption: and even welcome to country can also be
Caption: tuned in remotely
Caption: videos made for us to be a part of this
Caption: fantastic new world
Caption: you
Caption: are
Caption: rich
Caption: that is our word for strong and
Caption: resilient and we find new ways of
Caption: working together
Caption: and this is also an opportunity
Caption: to make new friends
Caption: to eat and share food and drink
Caption: and have those conversations wanking in
Caption: one canyon
Caption: so have a great day today and thank you
Caption: triple d for inviting me to deliver your
Caption: welcome and have a fantastic time
Caption: jungkook
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you very much robin collard for
Caption: that amazing welcome to country
Caption: all right
Caption: this morning we have
Caption: a
Caption: this morning we have an amazing keynote
Caption: speaker christina alden who is going to
Caption: be joining me on stage uh i might
Caption: introduce her while she gets her
Caption: computer set up
Caption: christina has traveled all the way from
Caption: las vegas where i have found out people
Caption: live there
Caption: as well as just go to visit
Caption: christina speaks
Caption: at conferences
Caption: all over the world
Caption: on various topics in tech
Caption: as well as tedx has done a tedx talk
Caption: which is great because we have our own
Caption: tedx sign on stage here today so i hope
Caption: christina will feel at home christina's
Caption: going to be talking to us this morning
Caption: about
Caption: memory
Caption: which is great so we hope that means
Caption: that you will remember
Caption: christina's talk as well as everybody
Caption: else's talk today
Caption: uh so i'm going to hand over to
Caption: christina
Caption: to open the conference this morning
Caption: and thank you very much for joining us
Caption: christina thank you
Caption: let's open this and keep this down here
Caption: certainly spill it otherwise
Caption: oh i forgotten the passcode okay
Caption: fantastic
Caption: let's move this over here
Caption: ah
Caption: brilliant
Caption: look at all you you're gorgeous
Caption: fantastic
Caption: i think a lot of us can relate to this
Caption: like you're having a dream
Caption: right
Caption: and i mean you are in it like you are in
Caption: it deep
Caption: and you are about to give somebody like
Caption: this person you cannot even believe that
Caption: they just said this to you and you are
Caption: having this dream and you are really
Caption: getting riled up right you are really
Caption: feeling it maybe your heart is racing
Caption: and they have really ticked you off this
Caption: last time and that's it you are not
Caption: going to deal with this anymore you will
Caption: not put up with maybe you got a finger
Caption: going right maybe maybe you got a hand
Caption: on your hip and your big climax suppose
Caption: yes here you go and suddenly
Caption: beep beep
Caption: right
Caption: your alarm
Caption: and you wake up and then maybe your
Caption: person is maybe they're there maybe
Caption: they're
Caption: oh
Caption: good morning
Caption: oh oh don't you good morning mate
Caption: right
Caption: and it's not necessarily anything that
Caption: that they've done
Caption: right but you still have that experience
Caption: your nervous system has felt it you have
Caption: the memory you see it in your eye in
Caption: your mind's eye right or who's had this
Caption: happen before
Caption: you're sitting around with your family
Caption: and you're telling a story
Caption: i do this for kids in my family so you
Caption: know we got lots of stories
Caption: we get together we start telling the
Caption: story and you're talking about how oh
Caption: you know remember that one time
Caption: when mom sent me down to the corner
Caption: store and i had the money in my hand and
Caption: i was riding my bike and i was going and
Caption: then it fell off the curb and the coins
Caption: went everywhere and your brother goes
Caption: hold on
Caption: that was me
Caption: i was the one who was with the money mom
Caption: sent me to the corner
Caption: i have the scar on my knee to prove it
Caption: like that's that wasn't even you
Caption: right
Caption: who's done that before
Caption: sometimes
Caption: we lock into these memories
Caption: right
Caption: we can
Caption: feel these stories we can drive this
Caption: narrative that's never even really
Caption: happened to us but we have
Caption: this experience
Caption: and so oftentimes our memories they'll
Caption: they'll drive a narrative to which we
Caption: become emotionally attached and
Caption: sometimes these emotional attachments
Caption: they can hold us back
Caption: and when stressed we lock into the way
Caption: that we feel
Caption: it starts to become supportive of that
Caption: stress
Caption: more
Caption: and more
Caption: and more and the more we reinforce that
Caption: feeling
Caption: the deeper those memories
Caption: they get locked into our neural pathways
Caption: and we'll talk a little bit more about
Caption: that process
Caption: later but you know with lots of help
Caption: from uh highly trained professionals
Caption: i've been able to
Caption: learn how to navigate stressful triggers
Caption: by processing my memories better and
Caption: releasing emotional attachments that are
Caption: holding me back i've learned to change
Caption: the narrative
Caption: and
Caption: [Music]
Caption: i've learned to understand when my
Caption: memory is reliable when my memory is not
Caption: reliable and how it serves me
Caption: regardless of the accuracy so today i
Caption: want to share some of that stuff that
Caption: i've learned about improving brain
Caption: performance and as always please just
Caption: take what applies to you and throw the
Caption: rest away i'm not a doctor i'm not a
Caption: neuroscientist
Caption: i'm not a therapist but i do have
Caption: first-hand experience overcoming trauma
Caption: and i'm not going to be talking about
Caption: any of that today but i've come to
Caption: realize that the stories that i've tell
Caption: myself and others they can either be the
Caption: chains that bind me
Caption: or they can be the keys that release me
Caption: from that trauma that i aim to overcome
Caption: my name is christina aldan i am a brand
Caption: strategy consultant i'm based out of las
Caption: vegas i'm a speaker trainer
Caption: mentor i'm a certified mental health
Caption: first aid for youth and for adults and i
Caption: am really excited to be here i sit on
Caption: the board of directors for a non-profit
Caption: for stem and also for mental health
Caption: awareness if you want to continue this
Caption: conversation please use the hashtag
Caption: luckymemory
Caption: i want to say thanks so much to
Caption: our sponsors and to ddd perth i
Caption: personally grew up in a teeny tiny
Caption: little town in the midwest in michigan
Caption: and i never ever thought that i'd be
Caption: able to travel to australia in fact i
Caption: dreamed about traveling to australia
Caption: when i was a kid because it is the
Caption: farthest way directly on the other side
Caption: of the planet
Caption: from where i grew up and so this is
Caption: amazing to me to be delivering the
Caption: opening keynote at ddd perth and i just
Caption: want to say thanks so much to all of the
Caption: organizers and volunteers and the
Caption: sponsors for bringing us together today
Caption: so
Caption: so what
Caption: our memories they hold the key
Caption: to better communication to emotional
Caption: intelligence to
Caption: being more open to the viewpoints of
Caption: others and for setting healthy
Caption: boundaries i just realized i'm doing a
Caption: lot of poses i'm going to stand here for
Caption: the rest of my talk like this
Caption: nobody's winning bingo today
Caption: but you could see how as a brand
Caption: strategy consultant
Caption: you know i'm always looking for ways to
Caption: connect products and services in
Caption: meaningful ways to our end users and and
Caption: to our customers you can see how this
Caption: stuff would be important to me when i'm
Caption: creating marketing funnels that have
Caption: emotional triggers attached to them so
Caption: what is memory
Caption: it's a faculty by which the mind stores
Caption: remembers information something
Caption: remembered from the past
Caption: it is a recollection which is really a
Caption: way to say you know memory is the
Caption: process that we use to encode store and
Caption: retrieve data
Caption: this affects our cognition that's how we
Caption: think about things and also it affects
Caption: our behavior how
Caption: we respond our observable responses and
Caption: so our brains are constantly taking in
Caption: data both internal and external we have
Caption: all of these stimuli and we're
Caption: processing data in real time um
Caption: based on all the new information that we
Caption: take in
Caption: mixed with the information that's
Caption: already in there right and so these days
Caption: what we know as memory is actually it's
Caption: an interconnected group of memory
Caption: subsystems right we used to think that
Caption: there's left brain and right brain
Caption: that's actually not how our brains work
Caption: and these multiple memory systems
Caption: they're constantly processing data and
Caption: they're able to function together or
Caption: independently of each other
Caption: so memories are weird
Caption: memories can be compressed
Caption: our brain has this quality where you
Caption: know if the stimulus is the same over
Caption: and over again
Caption: our memories will just compress it
Caption: because it's the same day who's done
Caption: this recently when you said i do this
Caption: oh yeah last time you were over my house
Caption: for dinner six months ago and we did
Caption: board games and we did
Caption: no christina that was a year and six
Caption: months ago
Caption: because everybody's living been living
Caption: the same day over and over and over and
Caption: over again because of covid and so our
Caption: brain has this quality for efficiency
Caption: that it just compresses the memories
Caption: right and so remember it's our emotions
Caption: that that drive that narrative for our
Caption: memories and so even though we can't
Caption: give our brain more processing power
Caption: like like we can for our machines we can
Caption: just insert some
Caption: more processing power into our computers
Caption: we can't do that for our brains but we
Caption: can
Caption: we can look for unconscious biases we
Caption: can look for inefficient processes in
Caption: our brains and we can actually with
Caption: practice
Caption: improve our brain performance so i'm
Caption: going to uh share with you some of the
Caption: ways that our brains might fail us and
Caption: ways that we can improve our memories
Caption: today and i'm not saying that you know
Caption: you can completely forget things or
Caption: that'll erase away things but we can
Caption: improve how we process things this has
Caption: especially been helpful for my mentees
Caption: for my coaching clients who are going
Caption: through long covid right who's been
Caption: experiencing a lot of brain fog in the
Caption: past couple of years that is a real
Caption: issue and so
Caption: if you can just focus on one of these
Caption: techniques for three months and then
Caption: move on to the next one then okay cool
Caption: i'm gonna share with you a whole lot of
Caption: techniques that i've learned and been
Caption: practicing
Caption: in the last four years it's been really
Caption: cool
Caption: check this out
Caption: so today we're going to talk about these
Caption: types of memory systems
Caption: we're going to talk about the biological
Caption: storage about improving daily
Caption: performance about your confidence so for
Caption: an example if you are
Caption: if you are
Caption: if you're starting for a new job
Caption: right you're starting a new job and you
Caption: get to introduce yourself to people
Caption: around the office
Caption: you want people to observe you
Caption: recognizing other people's names and
Caption: having that memory and holding on to
Caption: other people's names because then you
Caption: appear more confident and so that is a
Caption: quality that's going to be more
Caption: beneficial to you right
Caption: emotional intelligence we're going to
Caption: talk about that a little bit i could
Caption: talk about that all day but we don't
Caption: have all day
Caption: and then you know conflict conflict is
Caption: inevitable and so there is a one-way
Caption: extreme way to respond to a situation
Caption: and there's another extreme way to
Caption: respond to a situation i kind of try to
Caption: waver around the middle so that when we
Caption: have informed choices to choose from
Caption: then we're going to pick the best
Caption: possible response to get the best
Caption: possible results in a situation
Caption: so barrick and ebbinghaus they're the
Caption: ones who conducted this research in 1984
Caption: and they found that most of the
Caption: forgetting happens between the ages of
Caption: four to five that's when our memory
Caption: subsystems start to develop and we have
Caption: two of them declarative and
Caption: non-declarative so we have a different
Caption: memory subsystem for for memorializing
Caption: like algebraic formulas for example or
Caption: or a different memory subsystem for
Caption: doing on-the-spot math right in fact
Caption: there's this quality called memory
Caption: consolidation who's heard of that before
Caption: memory consolidation it's when you go to
Caption: sleep right and you get the benefit of
Caption: consolidating your memories and and it
Caption: really strengthens
Caption: those neural pathways and synaptic
Caption: connections between the neurons
Caption: structurally and chemically that is
Caption: called memory consolidation
Caption: our declarative memory
Caption: it's your conscious memory
Caption: it involves effort involves intention
Caption: and so we can use intentional techniques
Caption: we do tests we do aptitude tests we do
Caption: the lsat for attorneys we we do certain
Caption: um
Caption: mnemonics or repetition right and
Caption: biologically it's the hippocampus that
Caption: and the frontal lobes that manage this
Caption: part of our memory the declarative
Caption: memory system it can be measured with
Caption: those explicit tests so check this out
Caption: these are the three different types that
Caption: we have we have working memory and
Caption: people who struggle with adhd usually
Caption: this is the type of memory subsystem
Caption: that is challenged most for them because
Caption: you only have two to 18 seconds for the
Caption: old information
Caption: to collide with the new information and
Caption: then you process it right the the
Caption: biological uh part of your brain
Caption: uh that's a present is the ability to to
Caption: help you take in that new information
Caption: and then we have episodic memory
Caption: episodic memory this is our long-term
Caption: memory system um but it's about specific
Caption: life events right this is where we we
Caption: store our our wedding day memories
Caption: that
Caption: one time and christina aldan gave an
Caption: amazing keynote at ddd perth wow right
Caption: these episodic memories when you're
Caption: riding your bike and you're holding on
Caption: to the coins and then your bike falls
Caption: and the coins go everywhere
Caption: episodic memory subsystem is where that
Caption: is stored and then we have our semantic
Caption: memory subsystem and you know this is
Caption: general knowledge this is two plus two
Caption: is four right the capital loss of nevada
Caption: is carson city the the factual general
Caption: knowledge if i have a red ball in my
Caption: hand
Caption: and i decide to
Caption: fling it all the way to the back of the
Caption: room take that speaker pose bingo
Caption: i
Caption: have the red bull and maybe for your
Caption: semantic memory maybe you see it okay
Caption: did she throw it yes was the ball read
Caption: general factual information there's no
Caption: narrative or emotion attached to it what
Caption: happens when we start attaching a memory
Caption: to it that's a a narrative to it that's
Caption: a little bit different
Caption: oh my gosh did you see christina winged
Caption: that ball right past my head she almost
Caption: hit me what a jerk right that's a
Caption: totally
Caption: different memory subsystem semantic
Caption: memory only works with the general
Caption: knowledge
Caption: then there's non-declarative memory this
Caption: is your unconscious mind memory it is
Caption: inherently there it's automatically
Caption: there your biases uh instantly are there
Caption: and it requires zero effort it's
Caption: unintentional right biologically this is
Caption: our cortical areas of our brain the
Caption: cerebellum the basal ganglia
Caption: they're the ones that govern the
Caption: non-declarative memory subsystem and so
Caption: this is really imperative for forming
Caption: new memories you'll see if people have
Caption: amnesia and they're struggling with that
Caption: usually they have maybe damage to their
Caption: cerebellum or something like that and so
Caption: people um can can improve by even you
Caption: know focusing on activities that are
Caption: going to stimulate the basal ganglia the
Caption: cortical areas the cerebellum and of
Caption: course there are three
Caption: different
Caption: memory subsystems priming our memory we
Caption: can prime our memory by
Caption: repetition there are certain things like
Caption: um
Caption: you can prime your memory
Caption: with a perfume right you're at you're at
Caption: the grocery and you go walk by and
Caption: little grandma comes by and oh she
Caption: smells like your little grandma because
Caption: she's wearing that same perfume we can
Caption: prime our memory with those kinds of
Caption: things and then we also have
Caption: conditioning
Caption: conditioning is like pablob's dog
Caption: who's heard of pablob's dog here most
Caption: everybody right he rang the bell he fed
Caption: the dog the dog would salivate ring the
Caption: bell feed the dog dog would salivate
Caption: pretty soon all he had to do is
Caption: ring the bell that's it and the dog
Caption: would salivate exactly and so we can
Caption: condition our brain patterns through
Caption: things like neuro-linguistic programming
Caption: or through hypnosis certain techniques
Caption: that will help improve your
Caption: condition brain and then we have our
Caption: motor procedural memory this is a
Caption: physical repetition over and over and
Caption: over again hitting a baseball hitting a
Caption: golf ball dribbling a basketball these
Caption: are a motor procedural memory subsystem
Caption: stimuli
Caption: so
Caption: when these different
Caption: subsystems are stimulated right they
Caption: start encoding storing and retrieving
Caption: data together and sometimes not together
Caption: sometimes a memory subsystem will be
Caption: isolated from the other one and it won't
Caption: be activated so for example let's taking
Caption: it let's say you're taking a math final
Caption: all right we've learned semantic memory
Caption: is going to store that formula right
Caption: general factual knowledge cool all right
Caption: but then you sit down to take your math
Caption: final and
Caption: your brain goes
Caption: somehow your short-term memory there
Caption: is not giving you access either maybe
Caption: you have
Caption: an amygdala hijack and you're just like
Caption: panicking and you're freaking out
Caption: because you're not a person who takes
Caption: tests really well maybe like i said
Caption: maybe you have uh adhd right and so that
Caption: that new information's colliding with
Caption: the old information and it's just
Caption: they're hitting a wall and it's not
Caption: happening right and so maybe um this
Caption: this is you're having a panic attack
Caption: this is this is a real thing for a lot
Caption: of people right um and then on top of
Caption: that maybe you're suffering from the
Caption: effects of of long covid
Caption: or maybe you're more of an auditory
Caption: learner and processor when it comes to
Caption: math maybe you're more of a visual
Caption: learner and process
Caption: visual
Caption: cues when it comes to math maybe you're
Caption: more of an associative learner right
Caption: maybe you got to have your favorite
Caption: conference hoodie when you do your math
Caption: test because guess what it's my lucky
Caption: hoodie
Caption: we see this with sports people right we
Caption: see this all the time everybody's got to
Caption: have their
Caption: lucky hoodie they're not gonna shave my
Caption: beard because it's lucky i'm not gonna
Caption: cut my hair whatever that is but they're
Caption: more associative and so that's how they
Caption: perform best
Caption: right
Caption: there are a lot of different pro
Caption: approaches and the goal is to get your
Caption: brain
Caption: to organize information in a way
Caption: that is optimum for you and guess what
Caption: there are 7.9 billion different ways to
Caption: do that ladies and gentlemen so it's
Caption: amazing that anything gets done at all
Caption: in fact we were talking about that last
Caption: night
Caption: but here's the thing brains they lie
Caption: right brains lies we heard in the
Caption: beginning of my talk brains lie and the
Caption: more rigid our beliefs are
Caption: the more distracted we are the more our
Caption: brains are going to lie and if you talk
Caption: to police
Caption: at a scene they will say that eyewitness
Caption: accounts are not accurate
Caption: they can interview
Caption: 20 different people who are all right
Caption: there and you're going to get 20
Caption: different
Caption: answers because again there's 7.9
Caption: billion different ways to process those
Caption: data and that information right so for
Caption: example
Caption: our brains can create false memories if
Caption: you are a person who struggles with
Caption: connecting with others and i mean
Caption: i mean this is a real thing for a lot of
Caption: people
Caption: they deeply want connection and crave
Caption: connection but are unable to for
Caption: whatever reason
Caption: find it
Caption: maybe you're sitting at home and you're
Caption: thinking about that
Caption: maybe you start ruminating a little bit
Caption: maybe you start feeling a little bit
Caption: from a victim mindset
Caption: maybe
Caption: you start recalling past memories
Caption: through that victim mindset you can
Caption: actually create
Caption: false memories from that
Caption: and
Caption: that narrative starts to drive how you
Caption: operate that narrative starts to
Caption: really shift how you see the world and
Caption: create these false memories and you know
Caption: our brains are totally capable of this
Caption: in cases of extreme trauma even your
Caption: brain might dissociate from the memories
Caption: altogether
Caption: so here's a perfect example let's say
Caption: you went to go see the new avengers
Caption: movie i guess it's the doctor strange
Caption: one as i said the other one's gone um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you go to see the new adventures move
Caption: and you're like hey this is such a great
Caption: movie i love it you go with your friend
Caption: joy
Caption: and you're sitting there watching the
Caption: movie and you're eating your popcorn and
Caption: it's awesome and the movie's over and
Caption: two weeks later you're like hey walking
Caption: down the street hey joy what's up
Caption: you should go see that new avengers
Caption: movie i went to john with john to see it
Caption: a couple weeks ago and it was amazing we
Caption: had such a great time there were
Caption: explosions the whole multi-universe
Caption: thing i mean it was so awesome enjoy
Caption: sitting there going
Caption: you're kidding right
Caption: it was me
Caption: i was there i was there with you and
Caption: here's the thing it's not that you did
Caption: it on purpose right gosh i love joy love
Caption: john like we're all friends
Caption: no it's just that your focus
Caption: was on the movie itself and so your
Caption: brain just kind of
Caption: fills in the the friend spot i've
Caption: totally done this before by the way it's
Caption: it's it's not awesome um but
Caption: you you can you could totally create
Caption: these these false memories your brain is
Caption: is perfectly capable about that of that
Caption: interruptions i want to say a quick
Caption: thing about interruptions because we
Caption: have retroactive and proactive
Caption: interference and i use this as a tool so
Caption: interruptions i work from home i am a
Caption: consultant when my kids come running
Caption: into my office they go hey mom can i run
Caption: today i go just a minute
Caption: i give him one of those right because
Caption: interruptions are the number one reason
Caption: that we forget and it's the same thing
Caption: when we work in big open offices it's
Caption: the same thing when somebody runs in now
Caption: there's nothing wrong with this what
Caption: this does is it gives you a pause to
Caption: finish up the email to finish up the
Caption: thing to
Caption: finish up the text thread hold on get in
Caption: line you're number three let me just
Caption: wrap these up right
Caption: in fact if you communicate with people
Caption: it's they're going to actually
Caption: appreciate and respect your boundaries
Caption: and they're not going to start running
Caption: into your office as much so um you could
Caption: you could just you know just one let me
Caption: just finish this up real quick i have a
Caption: thought let me finish it up because you
Caption: know what if you don't
Caption: it's gone
Caption: the interruption has to be significant
Caption: enough
Caption: in order for you to forget it though so
Caption: if it's really fast and my kids are just
Caption: coming in hey can i have a glass of milk
Caption: yes go ahead i can keep going no problem
Caption: i'm not going to drop the balls that i'm
Caption: juggling right however if they come in
Caption: and they go mom mom
Caption: mom
Caption: what
Caption: right
Caption: or who's had this uh hey can i ask you a
Caption: quick question real quick just just take
Caption: five minutes
Caption: nope
Caption: give him one of these right
Caption: just a moment let me finish this thought
Caption: let me finish this email it's gonna be a
Caption: really powerful tool and then you're not
Caption: going to lose that because interruptions
Caption: are the number one reason why we forget
Caption: take the look here look at this
Caption: what you see
Caption: is not always what you get
Caption: what you see is not always what you get
Caption: remember what i said eyewitness accounts
Caption: are not accurate they are not dependable
Caption: and if you ask 20 different people at a
Caption: scene you're going to get 20 different
Caption: answers this has been proved over and
Caption: over again replicated in laboratories
Caption: and research all over the planet that we
Caption: cannot always trust our memories because
Caption: brains lie so how can we improve our
Caption: memory it's totally possible we can
Caption: improve our memory we can improve our
Caption: capacity for learning and we can improve
Caption: our ability to encode store and retrieve
Caption: data this is how we do it we used to
Caption: think
Caption: that our brains were so much more
Caption: limited
Caption: eight nine ten years ago we didn't know
Caption: anything about the brain we used to say
Caption: you can't teach an old dog new tricks
Caption: who said that before
Caption: stop saying that it's not true
Caption: in fact you can teach an old dog new
Caption: tricks in fact you can start creating
Caption: neuro neural pathways as early as five
Caption: to six hours your brain will start
Caption: rewiring
Caption: it's pretty cool if the stimulus is
Caption: strong enough or repetitive enough
Caption: we can rewire our brain i know this i am
Caption: living proof of this as somebody who has
Caption: overcome trauma as somebody who at one
Caption: point was even catatonic for nine days
Caption: straight i did not speak
Caption: these are the ways that i have learned
Caption: to improve my brain performance and i
Caption: use it with my mentees my consultants my
Caption: coaching clients
Caption: everybody and it's really really cool so
Caption: this is neuroplasticity in action right
Caption: so if we strengthen that neural pathway
Caption: and we stimulate it over and over and
Caption: over again then we start to learn things
Caption: if the stimulus is strong enough or
Caption: repetitive enough it will stick
Caption: also
Caption: if we stop the stimulus
Caption: those neural pathways will dissolve
Caption: right
Caption: so think about it it makes sense that
Caption: just reading a book about emotional
Caption: intelligence or memory it's not going to
Caption: instantly improve you have to actually
Caption: practice these things over and over and
Caption: over again or the stimulus has to be
Caption: strong enough ladies and gentlemen
Caption: imagine teeny tiny little christina i
Caption: take you back
Caption: you know 40 some years ago crawling
Caption: around the floor of my grandmother's
Caption: house and in the u.s we have um we have
Caption: 110 volts but you know what this this i
Caption: i think you get the picture we are uh
Caption: looking at me crawling around my
Caption: grandmother's house and i pick up one of
Caption: those metal hairpins
Caption: and it happens to be the perfect size
Caption: for
Caption: crying crying oh my gosh
Caption: it bit me
Caption: it bit me right my mom had no idea what
Caption: bitter because we didn't have dogs we
Caption: didn't like what was it what bit her i
Caption: had no no
Caption: it bit me and then she realized that i'd
Caption: stick the bobby pin into
Caption: the socket how many times do you think i
Caption: stimulated that narrow pathway in my
Caption: life
Caption: once
Caption: once that was all that was needed for me
Caption: to learn the lesson if the stimulus is
Caption: strong enough or repetitive enough
Caption: you will
Caption: remember it and also neuroplasticity
Caption: just as we will remember it we can
Caption: forget it so my french teacher used to
Caption: say if you don't use it
Caption: you lose it
Caption: that's why the only thing i can say in
Caption: french is escotu uncravat
Caption: are you a thai
Caption: it's completely useless i don't know
Caption: three years of french it's unbelievable
Caption: and so we we went through the different
Caption: kinds of
Caption: memory subsystems we we talked about the
Caption: the value of neuroplasticity we talked
Caption: about how
Caption: memories can be false let's talk a
Caption: little bit about how we can process our
Caption: memories
Caption: we have shallow processing superficial
Caption: or deep where we have that purpose
Caption: attached to the data when we have
Caption: something that's meaningful to us now
Caption: remember there are 7.9 billion different
Caption: ways to do this and that means
Caption: introverts and extroverts are going to
Caption: respond to the same stimuli in a
Caption: different way
Caption: if you are in teams we need to
Caption: understand this and we need to take this
Caption: into consideration uh devnekema put up a
Caption: really great twitter post that she said
Caption: i could use as i was putting as i was
Caption: putting my talk together front load the
Caption: data
Caption: front load me with information give me
Caption: time to process and respond i'm not an
Caption: on the spot thinker but give me time
Caption: to be thoughtful and it's worth the wait
Caption: give me reference material make
Caption: asynchronous collaboration possible my
Caption: brain's not always lit up and ready for
Caption: output
Caption: allow me to communicate in text that's a
Caption: big one for me that's a really big one
Caption: for me because is anybody else really
Caption: good like you go home and like oh i
Caption: should have totally said this
Caption: oh that's smart ass i should have gave
Caption: him that dig and i would have really
Caption: right
Caption: oh i had the perfect response four days
Caption: later like the other person's not even
Caption: thinking about the conversation anymore
Caption: you know
Caption: real-time meetings are allowed to
Caption: process at once and i'm already short on
Caption: working memory i'm probably bored and
Caption: it's taking everything i have just to
Caption: stay focused and listen for
Caption: understanding this is especially true
Caption: during covid times here is a summary of
Caption: what devnekema has to say
Caption: understanding this it helps us support
Caption: everyone
Caption: on the team so that everyone can perform
Caption: better on the job if you are going to
Caption: come right out of the gate and be like
Caption: hey everybody all right let's go let's
Caption: get this meeting started right
Caption: extroverts are gonna go yeah let's go
Caption: this is awesome
Caption: i got ideas we're gonna start talking
Caption: over each other oh i got some creative
Caption: things let's go and all of the
Caption: introverts are gonna go
Caption: i guess it's gonna be one of those
Caption: meetings again
Caption: they're going to check out
Caption: they're going to sit back
Caption: and quietly resent you
Caption: and they're gonna wait for the big
Caption: moment two months later
Caption: when the poop hits the fan
Caption: and they're gonna say
Caption: i told you so
Caption: i told you two months ago
Caption: because they respond to the same exact
Caption: stimuli in different ways and we need to
Caption: understand this and this is why we have
Caption: to have all types of communication and
Caption: and facilitation during during our
Caption: meeting so
Caption: let's talk about encoding memories
Caption: ways that we encode
Caption: our memories
Caption: our focus right you train your brain to
Caption: recognize patterns for example you might
Caption: want to think about
Caption: trying to recognize somebody in a happy
Caption: cheerful moment and then the next day
Caption: two happy cheerful moments and then the
Caption: next day three happy cheerful moments
Caption: and then the next day four happy
Caption: cheerful moments because you know what
Caption: we are really good at finding the not so
Caption: good moments we don't need that that's
Caption: already implicit in our brain looking
Caption: and scanning for threats so think about
Caption: what your focus is remember the popcorn
Caption: eating
Caption: while watching the movie and eating
Caption: popcorn was your friend and then you're
Caption: like oh sorry joy um but what's your
Caption: focus
Caption: next you can also train your brain um
Caption: with a slow and low
Caption: oh
Caption: let's try it right now right slow and
Caption: low
Caption: so these small intentional changes
Caption: that's how big changes are made and when
Caption: we have a relaxed nervous system we are
Caption: going to be able to take in information
Caption: a whole lot better we can create our own
Caption: opportunities we can create our own
Caption: luck
Caption: we can improve our encoding
Caption: through a technique
Caption: that's called the memory card technique
Caption: i'm from las vegas we love to play cards
Caption: in vegas so you take some cards you lay
Caption: them all out and you can try to remember
Caption: them you can do things like try to
Caption: remember the order of the 52 deck of
Caption: cards you can do things like try to
Caption: remember all of the cards that have a
Caption: white background you can remember all of
Caption: the black cards all of the red cards and
Caption: as you do this over and over and over
Caption: again what you're doing is you're
Caption: training
Caption: your brain to encode data better and
Caption: faster
Caption: you can also do this through action this
Caption: boosts our episodic memory encoding
Caption: because it releases noradrenaline and so
Caption: if you've got a wobbly kid like me
Caption: right
Caption: when they're studying give them a wobble
Caption: cushion
Caption: because they're going to wiggle at
Caption: school
Caption: and so we'll this is how we get a lot of
Caption: like active learning right and and
Caption: different types of seats in classrooms
Caption: that the teachers these days uh are
Caption: always advocating for right a more
Caption: experiential active learning environment
Caption: is going to be a lot more helpful for
Caption: many learners here's a new one this is
Caption: in you can improve your coding by the
Caption: shoot the thumb technique who has heard
Caption: of this one shoot the thumb technique is
Caption: awesome and i'm gonna really embarrass
Caption: myself okay here we go uh shoot the
Caption: thumb technique you gotta shoot
Caption: your thumb
Caption: here we go all right i got it okay i'm
Caption: gonna shoot my thumb all right so you
Caption: shoot your thumb
Caption: while you are holding on to a memory and
Caption: the cool part about this is you get
Caption: bilateral stimulation of both
Caption: hemispheres of your brain and as this
Caption: information goes across your brain by
Caption: lateral across your hemispheres you are
Caption: oh look i'm talking okay
Caption: you can
Caption: have other data transfer across those
Caption: neural pathways it's not just that one
Caption: memory that's held and so it's a really
Caption: effective teaching strategy um
Caption: for for helping to improve encoding
Caption: um
Caption: let's see
Caption: shoot the thumb transmitting data yes oh
Caption: spacing effect the spacing effect is one
Caption: that i use for my for my pub conf talks
Caption: any of my ignite talks those five
Caption: minutes super fast talk i did this with
Caption: my tedx talk when i did that one you can
Caption: um read your talk or your list
Caption: and then
Caption: say it out loud when you're saying it
Caption: out loud you're feeling your vocal cords
Caption: you're hearing yourself do it you're
Caption: feeling you're writing it on the paper
Caption: not just typing it out right and then
Caption: read your list again or you talk again
Caption: go to sleep you get take advantage of
Caption: that that memory consolidation technique
Caption: that we talked about earlier right
Caption: remember and then when you wake up and
Caption: you repeat it the next day you're going
Caption: to significantly remember that
Caption: information this is a very very
Caption: effective technique
Caption: the other thing you can do is relax you
Caption: can improve your memory recording by
Caption: encoding by relaxing again this allows
Caption: the neurotransmitter vasopressin um to
Caption: be released and that makes us much more
Caption: open to receiving
Caption: information right so you can take a nice
Caption: big breath and you can relax so here is
Caption: a summary of how we can improve in
Caption: coding if you just take one of these
Caption: techniques and practice it every single
Caption: day for three months i promise you you
Caption: will improve your memory encoding
Caption: let's talk about storing our memories
Caption: we can use our senses sight sound smell
Caption: touch taste we have a sense of agency we
Caption: have a sense of blushing a sense of
Caption: hunger
Caption: a sense of time
Caption: the more that we can
Caption: incorporate those the more we're going
Caption: to remember it right so for example
Caption: think about you you have songs
Caption: that put you right back into that moment
Caption: right i think about uh
Caption: the rolling stones i think about i can't
Caption: get no satisfaction it takes me right
Caption: back to that time
Caption: like cruising in the car with the
Caption: windows down and the hair i was like so
Caption: young and free right like we all have
Caption: certain songs
Caption: that mean something to us because of the
Caption: way that we've stored those memories
Caption: here's the thing about senses
Caption: they can be tricked
Caption: right you add a shadow and suddenly it
Caption: creates an illusion so you can't depend
Caption: just on one of your senses
Caption: storytelling storytelling is another way
Caption: that we can really remember things our
Caption: as humans we love stories we love
Caption: stories i grew up in the midwest on the
Caption: shores of lake superior and my uncles
Caption: they used to tell the grandest stories
Caption: of that fish they caught
Caption: and every time they told the story the
Caption: the fish would get a little bit bigger
Caption: and a little bit bigger and a little bit
Caption: bigger and before you know it'd be like
Caption: hey
Caption: remember that time when you caught that
Caption: big fish yeah and then everybody knows
Caption: the story and we've all heard it so many
Caption: times so storytelling is another way to
Caption: help with your memory storage our
Caption: hippocampus is the way
Caption: is the place in our brain that stores it
Caption: and of course you know any of that
Caption: bilateral
Caption: thinking
Caption: is going to help any of that bilateral
Caption: stuff because what we know is that our
Caption: brains store things in chunks we love
Caption: chunks this is why we do things like uh
Caption: we do phone numbers who's done this
Caption: before
Caption: okay yeah let's let's trade numbers cool
Caption: all right yeah all right you get your
Caption: paper out
Caption: you get your pen you're ready to go okay
Caption: go ahead i'm i'm ready all right it's
Caption: 172
Caption: 2 2 2
Caption: 21 20 wait wait wait wait wait okay no
Caption: your phone number yeah that is my phone
Caption: number okay it's it's it's
Caption: 1722
Caption: [Music]
Caption: and then we're going to do oh 15 no just
Caption: give it to me like a human and not a
Caption: psychopath okay would that be all right
Caption: with you listen it's the cadence it's
Caption: the tone we like to chunk data it's one
Caption: seven zero two two two two one five one
Caption: five everybody knows
Caption: you like the chunks right we like chunks
Caption: of data and so that is how you can
Caption: improve your memory storage some basic
Caption: influencing factors and so we could do
Caption: things like uh meditate
Caption: right i meditated this morning sat down
Caption: and did a little
Caption: just before we got on because i'd like
Caption: to be nice and relaxed it's going to
Caption: help us improve our learning our our
Caption: capacity for empathy
Caption: and our memory after just eight
Caption: weeks of meditating even if you've never
Caption: even meditated before our brains will
Caption: have more gray matter and development in
Caption: those areas the other thing that we can
Caption: do
Caption: is get in touch with our feelings
Caption: if we get in touch with our feelings and
Caption: our emotions we're going to remember
Caption: more remember emotions are what drive
Caption: that narrative and so that is going to
Caption: uh
Caption: have a positive or it can have a
Caption: negative right effect on inhib
Caption: inhibiting or
Caption: prohibiting those neurotransmitters to
Caption: accurate activate parts of our brain so
Caption: taken to the extreme if you're too
Caption: emotional
Caption: then you might need to work a little bit
Caption: on your your psychological boundaries
Caption: with people right so get in touch with
Caption: your feelings
Caption: here's the other thing you can do is
Caption: association for example putting on your
Caption: favorite hoodie or or or attaching that
Caption: new information to something that's
Caption: already in there i do a workshop about
Caption: this where we actually do practice
Caption: things and we build a memory palace and
Caption: i show you exactly how to associate
Caption: certain memories with certain things in
Caption: in that's already being retained
Caption: the other thing we can do is we can
Caption: create chaos and you can break habits
Caption: where you're not really actually
Caption: uh they're not actually serving you
Caption: anymore instead you know sometimes we
Caption: just have information in there and we
Caption: just do it just because so there's the
Caption: the story of the the thanksgiving dinner
Caption: or the christmas dinner and the mom is
Caption: preparing it she's showing her daughter
Caption: how to how to make the ham and how to
Caption: cook it okay cool so she takes it she
Caption: puts all the seasonings on it and she
Caption: she sets it down and she whacks it in
Caption: half and she puts it in two pans and
Caption: then she puts it in the oven
Caption: the daughter goes
Caption: that's great mama why do we whack it in
Caption: half like what's she i don't know that's
Caption: just the recipe that's how our family
Caption: does it that's what grandma always said
Caption: and she goes to grandma and she says hey
Caption: how come we cut the ham in half what's
Caption: what and she said oh well we just never
Caption: had a pan big enough so yes
Caption: so think about why you're doing things
Caption: don't just put things onto autopilot
Caption: over and over again we can improve our
Caption: storage through repetition remember if
Caption: the stimulus is strong enough or
Caption: repetitive enough
Caption: right you can strengthen those neural
Caption: pathways you get more protein synthesis
Caption: the myelinated sheaths get bigger
Caption: we get more bundles more narrow pathways
Caption: in fact um through
Caption: that uh memory subsystem and so
Caption: it's estimated in marketing and
Caption: advertising in my world that somebody
Caption: needs to see something 21 times before
Caption: it before it sticks into our skulls and
Caption: so you know we're exposed to that same
Caption: messaging over and over and over again
Caption: you could see how this would be positive
Caption: you could see also how this might be be
Caption: harmful as well
Caption: we can improve storage by better
Caption: documentation we see this in tech right
Caption: we can make
Caption: documentation about why choices are made
Caption: and also why not choices were made
Caption: because if we right now
Caption: say we're not this isn't going to work
Caption: for us if we write why
Caption: two years down the road funding might
Caption: become available right so maybe we can
Caption: change that decision and it's documented
Caption: right there instead of everybody going
Caption: hmm now why did we do this why didn't we
Caption: do that i'm not sure
Caption: the project manager's gone sales team is
Caption: long gone and nobody really understands
Caption: why those those
Caption: choices and decisions were made we can
Caption: also improve our storage by facilitating
Caption: our meetings better remember
Caption: somebody
Caption: if they bring an idea to the table for
Caption: example and then two months later
Caption: somebody brings up that same idea they
Caption: go hey let's do this
Caption: yeah i think that was a great idea that
Caption: was a great idea two months ago when i
Caption: brought it up
Caption: but your focus wasn't on the who
Caption: because instead you were focused on on
Caption: the what so we can improve storage by
Caption: you know having better facilitated
Caption: meetings
Caption: and the last thing for improving storage
Caption: i must mention is the von restore for
Caption: effect this
Caption: is the things that are unique are going
Caption: to stand out and be remembered the most
Caption: so i worked in a hotel during my uh
Caption: college years in the summer and there
Caption: was a police officer there with his dog
Caption: partner and they were they were training
Caption: and he was staying in the hotel and
Caption: he and another officer were sitting
Caption: there in the lobby one night and we were
Caption: all talking and they were making fun of
Caption: me because they're like oh yeah your
Caption: white car
Caption: you better stop speeding because i i see
Caption: white cars better right and the other
Caption: police officer he was like no i actually
Caption: see red cars better because they stand
Caption: out to me more and so he gave more
Caption: tickets to to cars that were red cars as
Caption: opposed to any other color of cars and
Caption: and that's the
Caption: restore for effect so we can take
Caption: advantage of things that maybe
Caption: are a little bit more unique and they're
Caption: you're going to uniquely stand out
Caption: here is
Caption: a summary of that
Caption: and so the last one
Caption: i want to talk about how we retrieve our
Caption: memories and so um something that
Caption: influences uh that you know is tolving
Caption: he's the one who
Caption: he proposed that that forgetting
Caption: oftentimes is just a matter of memory
Caption: retrieval and so i think this was
Caption: 1983 yeah so this is when like um you
Caption: have that actor's name on the tip of
Caption: your tongue
Caption: and it's right there you know he's that
Caption: guy with the head the two worms he was
Caption: in that show with the with the person
Caption: right that's that's what the he's
Caption: referring to when we start talking about
Caption: memory retrieval and so another example
Caption: i do this i walk into my kitchen and i
Caption: go
Caption: hmm
Caption: what the hell come in here floral what
Caption: am i right and so what do we do we
Caption: backtrack we associate what we were
Caption: thinking and and how
Caption: so we can retrieve those memories give
Caption: it a cue give it a prompt and then we
Caption: can move forward so one way that we can
Caption: improve our memory retrieval is we can
Caption: use the same method
Caption: so different cues help us manage our
Caption: mindset and so uh we can improve our
Caption: memory retrieval by matching and
Caption: encoding uh the the matching the
Caption: encoding and the retrieval cues right
Caption: and if you use that same method every
Caption: single time like sometimes people will
Caption: say all right i use the same method for
Caption: creating a password
Caption: then it helps you remember the password
Caption: without even having to remember 4 000
Caption: passwords all the time and it also helps
Caption: you as you change those passwords right
Caption: you can also do intentional recall your
Caption: mood and other biases you know there
Caption: whatever is in that moment they're gonna
Caption: influence
Caption: the information that you recall so if
Caption: you want to intro improve your memory
Caption: retrieval
Caption: consider that mindset that you're that
Caption: you're in and then you know move forward
Caption: with intentional recall intentional
Caption: recall is then how we teach that
Caption: information to people
Caption: right if we
Caption: feed it back to somebody this is what i
Caption: learned then we are going to be much
Caption: more
Caption: able to retrieve memories in the future
Caption: we're training our brain to think that
Caption: way so consider maybe how the
Caption: information could be applied to your
Caption: work that you've learned in the
Caption: conference this uh this afternoon right
Caption: think about um
Caption: how
Caption: maybe
Caption: you are going to long-term store
Caption: something through association that's
Caption: also going to help imprint it into those
Caption: neural pathways
Caption: the other thing you could do is stay
Caption: healthy surprisingly or not
Caption: unsurprisingly right sleep
Caption: eating safety
Caption: discomfort stress these things really
Caption: affect your memory retrieval and then
Caption: the last one is to observe mindlessness
Caption: right memories they can be malleable and
Caption: so it's really important to to bring
Caption: your observation skills to the table
Caption: maybe you want to take a different route
Caption: to work or a different route home and
Caption: just observe the things around you
Caption: instead of normally maybe you drive and
Caption: you arrive at your destination and you
Caption: go hmm i didn't really
Caption: i guess i was kind of on autopilot right
Caption: you kind of dissociate from the
Caption: experience and so maybe it's time to
Caption: sharpen the edges of your foggy mind in
Caption: some of those places so take a look here
Caption: this is the ways that we can improve our
Caption: memory retrieval
Caption: the methodology
Caption: managing your mindset intentional
Caption: recalls staying healthy and observing
Caption: mindlessness so
Caption: those are the ways you can improve
Caption: retrieval
Caption: as you go through the rest of the
Caption: conference
Caption: i want you to think about these
Caption: questions okay i want you to think about
Caption: what you are remembering from the talks
Caption: that you're seeing is there a pattern
Caption: of the things that you notice
Caption: are you sticking with certain topics are
Caption: you sticking with certain speakers um
Caption: why
Caption: compare your notes and foci i want you
Caption: to talk to somebody else with
Caption: intentional recall ask them what were
Caption: they focusing on what were you focusing
Caption: on why and teach them oh this is what i
Caption: learned out of this talk from this
Caption: speaker what did you learn when we have
Caption: that it's going to help us remember the
Caption: content more
Caption: what surface processing did you use the
Caption: shallow processing what deep processing
Caption: maybe there were things that were more
Caption: meaningful and had more purpose to you
Caption: right
Caption: what distractions occurred
Caption: you'd be wise to turn off your
Caption: notifications while you're in in speaker
Caption: rooms and trying to pay attention so
Caption: you're not having all these different
Caption: distractions pop up right
Caption: so memory can be a very tricky thing and
Caption: if nothing else today i would like you
Caption: to remember this here's it's the big
Caption: secret that
Caption: everybody's so worried about finding out
Caption: and that's you know we all google the
Caption: things
Caption: we all google the things right and we
Caption: all forget and as we've learned today
Caption: memories can be faulty they can create
Caption: false memories we can
Caption: get stuck and not be able to retrieve
Caption: the the data that we already know and
Caption: you don't have to memorize all the
Caption: things having the ability to think think
Caption: creatively through a solution that's
Caption: where our strength lies and each of us
Caption: puts our own unique creative way of
Caption: approaching the solution to a client's
Caption: problem and you know it doesn't matter
Caption: if we have to use the googles right to
Caption: look up how to do things and
Caption: having all of these coding tests and and
Caption: only one memory subsystem to test you
Caption: know i just really don't think that it's
Caption: it's effective and the same thing goes
Caption: with our kids teaching them to just
Caption: blindly follow things and memorize
Caption: things without a purpose it doesn't make
Caption: sense
Caption: it stifles their creativity and they
Caption: lose the ability to make informed
Caption: choices
Caption: so as i stand in front of you today
Caption: i encourage you all
Caption: job seekers hiring managers parents and
Caption: i even want to appeal to the little
Caption: inner child inside of all of us
Caption: how well that we remember something
Caption: is not what defines our intellect it's
Caption: how we apply that information that's
Caption: what matters with empathy with healthy
Caption: boundaries with creativity and with
Caption: collaboration we all grow together
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: and one more thing i wanted to ask if
Caption: anybody remembers if i was wearing a
Caption: sweater at the beginning of my talk
Caption: or glasses
Caption: or a scarf
Caption: or a ponytail at all
Caption: it's it's important i think to kind of
Caption: remember what our focus is on and what
Caption: we are taking away from all of these
Caption: talks because every single person is
Caption: going to get something different
Caption: out of our talks today
Caption: and it's going to be a missed
Caption: opportunity if you aren't able to
Caption: challenge each other and to share that
Caption: information together so thank you very
Caption: much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: all right thank you
Caption: thank you christina
Caption: uh
Caption: people have already worked out that
Caption: there are sessions starting soon there
Caption: are more sessions starting we will start
Caption: a little bit later to account for the
Caption: fact that people have to make their way
Caption: there
Caption: so i'm assuming everyone knows where
Caption: they're going
Caption: thank you
Caption: you need a professional bodyguard
Caption: delivered to your door in less than half
Caption: an hour you've got it buddy but without
Caption: an app ain't no bodyguard getting
Caption: delivered nowhere so where are we with
Caption: that uh the app is almost ready uh we
Caption: just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: canada needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: ah
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top line
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in
Caption: the it industry in general
Caption: top run is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: good morning everyone thank you for
Caption: joining us here in quakka
Caption: we're ready to kick off with our first
Caption: talk after the keynote uh so we have for
Caption: our first speaker here we have cornell
Caption: stain
Caption: corner is a service and experience
Caption: designer that loves creating clarity
Caption: through research and experimenting to
Caption: bring products to life
Caption: it is his first time speaking at ddd so
Caption: he's very excited please be very kind
Caption: and i'll hand you over to cornell to
Caption: talk about feature trees
Caption: yeah thank you very much
Caption: so i've never used one of these i call
Caption: them earlier like a beyonce mic and
Caption: because my name is cornell it's like a
Caption: corianse mic so we're just gonna roll
Caption: with it so yeah i'm just gonna just jump
Caption: straight in so i want to talk to you
Caption: today about feature trees and that's
Caption: what this entire talk is about before we
Caption: do and we just mentioned um this is my
Caption: first time speaking at ddd last year was
Caption: my first time attending ddd so
Caption: me being here is yeah it's just
Caption: absolutely crazy for me um the sponsors
Caption: made this day um possible and it's yeah
Caption: this knowledge community we have here in
Caption: perth it's just absolutely amazing so
Caption: thanks for learning with me i'm learning
Caption: about this topic as well so yeah just
Caption: again i'm going to say this a few times
Caption: thank you for allowing me to share today
Caption: so i have a bone to pick with you
Caption: you did this you voted for this talk so
Caption: you know like why are we here that kind
Caption: of thing so this is in place of the
Caption: agenda slide so what's all this then so
Caption: today i want to take you through first
Caption: of all what is a feature tree
Caption: why i use it in my workflow when i'm
Caption: designing and building products
Caption: and why sort of a central artifact for
Caption: teams to rally around and then also i'm
Caption: going to share some tips and tricks from
Caption: how you create them and you'll also hear
Caption: today a few cornellisms i don't write
Caption: scripts for my talks it's just
Caption: incompatible with my nerves so i'm just
Caption: gonna wiggle it but within reason of
Caption: course so let's jump right in
Caption: for me the gold standard of a feature
Caption: tree is that of up so up is a digital
Caption: bank quick show of hands anyone with up
Caption: yeah they're pretty cool i probably
Caption: should change to them so let's imagine
Caption: up that app in your pocket that is the
Caption: product i'm going to use a lot of sort
Caption: of agile product service design kind of
Caption: language here today so if you hear some
Caption: of that language that's where that comes
Caption: from but up that is the product the
Caption: product is the tree the thing that your
Caption: users see so that's the end goal
Caption: visualizing the product
Caption: next up we've got a set of features
Caption: that's the functionality everything
Caption: that's built that the user can interact
Caption: with what's built they sum to the tree
Caption: so that's where the roots come from the
Caption: tree pretty simple concept
Caption: and then we go into the detail of a
Caption: specific feature
Caption: so here we've got for example the
Caption: feature of a payment and on the bottom
Caption: right you'll see a key so you've got
Caption: stuff like what's being built or what's
Caption: in progress what have we already done
Caption: what's coming up or what have we pruned
Caption: what are we not building sometimes it's
Caption: nice to visualize that so for example in
Caption: this very specific example we've got
Caption: making a payment of course it's a
Caption: payment app you want to be able to make
Caption: a payment what's next oh you might want
Caption: to schedule the payment and then what's
Caption: next you might want to do multiple of
Caption: those and you want them to recur so
Caption: that's just a way for users and whoever
Caption: interacts with this feature tree to go
Caption: that's a pretty simple way of me
Caption: understanding what are all the things i
Caption: can do in this product and you stagger
Caption: those features and you'll see some of
Caption: them connect they can get pretty curly
Caption: pretty quickly but it's it's intended to
Caption: be a simple communication artifact
Caption: so if we zoom all the way out you'll see
Caption: this long complicated map of features if
Caption: you will so divided by columns sometimes
Caption: even by
Caption: priority or by rows the order in which
Caption: it's been delivered but it may look like
Caption: a really sophisticated complicated map
Caption: and you might think this is a bank it's
Caption: a public-facing product why are they
Caption: making this sort of that transparent i
Caption: think it's pretty cool for products to
Caption: be so radically out there and say these
Caption: are the things i've done so it firstly
Caption: allows people to navigate that map and
Caption: see these are all the cool things i can
Caption: do for example you want the api to hook
Caption: in to get all your payment data you want
Caption: to do some fancy graphs with it you can
Caption: do that because it's lower down on the
Caption: feature tree and you can see that that's
Caption: only for some obsessive people not like
Caption: me but it can also see what's up next
Caption: for example
Caption: so
Caption: having that accountability publishing
Caption: this online this is a fully interactive
Caption: website super high fidelity i'm not here
Caption: today to tell you this is what we're
Caption: aspiring to when we're doing feature
Caption: trees but it exposes a concept to me at
Caption: least
Caption: pretty beautifully so if you're thinking
Caption: this is super complicated it's very
Caption: messy it's a lot of detail it's actually
Caption: in my
Caption: estimation just supposed to be a really
Caption: well organized list so i want to play a
Caption: quick game
Caption: buy a show of hands a common list we all
Caption: use which is our shopping lists right
Caption: so
Caption: it's a game so put your hand up for me
Caption: if you before you go grocery shopping if
Caption: you even make a list
Caption: okay good you're all done just go rock
Caption: up then opportunistic please keep your
Caption: hands up for me
Caption: so now keep your hand up for me if you
Caption: organize that list somehow
Caption: a few hands might drop okay we got some
Caption: people they love it okay now next
Caption: question keep your hand up again for me
Caption: if you organize that list by the floor
Caption: plan of your favorite grocery store
Caption: okay here we go okay so you kind of
Caption: using your shopping list as a bit of a
Caption: map right so that helps you navigate
Caption: your groceries or final question for now
Caption: then i can let you put your arms down so
Caption: keep your hands up again and one or two
Caption: people might actually put their hands up
Caption: again
Caption: keep your hands up if you organize your
Caption: shopping list deliberately the keyword
Caption: here is deliberately so that it can be
Caption: used in any grocery store
Caption: telstra purple's hiring so come chat to
Caption: us afterwards that'll be great no so the
Caption: only concept i wanted to explore there
Caption: is you might then be using your shopping
Caption: list as a compass something that allows
Caption: you to navigate or respond to the
Caption: environment you're in so we're going to
Caption: live a little bit in metaphor territory
Caption: what is a feature tree is it a map is it
Caption: a compass i'm here to tell you why not
Caption: both
Caption: so typically when we see a feature tree
Caption: a list a very simple well organized list
Caption: i see one of those old school maps that
Caption: you fold out it's a static fixed
Caption: environment you think at least at that
Caption: point in time you know your environment
Caption: that is just your articulation i guess
Caption: of what we know now and what we've built
Caption: what we're currently building and what's
Caption: up next sometimes even just arriving at
Caption: that is sort of the destination that
Caption: process
Caption: but is it a compass how does a feature
Caption: tree act as a compass to help us
Caption: navigate the the colorful you know seas
Caption: or world that is navigating this product
Caption: space and that is if you've got that
Caption: baseline that document that set up that
Caption: allows you to say right this is my
Caption: product these are the features these are
Caption: all the functionality that exists if for
Caption: example introducing new functionality
Caption: you've got that visual artifact that
Caption: allows you to negotiate a little bit if
Caption: i have this i won't be getting this or
Caption: that fits in here or these things relate
Caption: especially when there's multiple teams
Caption: communicating around for example a
Caption: product backlog and that you have that
Caption: summary piece that accompanies it so it
Caption: might sound a little bit like apologetic
Caption: this is not like the most crazy outer
Caption: topic ever but it's such a nice way of
Caption: just surfacing coming up for air from a
Caption: product backlog so i mentioned product
Caption: backlog let's look at one so this is a
Caption: common backlog what you don't have to do
Caption: today is
Caption: critique the user stories here you can i
Caption: didn't write them so i'll join you so
Caption: this is just an example of user stories
Caption: in a backlog that developers would
Caption: commonly use to build certain
Caption: functionality on the right this is the
Caption: product called jira i like the example
Caption: here because it at least visually color
Caption: codes all that green stories on the
Caption: right i think they relate to one another
Caption: and they form a feature set
Caption: you can't scroll here but i can so for
Caption: example when i scrolled down you can see
Caption: okay there's multiple stories here so
Caption: we're working on a piece of
Caption: functionality for that feature here here
Caption: so it does go into that space but
Caption: sometimes it's not as visual
Caption: so this is another deliberately sort of
Caption: small
Caption: screenshot here let's just for example
Caption: say that first
Caption: one to seven stories here if you
Caption: understand this product it's all in the
Caption: realm of like i get it it's maybe a
Caption: value on a page and when was it last
Caption: updated things like that so this back to
Caption: the shopping
Caption: experience is for example i'm in the
Caption: wolves in palmyra i'm there i just grab
Caption: a basket i know i need bread and eggs i
Caption: think i know what needs to happen story
Caption: one to seven all of a sudden shout out
Caption: to my partner jeff she calls me i've got
Caption: a basket by the way can you buy eight
Caption: watermelons for me and i'm like i don't
Caption: have
Caption: hashtag scoped for eight watermelons in
Caption: my basket it's gonna smash the bread
Caption: i'm wearing a mask i'm gonna sneeze
Caption: straight up a bad time no one likes that
Caption: kind of a surprise
Caption: if we had a feature tree you could say
Caption: for example that is a really high effort
Caption: or high value feature visualized that
Caption: way you're gonna run through a quick you
Caption: know quick fire of stories over here but
Caption: there is that big thing coming our way
Caption: that story in this example was just
Caption: casually create an ios version of the
Caption: app and we were like okay cool cool cool
Caption: um so here's another example i say does
Caption: it hurt yet i'm humoring designers
Caption: sometimes we're asked to just hand over
Caption: a um
Caption: all of the research we've done so just
Caption: quickly give me all the business
Caption: requirements and we'll build it
Caption: detail has a home i absolutely love
Caption: detail but this is not that
Caption: if you pull me into a meeting with no
Caption: notice what have you done where are we
Caption: at what are we building this does not
Caption: give you that so all i'm saying is this
Caption: has a place
Caption: especially when it comes to the
Caption: tactical
Caption: strategic or vision or system level
Caption: transformation that detail for me lives
Caption: all the way in the tactical don't you
Caption: dare just over discover things that are
Caption: three four five years away because it's
Caption: gonna go stale so what a feature tree
Caption: does really well for me is um support
Caption: this the detail that we've discovered
Caption: and then
Caption: it visualizes that neatly where it fits
Caption: in and it supports the delivery of the
Caption: backlog so it represents the work it's
Caption: the sum of what's in the backlog in a
Caption: more visual way
Caption: so that's kind of the theory bit over i
Caption: guess so introducing you to what it is
Caption: let's go into why i think it's awesome
Caption: it's good for me to give get a lay of
Caption: the land like who is here in the room so
Caption: i might ask you or online if my mom in
Caption: south africa is watching hello melinda
Caption: um so
Caption: we've got four groups here crudely
Caption: summarized right crudely summarized if
Caption: you're not in one of these groups pick
Caption: one but i just want a quick show of
Caption: hands so designers
Caption: my fan club over there thank you awesome
Caption: okay so developers
Caption: that could be data divs really well
Caption: represented awesome um product owners or
Caption: product people anyone in that space
Caption: awesome and then project stakeholders
Caption: whatever that means awesome colorful
Caption: okay so i'll try and skew towards the
Caption: dev side of things if my
Caption: you know abilities allow so i want to
Caption: take you through my experience of
Caption: exposing or introducing this as an
Caption: artifact to these four groups
Caption: what changes i brought about or what
Caption: kinds of problems does it solve i'll
Caption: also on the right of each of these
Caption: slides just show you some of the
Caption: examples that i've worked on
Caption: i may have had a direct hand in some of
Caption: them or my team the fan club over there
Caption: may have created some of it so if you've
Caption: got any questions yeah if you love them
Caption: let me know if you don't
Caption: so let's jump into why designers love it
Caption: you can all read the bullets as well so
Caption: i'll do some storytelling around the
Caption: bullets but the first thing we do is
Caption: often when we are introduced i work in a
Caption: consulting capacity so
Caption: when we're introduced to a new problem
Caption: you might go through some rapid research
Caption: on my favorite is the research has been
Caption: done can you just make it look pretty so
Caption: we might end up for example with a
Caption: pretty prototype it's clickable it's
Caption: real it feels good the designer smashed
Caption: it
Caption: but there's so much more value about
Caption: going through that process sincerely and
Caption: in depth you gain a lot of context so
Caption: the first bullet there is it allows us
Caption: to share the context far beyond just the
Caption: pretty pictures because the second we
Caption: asked some of the questions
Caption: is that system ready to give us the data
Caption: we think we need for that feature day
Caption: one no it's not okay is it still a
Caption: valuable problem to solve yes okay well
Caption: we might untangle the prototype ever so
Caption: slightly and that might be represented
Caption: by the order in which we organize our
Caption: thought so again pretty simple concept
Caption: but it is nice for us to at least then
Caption: go
Caption: if i just want to do the right thing for
Caption: the users and for the products owners
Caption: and stakeholders that kind of thing you
Caption: want to be able to at least organize
Caption: your thought in a way where you can
Caption: systematically feel like the goalposts
Caption: are not moving you're at least just
Caption: slowly summing to that experience
Caption: perfect example of when things change
Caption: you can adjust it allows you to find
Caption: discovery gaps so my favorite is go tada
Caption: i'm done and then a developer would be
Caption: like well
Caption: i
Caption: get you're close but not so have you
Caption: thought about that that way does this go
Caption: where does back go and all that stuff so
Caption: that's a really good example for me
Caption: where i could then go back and say
Caption: cool let me add that to my future tree
Caption: or story on that feature tree if you
Caption: will and go i'll go back and i'll go
Caption: do some discovery and lastly like i've
Caption: probably already mentioned it gives us a
Caption: bit of a seat at the strategy chats i'm
Caption: being lazy with the wording strategy
Caption: chats but when you've discovered stuff
Caption: you understand user problems
Caption: you might think that the road map that
Caption: was agreed to six months ago is still up
Caption: to date it's probably not it allows us
Caption: to give some input in that
Caption: reprioritization of work because we've
Caption: done some of that discovery
Caption: so from a development perspective should
Caption: be no surprise to you i'm not a
Caption: developer so i'll try but this is what
Caption: my colleagues at telstra purple have
Caption: mentioned it's helpful for so especially
Caption: when you're
Caption: let's say for example it's a really long
Caption: development gig it's a really
Caption: established product onboarding a new
Caption: team member it's awesome so the example
Caption: here on the right would be lots of
Caption: different features of a product i'm sure
Caption: you can put together who it's for and
Caption: what it is so let's assume some of those
Caption: features they could for example say you
Caption: see that feature you know the second one
Caption: from the left i've worked on that
Caption: feature all of these green dots i built
Caption: that with my own bare hands and my blood
Caption: sweat and tears and this is what i've
Caption: learned when i did that oh you're going
Caption: to join me working on that feature
Caption: fantastic ignore the rest for now but if
Caption: you ever encounter something go look for
Caption: it find it in it at least at the very
Caption: least it allows you to navigate a bit of
Caption: that uncertainty because i don't think a
Caption: product backlog if you want to run some
Caption: fancy report of all the stories that
Caption: were done where are the high story
Caption: pointers which are the ones that dragged
Caption: on six prints longer than it should have
Caption: that kind of drawbar in a backlog maybe
Caption: it doesn't give that story but at least
Caption: this
Caption: helps you to come up for air and tell
Caption: that story a little bit
Caption: so it visualizes the holistic scope and
Caption: progress
Caption: so we'll get into how we even get to
Caption: this point but again often taking a
Caption: backlog and trying organizing it in a
Caption: way that does conveniently over
Caption: summarize always use that word
Caption: conveniently because someone is just
Caption: just tell me what i need to know i'm
Caption: like there's so much detail so if the
Caption: point of getting here if your backlog is
Caption: in a bit of a state because sometimes it
Caption: is and again teams like things the way
Caption: that they like them so if you're
Caption: changing teams onboarded a new team
Caption: member and you want to sort of reflect
Caption: to how that team likes to work and
Caption: organize themselves
Caption: then if the backlog is a mess your
Caption: feature tree will be a mess but yeah
Caption: call me toxically positive but that's an
Caption: opportunity for a feature tree so you
Caption: can reorganize that work then so that
Caption: for the most bit
Caption: for the almost everyone working on this
Caption: product on the example of up if you want
Caption: to so so radically put yourself out
Caption: there and make it that ultimate
Caption: accountability of here's what i'm doing
Caption: it visualizes that and it just allows
Caption: you to say this is what i've done this
Caption: is what i'm doing and that's what's
Caption: coming up next
Caption: the last bullet here empowers autonomy
Caption: is a bit like what a designer feels like
Caption: but i've got input to give into the
Caption: order because users want this more than
Caption: what you think they wanted there or
Caption: months ago similar story here in that
Caption: if we've got a specific feature
Caption: especially things that are two or three
Caption: or four sprints ahead and we say this is
Caption: a bit of functionality that we want to
Caption: develop but a produ a product owner had
Caption: a brilliant idea overnight or promised
Caption: some functionality at a pub last night
Caption: whatever story it rings through then you
Caption: want to introduce new functionality
Caption: then or immediately a developer would
Caption: say for example with a feature tree
Caption: okay you see all of this functionality
Caption: we've got over here i don't think we've
Caption: got time or the technical resources for
Caption: example to get any of that if we
Caption: introduce that and it just facilitates
Caption: that needful conversation about always
Caption: you know keeping the what's next in
Caption: focus so that you can you can focus on
Caption: that while having a plan for what's to
Caption: come so that's why i like them in that
Caption: context as well
Caption: so let's keep the head there
Caption: why product owners love it they're not
Caption: not just product owners it's people
Caption: working on products in that product
Caption: sense in its broadest possible colorful
Caption: meaning
Caption: if it's multiple trees is it a feature
Caption: forest
Caption: who knows so this could be multiple
Caption: feature trees and what we do here for
Caption: example again not my project but it was
Caption: used to affect here more in the map
Caption: context let's just visualize what we're
Caption: doing
Caption: a big big stream of work with multiple
Caption: teams working on multiple things so it
Caption: can get complex quite quickly but what
Caption: we're trying to do is get a lay of
Caption: visualize it this is an online
Caption: whiteboarding tool doesn't always have
Caption: to be presentation ready if you will but
Caption: it doesn't even it can even be a
Caption: scribble but just have a visualization
Caption: of everything we're working on and
Caption: that's where the color coding here comes
Caption: in we've built all of this stuff
Caption: this is getting for example data from a
Caption: platform that we're retiring in six
Caption: months we're going to have holes here
Caption: and this is what's coming up and what
Caption: that also allows people to do for
Caption: example is budget cycles
Caption: love them or hate them but they exist so
Caption: how much cashola do you need for the
Caption: next 12 months okay cool let's do a very
Caption: cursory estimate i think we'll focus on
Caption: this section
Caption: let's see if we've got the right people
Caption: the right skill sets the right time
Caption: allotted and things like that and then
Caption: you can do an estimate on something like
Caption: this so if you're a product owner
Caption: working on multiple products think of a
Caption: way that at least we can dive into the
Caption: detail from here or come up for air and
Caption: at least depending on which direction in
Caption: your organization you kind of tell the
Caption: story of your product and then why
Caption: project people are again i refuse the
Caption: word stakeholders it sounds so clunky
Caption: but then here's me again cross
Caption: capabilities streams of work anyway so
Caption: cross capability streams of work um if
Caption: you've got multiple teams again with
Caption: multiple skill sets there might be a
Caption: team for example here in perth say if
Caption: we've got a team over east and they're
Caption: working on a piece of functionality
Caption: maybe their own team wants their own
Caption: backlog you might actually separate
Caption: different backlogs for things like this
Caption: but you're at least able to organize
Caption: work in the way that you want and then
Caption: visualize it accordingly so
Caption: very easily we could say that column on
Caption: the far right that's actually
Caption: you know the team in sydney that one is
Caption: a team in melbourne this is the birth
Caption: team for example you could do things
Caption: like that as well
Caption: i've mentioned the color coding a few
Caption: times now it's just a simple artifact
Caption: think of it as like a traffic sort of
Caption: light system
Caption: it sets expectations in a way as well in
Caption: public facing products so for example
Caption: there's a new piece of functionality we
Caption: want to get the marketing team involved
Caption: to celebrate the the launch of something
Caption: for example they need to know when they
Caption: need to get ready that kind of thing so
Caption: you could for example have ready to
Caption: launch and then that team could say okay
Caption: they'll change the color once their
Caption: things are in order but this is very
Caption: much focused on the development of the
Caption: product and what's live for a user today
Caption: and then a small underrated feature as
Caption: well you'll probably discover some other
Caption: ones as well but it can
Caption: link directly to a product backlog as
Caption: well i don't know how many organizations
Caption: allow the people to come in and leave
Caption: notes on user stories and stuff like
Caption: that depending on your culture depending
Caption: on where you are but people can always
Caption: ask questions especially if they've got
Caption: helpful input so that one little random
Caption: dot over there that looks interesting
Caption: what's that about you can just sort of
Caption: put brackets at the end put the user
Caption: story id they usually have numbers
Caption: hyperlink that you click on that it
Caption: opens
Caption: if you've not been blocked from the
Caption: project so it should open so
Caption: that's sort of how these different user
Caption: groups
Caption: have benefit from there you'll also see
Caption: one column there again not my specific
Caption: project or feature tree but in this
Caption: instance arriving at this complicated
Caption: feature tree was a great way of just
Caption: visualizing the sheer volume of work we
Caption: think we've committed to but the
Caption: spoilers none of this can always happen
Caption: before say august that year so there was
Caption: a column an entire feature where they
Caption: said if we want something that is
Caption: polished end-to-end vertically slices
Caption: got the full real piece of functionality
Caption: let's de-prioritize some functionality
Caption: on the right so that was my
Caption: understanding how this was of impact for
Caption: that specific product
Caption: when do we plant feature trees i love
Caption: these metaphors so you can either in a
Caption: consulting context often there's a need
Caption: for one so we we work with an existing
Caption: product again even the process of
Caption: onboarding an entirely new team to a
Caption: product they may want just to use it as
Caption: part of their intuition building phase
Caption: you know any two three four sprints
Caption: that's time you will need to build
Caption: intuition about a product spoilers make
Caption: a feature tree because you could
Caption: organize your own thought you can replay
Caption: your understanding to someone that's
Caption: been on the project for a long while
Caption: it's going to have to iterate a few
Caption: times but there's that magic point of
Caption: like oh okay we see it the same way and
Caption: that's really a good point where people
Caption: can start becoming autonomous in their
Caption: decisions and things like that
Caption: but spoilers is usually this at least
Caption: from some of our experiences that's why
Caption: i use the fire extinguisher on the right
Caption: i use the knife for me when you've done
Caption: a polished i mentioned before we've done
Caption: this polished prototype it looks
Caption: beautiful it's awesome now we need to
Caption: answer those difficult questions of how
Caption: do we make it real how do we cut pieces
Caption: of functionality and that's why i like
Caption: the knife so we call it story slicing so
Caption: let's go into the first example
Caption: of how you grow one when you're working
Caption: with an existing backlog so you've got
Caption: your backlog hopefully it might be a
Caption: tool like jira or azure devops you might
Caption: use like a kanban style thing like
Caption: trello for example if you're using this
Caption: in a non-product space just to organize
Caption: your shopping lists for example some of
Caption: you so um if you you take your list
Caption: whatever list you have it's probably in
Caption: a tool somewhere
Caption: command or control i export csv get it
Caption: in a workable format so now at least
Caption: you're not distracted by what it is you
Caption: just have a clean list of what it is
Caption: now you can probably make a decision do
Caption: you work in a physical copy or a digital
Caption: copy so there's lots of awesome digital
Caption: tools
Caption: if your team if you sense we're not
Caption: aligned we can't talk about the backlog
Caption: in the same ways and you cringe when
Caption: people think they mention the priorities
Caption: in a little bit of do this together
Caption: but do it in person so i would recommend
Caption: you know those nice 3m the ones with the
Caption: nice glue use
Caption: physical post-it notes and then
Caption: write one post-it note per user story
Caption: so you've got your backlog with a long
Caption: list of user stories i've seen six seven
Caption: eight hundred long story backlogs
Caption: you did this to yourself write it all
Caption: out okay so now we've got post-it notes
Caption: of all of our user stories
Caption: in the world of user research this is
Caption: activity we like to call card sorting
Caption: it's typically used to sort the
Caption: information architecture or the way that
Caption: users navigate it's just what people
Caption: commonly associate with for example
Caption: features or pages or things like that
Caption: and it's essentially like playing snap
Caption: with your insight so what you want to do
Caption: is i've got you just start sequentially
Caption: maybe even hand a couple of post-it
Caption: notes out to the team do the sort of in
Caption: a workshop format and say right you've
Caption: got a post-it note there read it out
Caption: that's that one you go next is it the
Caption: same or is it different if you're
Caption: working from your product backlog
Caption: sequentially first story to last it
Caption: might be clear in the beginning but it
Caption: might unravel towards the end so trick
Caption: shuffle them up and then start fresh so
Caption: we're not anchored by the thought that
Caption: went into it but if if it's good thought
Caption: keep it work from the top so just do
Caption: what's right for your team but over time
Caption: what's going to emerge are these
Caption: hopefully organic hopefully intuitive
Caption: groups
Caption: of
Caption: um sets of features and that's what can
Caption: start forming the headers of your
Caption: feature tree so my biggest tip i can
Caption: give you as well steal from what's real
Caption: yo
Caption: so you've got if it's an existing
Caption: product you can probably already
Caption: navigate through it so it's got a home
Caption: page it's got in the up example a
Caption: payments page an information section
Caption: it's got all of that already if you're
Caption: struggling to synthesize that's the word
Caption: we use to gather thought if you're
Caption: struggling to synthesize all of these
Caption: post-it notes into mass
Caption: sort of adopted or intuitive headings
Caption: just take from what you have it's
Caption: perfectly fine
Caption: if you're designing a more internal
Caption: facing product and it's a business
Caption: process like a
Caption: nifty little payroll chatbot or one of
Caption: those cool ideas people come up with all
Caption: the time you might just have steps to
Caption: your approval process just leverage
Caption: what's real start there and over time
Caption: allow your tree to
Caption: grow so we've got the next one
Caption: focus now specifically for example on
Caption: the pile of the green post-it notes
Caption: that's just an arbitrary visual example
Caption: but we've got a set this is a feature
Caption: we're focusing on that feature now is
Caption: the good time
Caption: to ask does this actually make sense so
Caption: we've got a feature let's use the up
Caption: example again payments
Caption: they may want to integrate in future
Caption: with more payment platforms add new
Caption: stories it's not detailed stories i'm
Caption: not talking about all of the requirement
Caption: gatherings i'm just mentioning a mental
Caption: placeholder for all the things you still
Caption: want to add to that feature because
Caption: that's a bit more representative of what
Caption: you want to do in that space and at the
Caption: same time if there's monkey business in
Caption: there just cut it just get rid of it
Caption: it's probably the hardest thing to do
Caption: for people to separate with just this
Caption: legacy things that every new team
Caption: there's just that bottom of the stale
Caption: bottom of the backlog just get rid of it
Caption: if you're not comfortable trashing it
Caption: completely put it in a section like
Caption: de-prioritized maybe there is not going
Caption: to be that investment that's going to
Caption: unlock a new platform that allows that
Caption: feature to then become prioritized hold
Caption: on to it especially if there is some
Caption: usable discovery that's been done on it
Caption: or prototypes or things like that hold
Caption: on to it
Caption: you can do that
Caption: again with your entire team present i
Caption: would highly recommend
Caption: at least representatives of all those
Caption: groups that i've mentioned before
Caption: because then we can start that
Caption: conversation but what it does it it
Caption: builds context of the content in the
Caption: backlog really nicely it could take a
Caption: bit of time if you've got a really
Caption: really big product and but stagger it
Caption: maybe have a focus session for each of
Caption: these features so you stagger them out
Caption: and lastly now pull it together simple
Caption: right easy so this is not a talk about
Caption: prioritization that's a whole separate
Caption: talk so how we go about prioritizing
Caption: stories but let's look at the output of
Caption: prioritization that is the order in
Caption: which we're doing things
Caption: per feature so that's where the order of
Caption: the feature street feature tree starts
Caption: coming in what are we doing first from a
Caption: specific feature organize that top to
Caption: bottom and then left to right on your
Caption: feature that could be hint onto the user
Caption: journey it could be hinged onto the
Caption: highest value features or the features
Caption: that have the earliest milestone date
Caption: whatever order makes sense for you so
Caption: we've got all of our green post-it notes
Caption: and we order them and all of our other
Caption: buckets everyone loves sort of a junk
Caption: drawer have an other bucket be kind to
Caption: yourself
Caption: when you're pulling this together that
Caption: little asterisk if you spotted it
Caption: that's the things to keep in mind so
Caption: lots of words on a slide here sorry not
Caption: sorry so the first thing to do is who is
Caption: your audience of your feature tree don't
Caption: be too ambitious because that puts
Caption: pressure of making something like this
Caption: i'll acknowledge that it is a bit of
Caption: manual effort to get started at first
Caption: this is 2022. who knows maybe it's the
Caption: next feature for them to work on saying
Caption: jira to have the ability if you sort
Caption: your stories right to automate something
Caption: like this wouldn't this be awesome so
Caption: we're going to look back at this talk
Caption: and be like oh that's the cassette tape
Caption: or the floppy disk of 2022. so but
Caption: decide who is the audience of your
Caption: feature tree in app's case they went
Caption: bold they said it's the public we want
Caption: to keep ourselves accountable to that
Caption: that's the kind of product centered or
Caption: cultured that we want to try for but if
Caption: you've got to leave a leave booking
Caption: chatbots you probably won't do that so
Caption: just start small be humble
Caption: be you know begin small
Caption: and then answer the next question is it
Caption: at the right level of detail
Caption: we've got on your feature tree typically
Caption: it's the product you might want to go
Caption: epics and then a list of features a
Caption: branch for each story or we've got even
Caption: a lower level of detail to a story could
Caption: be something like a task depending on
Caption: what structure if there's test steps you
Caption: might sometimes use as a task in your as
Caption: your backlog for example decide what's
Caption: right for the team
Caption: don't start too detailed we love detail
Caption: when we start something because we just
Caption: want that confidence that it is in there
Caption: but if we are engaged in the process
Caption: it's okay to drop some of the detail off
Caption: and just visualize it so then we need to
Caption: answer
Caption: what format is right designers in the
Caption: room don't do it in illustrator because
Caption: then you automatically become the owner
Caption: because you're the only one that can
Caption: edit it use a tool that is easily
Caption: editable so like
Caption: a mural of the world or i say myro you
Caption: say mirror or fig jam there's lots of
Caption: online whiteboarding tools that's
Caption: actually quite accessible to use it's
Caption: shareable with the url you can make it
Caption: sort of semi-public and you can just
Caption: change the post-it notes as they go
Caption: the last two is also related to one
Caption: another is who will own it you might
Caption: think that it's intuitive for a single
Caption: person to own it like a product owner
Caption: you own a product you know you own it
Caption: you update it it's a lot of work if you
Caption: not maintaining it so if it's just a map
Caption: if it's just a point in time document
Caption: you can probably go a bit detailed but
Caption: acknowledge that save it as a pdf don't
Caption: even tempt people to think it's quickly
Caption: editable because there is a lot of
Caption: detail on it i will acknowledge but if
Caption: it is something that you're embedding
Caption: for example in your agile ceremonies so
Caption: for example a common two-week sprint
Caption: structure at the end you might have a
Caption: bit of a showcase ta-da these are all
Caption: the stuff we did we thought we would do
Caption: we didn't get through it's at that point
Caption: in time if it's hopefully set up in a
Caption: format where you can just quickly change
Caption: the colors of the post-it notes maybe
Caption: once a month move the order if things
Caption: change but if we embed it in our agile
Caption: ceremonies it's a really nice way to
Caption: start a sprint showcase especially if
Caption: there are broader stakeholders in that
Caption: group i said the word so if there's
Caption: other people in the
Caption: showcase that might not have the lowest
Caption: level of detail oh so where are we on
Caption: the
Caption: chat bot and then you could say cool
Caption: we've started that for example visually
Caption: and then go into the more detail which
Caption: is
Caption: yeah sharing some of that so i'll speed
Caption: up a bit so
Caption: now we're working with a new
Caption: backlog a new product we've just done
Caption: discovery there is a brand new shiny
Caption: prototype how do we stare at a blank
Caption: screen and go where do we start that's
Caption: very intimidating i'll admit even for me
Caption: so
Caption: the five ease of service design like if
Caption: this is an educational talk this is the
Caption: thing i might expose you to who knows
Caption: but the five ease of service design is
Caption: just a construct that service designers
Caption: like myself use to navigate a user
Caption: journey and spoilers it's so simple so
Caption: hopefully you can use some of it before
Caption: i jump into what they are and we again
Caption: you map out the user journey and how to
Caption: translate that to a backlog i just want
Caption: to share an example
Caption: i want to say again deliberately low
Caption: quality but i didn't have access to this
Caption: anymore so i just took a screenshot of
Caption: what i have but here what we'll see is a
Caption: problem that we solved for a wi insurer
Caption: so what they were trying to do is
Caption: release functionality so that their
Caption: users can cancel their insurance policy
Caption: online no questions asked go in press
Caption: cancel it's done instant refund in our
Caption: research what is really awesome is
Caption: there's no other insurer to our
Caption: knowledge that allows you to do that in
Caption: australia so represent wa which is
Caption: awesome
Caption: but we needed to design for an
Caption: experience here and after we had our
Caption: prototype we were able to arrive semi at
Caption: this point so i'll step you through some
Caption: of the detail and then i'll get to the
Caption: five is how you can remember the
Caption: structure for yourself if you're trying
Caption: to do something like this so on the left
Caption: that first feature this is a working
Caption: draft the early days the ugly version of
Caption: a feature tree and that's okay i don't
Caption: even think we iterated the fidelity
Caption: after this we kind of just kept it kind
Caption: of there it served its purpose
Caption: access how do users get into this
Caption: experience let's talk about it as a form
Caption: so how do users access this cancellation
Caption: form so these are all the things we're
Caption: considering today they've got a platform
Caption: a portal you can log into let's leverage
Caption: a cancel button there lots of cool ideas
Caption: we have in the future but we stagger
Caption: them out focus on priority first
Caption: the next four so the view policy details
Caption: of course you want to be sure you're
Caption: canceling the right policy so let's pull
Caption: up that information that's where the
Caption: interesting stuff starts presenting
Caption: information in a simple way that's
Caption: relevant to that place you've just
Caption: clicked from you want to select the
Caption: cancellation reason this is not just an
Caption: information grab it depends on the
Caption: reason you're canceling depends on your
Caption: refund and the terms and conditions and
Caption: stuff like that it also helps the
Caption: customer service of course then there's
Caption: the date and the refund so we want to
Caption: know when are you canceled from
Caption: depending on your reason there's some
Caption: rules and depending on
Caption: what
Caption: what kind of policy you have your refund
Caption: amount might look different shout out to
Caption: my boomers some of them pay cash once a
Caption: year that's a whole other refund journey
Caption: than the online credit card ones so for
Caption: example these are all the things we
Caption: needed to navigate and like right
Caption: there's you know lots of different user
Caption: groups and things like that editing your
Caption: details might as well you're there and
Caption: in the confirmation so what i'm taking
Caption: you through is the user journey of for
Caption: example the end result of our discovery
Caption: and that's how we chunked it up
Caption: for our backlog so if you want the
Caption: ability to recall or replicate something
Caption: like this for yourself
Caption: this is where the five ease of service
Caption: design come in i'm not starting at the
Caption: first one i'll tell you in a second why
Caption: but let's go with that second one enter
Caption: every journey starts somewhere right our
Caption: first pillar was purely this is a user
Caption: based or a user journey based feature
Caption: tree how do we access our experience
Caption: what's that entry point and we already
Caption: said there's existing portal our initial
Caption: release the minimum viable product hate
Caption: that word um is we're just pressing a
Caption: button and we're entering that
Caption: experience and that's why it's at the
Caption: top enter
Caption: the next four like i mentioned that's
Caption: engage
Caption: so any user journey again that you'll go
Caption: through in life as these characters
Caption: engage that's the core of it so you'll
Caption: probably have quite a few features in it
Caption: if it's a form it's the pages of the
Caption: form if it's uh leave booking chat but
Caption: it's the approval stage gates whatever
Caption: you need like i've already mentioned
Caption: every feature that exists has stories
Caption: associated with it and then finally your
Caption: confirmations your exits beginning
Caption: middle end
Caption: and enter engage exit those three
Caption: they're the core so i like to think of
Caption: the exits as your planned and your
Caption: unplanned successes and failures so
Caption: what's your plan success cool that's
Caption: just a confirmation message you're
Caption: getting almost all of your money back in
Caption: seven days awesome you get the text
Caption: message for reinsurance fantastic or the
Caption: unplanned failures could be your error
Caption: messages you need that to go live of
Caption: course day one but there's other cool
Caption: things later down the line office in
Caption: service design we find a little bit of
Caption: back of house manual stuff we're willing
Caption: to cope with to release this to test if
Caption: people actually want to use it and over
Caption: time we might invest in automating some
Caption: of that and that's where the book ends
Caption: come in
Caption: entice an extend
Caption: don't like to start at entice and extend
Caption: because that's usually when the big
Caption: picture thinkers get really excited what
Caption: are all the cool ways we can attract
Caption: users to these features and extend what
Caption: are all the ways that we can make a
Caption: linear journey or a product journey
Caption: circular and things like that don't
Caption: start there but acknowledge that these
Caption: are typically from my experience at
Caption: least lower down the priority list when
Caption: we're launching new functionality
Caption: constantly re-prioritize but entice how
Caption: do we get more users to that journey and
Caption: extend
Caption: now what do we want to automate more
Caption: what does this unlock that kind of
Caption: thinking
Caption: so just
Caption: teaching by sheer repetition the five
Caption: ease of service design start in that
Caption: middle beginning middle and end then i
Caption: would say answer those questions what
Caption: comes before and what comes after so if
Caption: we've got a user journey that is usually
Caption: how we can look at our prototype
Caption: now cut slice that's where the knife
Caption: comes in slice the prototype in that
Caption: user journey how does it answer that
Caption: question and then we look at the
Caption: experience and do the story breakdown
Caption: from there
Caption: so what we're looking at here like i've
Caption: mentioned already is at the beginning of
Caption: a feature tree all of the smaller
Caption: post-it notes they're color-coded for
Caption: various reasons like still needs
Caption: discovery that's a different team that's
Caption: where we blocked by a platform but at
Caption: the very least
Caption: and this is the other way it's the first
Caption: time i've tried this so bonus coronalism
Caption: for you why not roadmap it so we mapped
Caption: out this is the core piece of
Caption: functionality we're going to go live
Caption: with day one what is the second release
Caption: look like you want more but yeah the
Caption: second release or the phase after that
Caption: and where are we just scoped where's our
Caption: save for later bucket and that's how we
Caption: use the feature tree to give that
Caption: product vision and then we can create
Caption: the backlog from here and then we've got
Caption: structure in the backlog you can tag
Caption: your backlog then with your feature
Caption: flags or things like that and color code
Caption: it and these artifacts will continue if
Caption: you update your feature tree they live
Caption: together you update the feature tree you
Caption: update your backlog you update your
Caption: backlog you update your feature tree so
Caption: in high periods of change pause the one
Caption: definitely sort the house out sort the
Caption: backlog out or sort the feature tree out
Caption: which one you're more dominant in and
Caption: then make sure that the other one
Caption: reflects this change because then we can
Caption: navigate between the two
Caption: so
Caption: i made y'all a template so this is just
Caption: a basic powerpoint template a lot of
Caption: what you saw today is um just powerpoint
Caption: templates it's not overly fancy so i've
Caption: created one hopefully this qr code still
Caption: works from overnight i've not tested it
Caption: this morning and this qr code is only
Caption: going to be live today so shout out to
Caption: the future if you're watching this it's
Caption: not going to work so
Caption: i'll send you a couple of resources i'll
Caption: send you that how to make one slide and
Caption: of the five years of service design in
Caption: this powerpoint
Caption: template that i've made it's also on the
Caption: next slide so i'm going to move on i've
Caption: i've been given my five minute time
Caption: warning sorry if i went a bit over but
Caption: at this point i might say thank you
Caption: again for the 900th time and ask if
Caption: you've got any questions and hopefully
Caption: we can navigate that or i'll be probably
Caption: throughout today at the telstra purple
Caption: booth if you want to have a chat so
Caption: any questions any opportunities
Caption: it's all good we've got a question here
Caption: what is my favorite tool to work in for
Caption: feature trees it really depends
Caption: on the project story time the most
Caption: recent feature to you i've created was
Caption: in excel because our product owner
Caption: absolutely loved excel so it has the
Caption: ability to filter and sort and
Caption: give details and if you export a backlog
Caption: so for example in our case azure devops
Caption: it already is in a similar format so you
Caption: can manipulate that csv for that run
Caption: reporting off of it it intimidates some
Caption: team members because they're allergic to
Caption: excel and that's okay so then at that
Caption: point my experience is you make the
Caption: trade-off
Caption: i love the online whiteboarding tools i
Caption: work from home so for me it's an easy
Caption: place
Caption: if you can convince someone to just go
Caption: in and use it it's usually just show me
Caption: how you do it then they'll get into it
Caption: and see how easy it is and if they're
Caption: convinced that it's that easy then they
Caption: will but if you tell them you're going
Caption: to use a new tool they might be a bit
Caption: antsy but luckily for us i guess in our
Caption: process it's already embedded that
Caption: specific tool if you can work online but
Caption: almost flipping the question don't let
Caption: the tool block you so an excel can be a
Caption: bit feature oh sorry a powerpoint can be
Caption: quite fidgety if you're moving a lot of
Caption: group boxes around it's no one's
Caption: favorite
Caption: choose an easy tool like a
Caption: the mirrors of the world or they're
Caption: quite easy
Caption: i find
Caption: awesome
Caption: there's a sorry i want to also mention
Caption: on that note
Caption: if you take an excel spreadsheet and you
Caption: copy all the cells you have two windows
Caption: and you drag the excel cells over to
Caption: mirror it just creates post-it notes for
Caption: you it's a wickedly fast feature you'll
Caption: probably only believe it if you see it
Caption: but it's that quick it's actually really
Caption: cool so try it next time drag your
Caption: stories into these whiteboarding tools
Caption: do you have time for one more question
Caption: one more
Caption: all good if not
Caption: there will be morning tea if there's no
Caption: more questions whether that influences
Caption: your decision to ask
Caption: awesome so that's me thanks first dddd
Caption: talk done
Caption: thank you everyone
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you do i just close my lap yeah
Caption: you're fine all right thank you everyone
Caption: we have morning tea out in the foyer uh
Caption: you should have about 20 minutes before
Caption: the next sessions kick off so
Caption: get get hydrated get full of some snacks
Caption: and be ready to learn
Caption: if you always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general top one is the best of the best
Caption: and for me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your career
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: whatever you need to progress in your
Caption: career you have got everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: do
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: business
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in ours
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: canada needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: houses like dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together
Caption: now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me jester because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cathendra i am a test automation
Caption: especially pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top line
Caption: of testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in
Caption: the it industry in general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your career
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: welcome everyone
Caption: uh we're ready to kick off our next
Caption: session uh it's my great pleasure to
Caption: introduce our next speaker derek bingham
Caption: uh he's a speaker veteran but it's his
Caption: first time actually speaking at ddd
Caption: perth so we're very excited to have him
Caption: up on the stage today derek is a
Caption: developer with a passion for building
Caption: software of all shapes and sizes on any
Caption: conceivable platform and he's here to
Caption: talk about five design patterns to build
Caption: more resilient applications
Caption: thank you
Caption: hello
Caption: come in come in take a seat take a seat
Caption: um yes thank you carol my name is derek
Caption: i am a developer
Caption: advocate at aws and today i'm going to
Caption: talk to you about resiliency uh and
Caption: building resilient applications
Caption: now
Caption: a little side story about resiliency
Caption: i have done every role it's possible to
Caption: do at ddd i have been a room coordinator
Caption: i have been on the committee i have been
Caption: a floor coordinator i have just ran
Caption: around helping these awesome folks who
Caption: organized this this conference and today
Caption: is the first time after seven attempts i
Caption: actually made it as a speaker
Caption: resiliency yes
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: so in today's talk you'll fall into one
Caption: of three camps you'll either be in camp
Caption: one where you'll think oh that's an
Caption: interesting pattern never heard of that
Caption: before
Caption: or you'll call uh fallen camp two and
Caption: you go well i i know that pattern of uh
Caption: i've implemented before but maybe not in
Caption: in dot net so that's interesting or
Caption: you'll fall into um camp three and
Caption: you'll go like go like this oh
Caption: flip not another one
Caption: more on that later
Caption: so for those of you who do not
Caption: know me and my flicker is not working
Caption: you get closer get closer get closer
Caption: it's a big stage
Caption: reset the clicker
Caption: it's good start
Caption: there we go no there we go
Caption: brazilian the resilient clicker this is
Caption: not um so for those of you who don't
Caption: know me um i have been building software
Caption: for 20 years uh i am that old yes um
Caption: majority in in cloud so the last seven
Caption: or eight years i've been building
Caption: software in a number of different clouds
Caption: um
Caption: what we call cloud native so some people
Caption: call cloud native um others close
Caption: and
Caption: for for nearly five of those years i
Caption: have been working at aws
Caption: and the last two is developer advocate
Caption: um you may notice a slight accent i am
Caption: originally from ireland hence the the
Caption: green shoes that i i'm wearing today
Caption: but i am very much perth native and have
Caption: been living in this beautiful city for
Caption: 15 years and i probably worked with
Caption: quite a few of you in the audience so
Caption: i'm
Caption: sorry um
Caption: clicker is
Caption: of yes okay so a lot of people i usually
Caption: start talks with um a quote
Caption: and it's usually a quote by somebody
Caption: else so i thought ah first ever ddd talk
Caption: let's have a quote from me so a lot of
Caption: people ask me derek what do you do what
Caption: is a developer advocate and so this is
Caption: what i say a developer advocate is i
Caption: show people what i used to do
Caption: for a living
Caption: think about it
Caption: um so that's my quote and so
Caption: today i'm going to show you patterns
Caption: that i used to implement
Caption: for a living
Caption: and i'll have to stay i'm gonna have to
Caption: stay i love i love walking the stage but
Caption: my clicker's not working
Caption: oh no it's okay um thanks thanks sarah
Caption: so i'm gonna start with another quote
Caption: this is from a from a from a person a
Caption: lot more famous than i am and this is
Caption: the cto of uh
Caption: amazon dr vernon vogels so failures are
Caption: given and everything will eventually
Caption: fail over time so when people hear this
Caption: they're like what everything fails
Caption: nonsense everything always works in my
Caption: my machine
Caption: or or they say oh okay and that's that's
Caption: the acceptance that you need
Caption: failure is a thing when we build modern
Caption: software applications that are
Caption: distributed
Caption: we build them on different platforms we
Caption: go across networks that may
Caption: go across boundaries of regions
Caption: countries
Caption: all sorts of latency introduced and they
Caption: may also work on different hardware
Caption: so
Caption: nothing's ever going to work all the
Caption: time that's ridiculous so what we need
Caption: to do
Caption: is when we're building software we need
Caption: to take this in mind we need to build
Caption: our applications to be more resilient
Caption: it's terrible
Caption: click
Caption: so today i'm going to say five patterns
Caption: timeouts
Caption: graceful degradations retries
Caption: exponential back offs and circuit
Caption: breakers and you'll see it's a
Caption: progression as i build these out and
Caption: then we're going to dive into one
Caption: practice the practice of chaos
Caption: engineering
Caption: and that will become clear why we're
Caption: diving into chaos engineering when we
Caption: get to it
Caption: so the first thing to do is meet the
Caption: traditional distributed application that
Caption: we're going
Caption: to build today
Caption: before i get into it
Caption: anybody who doesn't like bad jokes you
Caption: may as well leave noy because there's a
Caption: lot
Caption: um a lot so i'm sorry i apologize
Caption: but not really
Caption: so this is our distributed application
Caption: it is a random joke generator
Caption: and here's a joke what
Caption: do computers eat for snack
Caption: microchips of course
Caption: and
Caption: if it has a
Caption: saw it has a punch line and a punch line
Caption: and if i hit tell me another
Caption: it's going to get another joke two hard
Caption: things in computer science cache and
Caption: validation naming things and off by one
Caption: errors okay
Caption: um and then if i hit the back end of
Caption: this um front end i've got a setup a
Caption: punchline and a source all in json
Caption: and and if i refresh it'll hit an api
Caption: that will give me a result and that's
Caption: the application so if we look at the
Caption: code itself i have a client app so the
Caption: client lab is a react app which is
Caption: basically just one app.js
Caption: and inside app.js i have a fetch job
Caption: component
Caption: an inside fetch job i have got basically
Caption: two functions i have got a um
Caption: a rendered joke data which renders uh
Caption: the beautiful ui that you saw earlier
Caption: and i also have a if it's that populated
Caption: data now this fetches the json object
Caption: from the backend api
Caption: or from the controller
Caption: now
Caption: what it does it renders a response in
Caption: json and displays it for your viewing
Caption: pleasure
Caption: so that is the ui then into the back end
Caption: is a net controller so what i'm doing
Caption: here i'm implementing what is an ijoo
Caption: client interface this is all in.net but
Caption: don't worry you should be able to
Caption: understand it and um what i do i call i
Caption: instantiate htcp client i
Caption: grab
Caption: an endpoint and i call out to it and i
Caption: serialize deserialize the json object
Caption: and return it back to the fro the front
Caption: end
Caption: as a joke so what i'm doing i'm calling
Caption: out to a third-party api from this from
Caption: this uh controller
Caption: the joke object itself that i'm
Caption: serializing deserializing is that setup
Caption: punch line and source and it's got
Caption: accessories and mutators as you'd expect
Caption: and then so then that's what you get so
Caption: you get tell me another calls the third
Caption: party joke api
Caption: third party joke api returns and why are
Caption: monkeys great at sports because they're
Caption: born champions
Caption: got a few drones
Caption: um
Caption: so that that that's our application
Caption: now like any good thing we need a an
Caption: architecture so the architecture is like
Caption: this so we have a react web application
Caption: i'd love to move over the other edge of
Caption: the day of the of the stage but i'm free
Caption: frightened my clicker won't work um
Caption: react web application calls the.net
Caption: microservice so the controller i showed
Caption: you
Caption: that then proxies into a third-party
Caption: joke api
Caption: uh which returns a joke to the
Caption: controller uh and then back to the react
Caption: web application
Caption: but what happens if the third-party joke
Caption: api that i do not control that is a
Caption: third party
Caption: ra has load runs into errors and fails
Caption: well what happens then is the react
Caption: client doesn't know that it's failed
Caption: the net microservice still proxies the
Caption: request
Caption: to the third party joke api
Caption: and it just waits uh it'll wait for
Caption: because i'm using the.net http client
Caption: the default weight is 100 seconds so
Caption: it'll wait for 100 seconds
Caption: and that will mean the react web
Caption: application will also be waiting for
Caption: result from the dotted microservice
Caption: and another client might come along and
Caption: do a request for a new joke because we
Caption: all need
Caption: bad jokes
Caption: and it will proxy it through the
Caption: third-party joke api which is still
Caption: broken and again we'll get into this
Caption: problem of waiting uh for the default
Caption: timeout of uh the client request
Caption: and what will happen after after time is
Caption: that.net microservice will be just full
Caption: of these waiting requests and it will
Caption: start to fail and
Caption: keep it'll keep cascading the failures
Caption: back to the react web application which
Caption: will just keep waiting um
Caption: until yeah nothing so this is all very
Caption: bad for our users and a very bad
Caption: experience for them
Caption: so let's go about fixing that and seeing
Caption: how we can apply patterns to make it
Caption: more resilient
Caption: the first pattern i'm going to define is
Caption: timeouts so
Caption: at the minute we're using default
Caption: timeouts for everything which is 100
Caption: seconds let's go about making the
Caption: timeouts more determinate
Caption: so here we are back in in the code
Caption: so if we look at um the http client
Caption: object uh in net we can actually add a
Caption: property to that directly now the
Caption: property is called timeout imagine it's
Caption: retitled i must say
Caption: and it is from seconds so i'm going to
Caption: give it five so that's going to override
Caption: the default behavior of 100 seconds and
Caption: at least make things more determinant
Caption: so what's going to happen if i implement
Caption: that
Caption: is my my application is going to change
Caption: its behavior somewhat
Caption: so if i refresh the the client
Caption: and you get another awesome joke if you
Caption: hit tell me another it'll keep returning
Caption: it will keep returning jokes as the
Caption: third party api is still up
Caption: and so if i hit tell me another
Caption: it'll keep returning until
Caption: we get a failure in the third-party joke
Caption: api
Caption: which
Caption: we probably will when this is spinning
Caption: for more than five seconds so at the
Caption: minute it's spinning so that means
Caption: something is wrong
Caption: so if we then go to the the back end
Caption: controller and do the refresh you'll see
Caption: boom we've got a an unhandled exception
Caption: uh which is actually if you look down a
Caption: timeout exception so what's happened is
Caption: the five seconds um has actually expired
Caption: and it's bubbled up a timeout exception
Caption: of five seconds so that that is a very
Caption: rudimentary
Caption: um use of a timeout we're just making
Caption: the request more determinate
Caption: but that's that's only the start
Caption: next the next phase of the refactoring
Caption: of this application is by using a
Caption: resilience library called poly has
Caption: anybody used polyand.net
Caption: excellent it is an excellent library um
Caption: if you are not a
Caption: developer don't worry um there are uh
Caption: equivalent.net uh sorry equivalent
Caption: resilience libraries for java there's
Caption: one inside spring
Caption: if you're using the aws sdks all these
Caption: patterns are actually built into them
Caption: and there's also i've seen a resilience
Caption: library for typescript as well so poly
Caption: is just the one for that
Caption: so let's start using poly and really
Caption: expand in our timeout
Caption: let's get rid of that that was
Caption: our default
Caption: net http client timeout the first thing
Caption: we need to do in poly is define a policy
Caption: so what we do is define a policy that
Caption: wraps our timeout so we say policy
Caption: timeout async
Caption: and then we need to give it a value
Caption: which again we'll set this five seconds
Caption: so the policy object comes from the poly
Caption: library
Caption: just for uh so you know and then once we
Caption: have defined the policy we need to then
Caption: put it in an execute so we're wrapping
Caption: it async executor
Caption: uh and then we'll pull once we've
Caption: defined the async method with
Caption: a
Caption: timeout token a token we will then wrap
Caption: our entire
Caption: call to the http client
Caption: up push it in to our execute async
Caption: anonymous inner function
Caption: and
Caption: define
Caption: our cancellation token thank you
Caption: so why why define the cancellation token
Caption: so the cancellation token is now giving
Caption: us greater granularity into the calls so
Caption: we've got two async calls in here we've
Caption: got a http client git async and a
Caption: content.read async
Caption: so the cancellation token will actually
Caption: allow us to cancel whatever task is
Caption: running
Caption: so we then finish and make that a return
Caption: to width and then we have five it and
Caption: see what's going to happen now to our
Caption: application again back in the front end
Caption: we'll have
Caption: a similar behavior where um the the ui
Caption: will will keep refreshing for more than
Caption: five seconds
Caption: and then if we go into the the
Caption: controller uh and we hit refresh
Caption: we'll see different behavior so what's
Caption: happening now the third party api has
Caption: again failed
Caption: uh but we've got a cast a task uh
Caption: cancelled exception because the
Caption: cancellation token is invoked and that
Caption: has meant that um the task is has um
Caption: bubbled up that exception
Caption: so as you can see we're on a bit of a
Caption: journey here um so we've got our timeout
Caption: we've then wrapped it in poly we've got
Caption: a greater granularity into the the call
Caption: stack but um we're still getting um
Caption: exceptions we're still bubbling up to
Caption: the to the um the controller what's the
Caption: next stage in refractoring this
Caption: well the next stage the next pattern is
Caption: called uh graceful degradation
Caption: so like the name suggests
Caption: it's gonna
Caption: degrade gracefully i.e we're not going
Caption: to uh we're going to have that client or
Caption: our beautiful users who are using our
Caption: beautiful joke um
Caption: creation or joke rendering application
Caption: actually get a result when things go
Caption: wrong
Caption: so that's the whole concept around
Caption: graceful degradation the application
Caption: gracefully degrades now how do we
Caption: implement a graceful degradation
Caption: so again we need to define what's called
Caption: a
Caption: fallback so a fallback is thing that you
Caption: can present to your users when all thing
Caption: all other things are filled
Caption: so in poly i create a policy that
Caption: returns a joke list
Caption: uh innumerable and done as list
Caption: and then on any exception
Caption: it will do something
Caption: so what we want our fallback to do
Caption: is to return a joke
Caption: so i'm executing a fallback async that
Caption: returns
Caption: a a list of jokes but for this
Caption: demonstration i'm simply going to return
Caption: one joke
Caption: and i'm going to do that inside another
Caption: async anonymous function that has a
Caption: cancellation token just like um
Caption: we had in our
Caption: initial request so define it as a new
Caption: list
Caption: once i've defined it as a new list
Caption: i then need to define my joke
Caption: so the joke object if you remember has
Caption: uh basically three fields it has a
Caption: source
Caption: a setup first
Caption: it has a punch line the all-important
Caption: punchline
Caption: and it has a source
Caption: so once i've defined that source i'm
Caption: going to give it a name of fallback so
Caption: you know that when this renders you'll
Caption: see source equals fallback
Caption: on the ui so we can see that our
Caption: fallback has been returned
Caption: now we're going to um what's called
Caption: implement what's called a policy wrapper
Caption: this is this is where we can actually um
Caption: chain policies together um using poly
Caption: so the general fallback policy that i've
Caption: defined i'm wrapping the original policy
Caption: in which is our timeout if you remember
Caption: so now
Caption: i'm going to change
Caption: and execute the policy wrap
Caption: okay so what what's going to happen now
Caption: is we're going to return this joke if a
Caption: five second
Caption: uh timeout occurs i'm in a band called
Caption: 1023
Caption: megabits or megabytes
Caption: sorry we haven't
Caption: had any gigs yet
Caption: kabum tish
Caption: thank you thank you
Caption: claps are good thank you
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: so um so that's our fallback
Caption: now if we go back into our our ui let's
Caption: have a look and see what happens
Caption: so let's refresh it's wait for f5 to
Caption: work in the application to come up
Caption: so here we go um so ui controller
Caption: third-party api
Caption: so we've went straight to the fallback
Caption: you see source equals fallback
Caption: um
Caption: you can see that we've hit the fallback
Caption: right away if i go tell me another
Caption: there we are the third party joke api is
Caption: recovered uh i tell you to be joked but
Caption: you might not get it nice
Caption: there's even networking jokes in here
Caption: come on refresh again and you've got i'm
Caption: in a band called 1024 so a fallback
Caption: again has has been invoked then refresh
Caption: that and why don't werewolves
Caption: ever know the time because they're not
Caption: when wolves third-party joke api sorry
Caption: that you can't read that that was that
Caption: was bad um so that is our fallback we
Caption: are invoking it when the timeout of five
Caption: seconds happens
Caption: and returns a joke you can return a list
Caption: or a random entry in that list if you
Caption: wanted to
Caption: but for brevity i'm returning one joke
Caption: only with the source of fallback
Caption: and that's how you
Caption: do gracefully degrade our api
Caption: cool
Caption: so that's that's great you say um
Caption: the third party joke api fails
Caption: times out after five five seconds users
Caption: always get a joke that we can determine
Caption: um well not really um because we need to
Caption: to give the third party joke api more
Caption: time
Caption: to if it's under load
Caption: to recover and we need to be able to not
Caption: just try once to get that joke from our
Caption: controller to the third party api we
Caption: need to try it a few times and that's
Caption: where what a retry will retry is
Caption: so let's push a retry pattern into into
Caption: our application
Caption: so again
Caption: we'll just gonna refactor the general
Caption: fallback into a method
Caption: called general fallback because i'm very
Caption: imaginative
Caption: and then once you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: then the next thing we're going to do is
Caption: define that retry policy
Caption: so the retry policy
Caption: is it's fairly straightforward
Caption: again type policy
Caption: on the handle
Caption: of exception now you could be more
Caption: generic i'm very generic in this
Caption: exception again for brevity but you can
Caption: be quite specific if you want
Caption: um and then once the exception happens i
Caption: want to retry async a number of times so
Caption: this time i'm going to retry five times
Caption: i'm going to build that retry policy
Caption: into my policy wrapper so
Caption: the first policy i want to do
Caption: is the retry policy
Caption: so i want to do the initial request
Caption: if that
Caption: hits the exception i'm going to retry
Caption: five times if that hits the exception
Caption: five times um
Caption: then i'll handle my fallback i'm going
Caption: to change the timeout to two seconds
Caption: because you know five times five is a
Caption: long time so five times two is a bit
Caption: quicker so f5 that
Caption: and let's see what happens to your
Caption: application
Caption: front end first
Caption: loading loading
Caption: so third-party api there are two hard
Caption: things computer science we've had that
Caption: before come on duke api
Caption: tell me another refreshing
Caption: so we'll know that if it's go over two
Caption: seconds so our timeline is set to two
Caption: seconds so if this is loading more than
Caption: two seconds we know we're retrying and
Caption: now it's retried five times
Caption: hasn't worked so we're back to our
Caption: fallback
Caption: because we've always got our fallback
Caption: and then tell me another 10 times people
Caption: in the world those who understand binary
Caption: and those don't
Caption: um and then refresh again on our back
Caption: end
Caption: let's see what's happening there from
Caption: our controller's perspective
Caption: so it's taking more than two seconds so
Caption: we're retrying
Caption: and then
Caption: well actually a third-party api has come
Caption: back again inside the five retry window
Caption: so we're getting a real joke
Caption: if i retry that again
Caption: it's pretty happy at the minute why did
Caption: billable bygones always it is lunch at
Caption: noon he was a creature of hobbit
Caption: no
Caption: come on very topical um
Caption: and this third-party joke api as always
Caption: is very happy
Caption: refresh again
Caption: oh here we go so we're retrying
Caption: can we hit five yes there we go so uh
Caption: we're back to our fallback because we've
Caption: retried five times two second increments
Caption: and it's fell back to our fallback
Caption: and we'll just go over the code so two
Caption: second timeout
Caption: if the exception occurs
Caption: over a retry count of five
Caption: then we will hit
Caption: our fallback exception
Caption: three tries
Caption: so
Caption: that's three tries and retries are
Caption: really really really nice
Caption: but what happens
Caption: when you just
Caption: implement retries
Caption: so just say i had this controller uh
Caption: just implementing the retry pattern
Caption: um and i had many of these controllers
Caption: all hitting my
Caption: third party api
Caption: at two second intervals
Caption: well what i've just created is a
Caption: distributed denali service application
Caption: that's hitting that third-party api and
Caption: uh probably putting it under more load
Caption: than it can probably handle because
Caption: everybody in the world wants bad jokes
Caption: so what we need to do is improve that
Caption: retry pattern and implement an
Caption: exponential back off
Caption: i think i've got some i got a slide
Caption: about this as well
Caption: so what's the exponential back off it's
Caption: simply backing off between retries
Caption: so as always our react web application
Caption: goes through and proxies through our.net
Caption: microservice
Caption: and then may uh
Caption: if it's will timeout after two seconds
Caption: after that two seconds it will then
Caption: retry
Caption: but with an extra exponential back off
Caption: instead of retrying after two seconds
Caption: again you actually wait for four seconds
Caption: for the next retry
Caption: and then eight seconds because the
Caption: timeout the time between retries is
Caption: increasing exponentially hence the name
Caption: and then finally
Caption: we'll have wait for 16 seconds and
Caption: hopefully after 16 seconds our third
Caption: party joke api will recover and return a
Caption: result to our react web application
Caption: so let's implement a exponential back
Caption: off
Caption: in our code
Caption: so
Caption: the only it's pretty simple thing to do
Caption: um so what we need to do is add a little
Caption: bit of maths to our repa retry logic
Caption: so luckily in poly there's a wait and
Caption: retry async method that i'm going to use
Caption: i'm going to
Caption: give it a duration of three
Caption: and a retry attempt number
Caption: and
Caption: i'm going to
Caption: time span between retail attempts is
Caption: this is where we want to exponentially
Caption: increase
Caption: so i used math.pow
Caption: i put in
Caption: two because we want to do the power of
Caption: two
Caption: by by the number of retry attempts that
Caption: we we have so it's two
Caption: 8 16.
Caption: well i'll render as
Caption: so that's uh that's me exponentially
Caption: adding let's be adding exponential back
Caption: off to the code
Caption: pretty simple so when i do f5 and run
Caption: the application
Caption: we'll then have again a different
Caption: behavior because what we're doing now is
Caption: we're giving that third party api time
Caption: to actually get working again
Caption: so here's our um
Caption: what do you call developer from finland
Caption: nerdic
Caption: that's a new one tell me another
Caption: so
Caption: as it's over two seconds i can tell now
Caption: that we're retrying so in this case we
Caption: want it to go two four you hit 16. so if
Caption: this spins for 16 seconds which i could
Caption: tell you when you're standing up here is
Caption: a very long time
Caption: um then we're going we should get our
Caption: fallback
Caption: and there we go yes right on cue uh i'm
Caption: a band uh tell me another and there we
Caption: go what's what's happened is our third
Caption: party api has come back and we're now
Caption: getting jokes again because we give it
Caption: time uh we haven't hit it every two
Caption: seconds we've actually
Caption: hit it two four
Caption: eight sixteen now i've chose two seconds
Caption: because it's arbitrary you can choose
Caption: the number uh that actually fits your
Caption: use case uh in your
Caption: what user behavior you want to see in
Caption: your application
Caption: but for this little um demonstration
Caption: i've chose two seconds because you
Caption: really don't want to sit there and watch
Caption: that spinning wheel for for a minute or
Caption: whatever
Caption: but there's more
Caption: so that that's exponential back off but
Caption: exponential back off is not enough
Caption: because it's a very popular pattern
Caption: everybody if they're implementing
Caption: retries is also doing exponential back
Caption: off
Caption: with three tries now
Caption: what happens is
Caption: yes we have a broader distrib
Caption: distribution
Caption: of retries uh but what happens is
Caption: everybody does it
Caption: exponentially and so our retries
Caption: actually end up clustering anyway
Caption: so
Caption: the whole problem that we're trying to
Caption: fix ie
Caption: hitting that's
Caption: trying to give that server our api
Caption: third-party api chance to recover we're
Caption: actually um we're not we're not doing it
Caption: because we're still hitting it all at
Caption: once as you can see in the left-hand
Caption: diagram those requests are all
Caption: clustering um as they come in
Caption: so what we want to do is actually
Caption: flatten flatten make those requests
Caption: actually random
Caption: we don't um want
Caption: to
Caption: get spikes of requests all coming at
Caption: once to our third-party api because it's
Caption: going to crash again we need it to
Caption: recover
Caption: so what we do is we add jitter
Caption: now there's a link there in the slide so
Caption: we have um
Caption: what's called a builder's library
Caption: in amazon aws amazon.com gives you a
Caption: list of all these patterns and how to
Caption: implement them
Caption: jitter is just one of the patterns
Caption: there's a whole lot of different
Caption: patterns that you need when you're
Caption: building cloud native applications
Caption: so let's see how we'd implement
Caption: exponential backup with jitter in our
Caption: application
Caption: so what we need to do is define a bit of
Caption: randomness to this retry
Caption: and so luckily in.net there is a
Caption: math.random
Caption: which we can define
Caption: inside of time span so what i'm doing
Caption: here i define a time span of
Caption: milliseconds and inside i'm going to
Caption: define that as a new random number so
Caption: i'm adding a random amount of time
Caption: between each retry
Caption: so that if in effect flattens the um the
Caption: retry curve
Caption: and that's it that's all you have to do
Caption: to implement jitter
Caption: in a retry so it's you should you should
Caption: do it basically
Caption: so let's um exponential back off with
Caption: jitter
Caption: now we're going to get into
Caption: um the fun one circuit breaker
Caption: so what is a circuit breaker so
Caption: if you have a we have a react web
Caption: application
Caption: proxying third-party joke api it's
Caption: breaking randomly
Caption: and we keep retrying and we're using
Caption: exponential back off with jitter we
Caption: trying we trying hopefully it'll come
Caption: back
Caption: but what if we wanted to reduce the load
Caption: completely off the third-party joke api
Caption: for a period of time you know at the
Caption: minute we're just implementing retries
Caption: with jitter and exponential back off but
Caption: ultimately it's hitting it's hitting
Caption: that third party 2 kpr
Caption: well this is where a circuit breaker
Caption: comes in so a circuit breaker is
Caption: something that you can implement that
Caption: will actually stop
Caption: requests
Caption: going through to the third party api or
Caption: other service that that you choose for a
Caption: number of minutes
Caption: why would you implement the circuit
Caption: breaker because it's giving ultimately
Caption: this third-party api no request so it
Caption: can spin up it can fix itself and
Caption: hopefully come back so with the circuit
Caption: breaker the request when it comes back
Caption: it comes back from the circuit breaker
Caption: itself and returns to the react web
Caption: application
Caption: so now any other subsequent request in
Caption: that time span of the circuit breaker
Caption: will be quick responsive and the um the
Caption: users will be happy they won't be
Caption: waiting for a time a retry or an
Caption: exponential retry or anything like that
Caption: they will get a more responsive um
Caption: response
Caption: for their request
Caption: so let's implement a circuit breaker
Caption: with a circuit breaker you need some
Caption: states so you have to store state inside
Caption: the you where you're calling it or where
Caption: you're implementing it so i'm just going
Caption: to refactor this a little bit and
Caption: refactor what we've got into
Caption: a global
Caption: field so policy wrap will become a
Caption: global
Caption: inside the controller and then i'm just
Caption: going to pull what i've got already and
Caption: refactor that into a method because
Caption: that's not going to change what we need
Caption: to do is add to it so extract the method
Caption: and call it
Caption: init policies
Caption: so there we go so what we've basically
Caption: got is the init policy is called
Caption: and then we we call the the api with the
Caption: right policies
Caption: so inside init policies itself let's
Caption: just jump into it after i've tidied it
Caption: up
Caption: so nothing's changed we've got our retry
Caption: general fallback and his initial policy
Caption: now we need to define
Caption: what is our circuit breaker
Caption: now a circuit breaker itself is is a
Caption: policy
Caption: you define it as a policy just like the
Caption: rest
Caption: now
Caption: again i'm catching a very high level
Caption: generic exception
Caption: but in poly we have actually got a
Caption: circuit breaker
Caption: async
Caption: method what we're doing we're saying
Caption: circuit breaker
Caption: if um
Caption: you stay active for a time span uh uh
Caption: after a number of exceptions
Caption: so what that's defining is the circuit
Caption: breaker itself saying uh if i catch five
Caption: sec exceptions
Caption: and go implement myself and stay active
Caption: for one minute
Caption: once i've defined the circuit breaker
Caption: policy i need to then define what to
Caption: return from the circuit breaker for that
Caption: one minute when it's uh in operation
Caption: and this is another fallback so i'm
Caption: going to call this one a circuit breaker
Caption: fallback now i could use my existing
Caption: fallback if i wanted to but i need to
Caption: handle this circuit broke exception so
Caption: this is why i'm implementing a specific
Caption: fallback for the circuit breaker and
Caption: also to demonstrate when it's invoked
Caption: so on broken circuit exception i need to
Caption: return another fantastic joke
Caption: and that's what i'll do here so again
Caption: fallback async
Caption: which will have a
Caption: an enumerable of type joke again i'm
Caption: only returning a single joke for brevity
Caption: async define cancellation token
Caption: and let's define the joke
Caption: so the joke this time um i'm gonna have
Caption: to come up with uh something
Caption: even better than a band of 102 three
Caption: megabytes so again this is um
Caption: we've got our object so job object that
Caption: the joke is so a setup punch line and
Caption: source
Caption: but this time the source is going to be
Caption: circuit breaker so we can tell that the
Caption: actual circuit breaker has been invoked
Caption: cool
Caption: and then we add it to our policy wrapper
Caption: so we want to
Caption: make sure that this is called
Caption: after uh five exceptions so we need five
Caption: exceptions so we put it after the retry
Caption: we say invoke circuit breaker fallback
Caption: when
Caption: the circuit breaker policy happens
Caption: i.e five exceptions
Caption: cool and that's our initial policy at
Caption: the bottom
Caption: so what's gonna happen is
Caption: we're gonna set up
Caption: let's go so why did
Caption: why did the developer
Caption: go broke
Caption: because
Caption: they used up
Caption: all
Caption: their cash
Caption: cash
Caption: thank you
Caption: um so f5 that
Caption: and let's see how our application
Caption: behaves
Caption: this is the the application you're
Caption: coming to know and love um so
Caption: let's go to the ui first
Caption: so what we're doing we're um
Caption: oh it's we've got into our um circuit
Caption: breaker right away so
Caption: uh we'll refresh that
Caption: again so as our circuit breaker is
Caption: invoked we were always going to get our
Caption: circuit breaker fall back for the next
Caption: minute so we can refresh refresh you see
Caption: how responsive the application is
Caption: getting
Caption: and it's always returning in the same
Caption: joke i.e our circuit breaker fallback
Caption: which is great
Caption: but if we wait a minute
Caption: we should we should then see the state
Caption: uh change and actually the um we'll
Caption: call again our third party api after the
Caption: um the circuit breaker
Caption: has went away um for the minute so
Caption: that's that's um that's circuit breaker
Caption: um
Caption: sometimes
Caption: it's it's it's it we implemented to just
Caption: improve the um responsiveness of our
Caption: application
Caption: so we're gonna give it in a minute
Caption: still active refresh should be a minute
Caption: by night
Caption: how many programmers take to change the
Caption: light bulb it's a hardware problem none
Caption: uh third-party api thank you very much
Caption: for that jam
Caption: so it's back so a third-party api is
Caption: back and now i will we'll be hitting it
Caption: again um and if we get have a number of
Caption: retries that that fall
Caption: and hit our five that hit our circuit
Caption: breaker the circuit breaker will be
Caption: invoked again um but now our third-party
Caption: duke api is behaving for now uh but
Caption: we've got that uh circuit breaker
Caption: fallback if if if if we need it
Caption: cool
Caption: so that's that's um
Caption: that's implementing the five practices
Caption: now
Caption: i want to end on the practice of chaos
Caption: engineering because what you've just
Caption: witnessed
Caption: uh today is
Caption: the practice of chaos engineering you
Caption: may not have known it
Caption: so chaos engineering is the process of
Caption: stressing an application by creating
Caption: disruptive events
Caption: observing how the system responds
Caption: and implementing improvements so what
Caption: have we done we've stressed our
Caption: application our application is a
Caption: third-party joke api we've been
Caption: requesting new jokes and sometimes we've
Caption: been getting some absolute cracking
Caption: jokes i think you'll agree and other
Caption: times um you know it's it's broken
Caption: so
Caption: we've been but when it breaks we've been
Caption: observing how our system responds
Caption: it has a little spinny wheel it throws
Caption: exceptions um and with that in mind
Caption: we've started implementing improvements
Caption: so we've implemented retries exponential
Caption: back offs with jitter and then finally
Caption: circuit breakers
Caption: but think of chaos engineering as this
Caption: lovely little wheel
Caption: and where we start with steady state our
Caption: application is happy
Caption: we then come up with a hypothesis
Caption: i can nearly speak and we think well
Caption: what will happen to our application if
Caption: we do x
Caption: so let's do that using the aws fault
Caption: injection simulator this is what i've
Caption: been using to
Caption: kill the third-party joke api
Caption: so what i do i create an experiment
Caption: and i create an experiment using an
Caption: experiment template where i go
Caption: description
Caption: stop instances
Caption: i then
Caption: give it a roll so it allows me to stop
Caption: those instances
Caption: i then um give it an action so again i
Caption: just want to stop the instances please
Caption: a brief description
Caption: and then an action type so the action
Caption: type is you choose a service you want to
Caption: invoke this action on
Caption: and in this case the ec2
Caption: and then you give it a duration so i'm
Caption: stopping my ec2 instances that are
Caption: running the third duke api for a minute
Caption: and that's my hypothesis that i'm
Caption: defining here
Caption: i define what i'm going to target by
Caption: using tags so all of the ec2 instances
Caption: that are running my third-party joke api
Caption: are all tagged with the value of api
Caption: so i i set that up here
Caption: and then i create my experiment it gives
Caption: you all these warnings because you
Caption: actually are going to stop real
Caption: instances and there they are they're
Caption: running at the minute they're happy um
Caption: and i can then run my experiment
Caption: another warning because even though it's
Caption: called the fault injection simulator it
Caption: actually does stop the things
Caption: um so that's why there's all these
Caption: warnings so what's happening now is my
Caption: experiment is starting to run
Caption: and currently
Caption: if i keep refreshing
Caption: you'll see that although my apis are
Caption: starting to run i just give it some time
Caption: for this experiment to invoke
Caption: now it's running
Caption: i refresh my third-party joke apis and
Caption: they're all stopping
Caption: and so now
Caption: my application that's calling this
Caption: third-party joke api needs to deal with
Caption: these things stopping
Caption: and this is where we go to the next
Caption: phase in this cycle after we've run our
Caption: experiment within verify so verify
Caption: verification is
Caption: what we were doing earlier we were
Caption: running our application and verifying
Caption: what was happening
Caption: then after a minute and we've ran our
Caption: application and uh our api is not
Caption: working we've built our resilient
Caption: applications and build our patterns
Caption: the apis actually come back
Caption: because the fault injection simulator
Caption: experiment defined a minute and so our
Caption: apis are now working as as they should
Caption: so that
Caption: is
Caption: how we define chaos engineering we have
Caption: verified what happens when the third
Caption: party apis are down for a minute and
Caption: then we start improving them and we
Caption: improve and we improve them using the um
Caption: the patterns that i defined earlier
Caption: as well as stopping instances we can do
Caption: other things in ec2s ecs container
Caption: systems
Caption: rds database
Caption: service
Caption: so a lot of different services in aws
Caption: support fault injection
Caption: and this is what we've done today so um
Caption: i'd like to thank our sponsors without
Caption: them we would be nothing
Caption: uh if you want to ask more questions
Caption: because we're running out of time about
Caption: this and any uh anything else about aws
Caption: i'll be at the booth for the rest of the
Caption: day um looking fatigued but please don't
Caption: let that put you off uh please come in
Caption: and come and speak to me i was always
Caption: good for a chat
Caption: uh all the code today is on my github
Caption: repo as well which is dkob as well as my
Caption: twitter handle
Caption: thanks everybody for
Caption: listening and
Caption: helping me get through all of these bad
Caption: jokes thanks to the clap over there a
Caption: few groans over there
Caption: and then there's a few i already knew
Caption: all this stuff over there so that's
Caption: that's the that is the three the three
Caption: areas that everybody fell into so thank
Caption: you thank you very much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: time for questions
Caption: excellent thank you derek that was some
Caption: truly awful awful jokes but i will give
Caption: bonus points for the werewolf joke
Caption: because it is a full moon today so
Caption: we're doing well um we do have
Caption: changeover now everyone so you've got 10
Caption: minutes to either hang out here or head
Caption: to another room if you're moving to
Caption: another talk
Caption: and in 10 minutes we'll have amy talking
Caption: here about ducks
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made sure dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: i really needed to wind down before bed
Caption: so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: poses like dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: yes
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: canada needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use it can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: welcome everyone uh it is my great
Caption: pleasure to introduce our next speaker
Caption: try not to knock things over
Caption: sorry next up we have amy kaepernick uh
Caption: giving her talk entitled how to manage
Caption: ducks
Caption: uh amy's a conference addict front-end
Caption: accessibility enthusiast and dog lover
Caption: she's been a microsoft mvp and twilio
Caption: champion since 2019 and believes that
Caption: mental health and managing your ducks is
Caption: an important and ongoing responsibility
Caption: you may have seen her on the stage
Caption: earlier today so we're very excited to
Caption: welcome her back thank you amy
Caption: okay i do have my slides
Caption: yeah so the reason you saw me on stage
Caption: this morning is because i was like well
Caption: i really want to present on the big
Caption: stage at ddd and the only way i'm going
Caption: to get to do that is by emceeing so i
Caption: started emceeing last year and then this
Caption: year i get to be on the stage so that's
Caption: really exciting
Caption: thank you everybody for coming along to
Caption: my session i know we've got a whole
Caption: bunch of amazing sessions to choose from
Caption: at the moment so i feel very special
Caption: that out of nine people you thought i
Caption: was the most interesting
Caption: i would like to start off by
Caption: acknowledging the traditional custodians
Caption: of this land the wajak people of the
Caption: noongar nation
Caption: i would also like to give a big shout
Caption: out to our sponsors without whom we
Caption: couldn't do this event thank you very
Caption: much to our amazing sponsors
Caption: and today i'm here to talk to you about
Caption: ducks
Caption: which was originally titled being a more
Caption: sustainable you but
Caption: i feel the ducks part is the most
Caption: important part of it
Caption: so when i first wrote this talk
Caption: i was look talking about being more
Caption: sustainable but rather than the you know
Caption: get rid of plastic straws and contain
Caption: just
Caption: environmental kind of sustainability
Caption: i looked at our own
Caption: sustainability
Caption: and had a look at the things that i
Caption: learnt over the years the mistakes that
Caption: i've made
Caption: the mistakes that i've kept making
Caption: and
Caption: thought i'd put together a bit of a
Caption: presentation to share
Caption: what i've learned
Caption: so
Caption: usually
Caption: when things are busy
Caption: like when i'm running a conference
Caption: i also don't
Caption: listen to my own advice as well so if
Caption: you feel like i sound like i know what
Caption: i'm talking about i'm still learning
Caption: just as much as the rest of you
Caption: so hi my name is amy as cairo has said
Caption: i'm a front-end developer i run a
Caption: business and work part-time for another
Caption: company i'm also a conference addict and
Caption: has spent as much time as possible
Caption: traveling the world speaking at and
Caption: running workshops at conferences
Caption: in my free time you know all the time i
Caption: have left
Caption: i love taking part in the perth
Caption: community
Caption: i'm an organizer for the perth azure
Caption: user group
Caption: and vice chair and director of
Caption: conference content for ddd purse if
Caption: you've heard of it
Caption: now
Caption: as you could probably imagine
Caption: or if you saw me this morning actually
Caption: witnessed in person
Caption: i'm often busy i'm often juggling
Caption: multiple things and i'm often overloaded
Caption: usually my fault and therefore stressed
Caption: because of it
Caption: but there are things that i've learned
Caption: things that i can help do to make it
Caption: easier and to manage my mental health so
Caption: that i don't burn out
Caption: as i said i often don't learn from my
Caption: mistakes
Caption: and
Caption: i'll often end up making the same
Caption: mistakes over and over even though i
Caption: know better so
Caption: don't feel like i've got a secret that
Caption: you don't
Caption: now
Caption: first off i want to talk about
Caption: burnout
Caption: it's a word that we hear a lot of in the
Caption: industry a few years ago i went through
Caption: a bit of a month i started a new job i
Caption: interviewed and hired a bunch of staff i
Caption: trained stuff i started a new degree all
Caption: while trying to replace my car
Caption: after i had just been physically
Caption: assaulted and i was looking for and
Caption: moving into a new rental property
Caption: oh
Caption: it was also my birthday and i was
Caption: planning two parties
Caption: so
Caption: oddly enough
Caption: at the end of all this
Caption: i burnt out
Caption: but i didn't understand that i'd burnt
Caption: out i didn't learn and i didn't actually
Caption: take time to have a break for myself so
Caption: although i recovered it took me a really
Caption: long time to get there
Caption: several years after this
Caption: i was working at a digital agency
Caption: working 60 to 70 hour weeks
Caption: i was having trouble sleeping i got to
Caption: the point where i was constantly dizzy
Caption: and nauseous
Caption: and
Caption: i recognized
Caption: that i'd experienced these symptoms
Caption: before
Caption: thankfully since then
Caption: i had been to a local meetup that talked
Caption: about mental health and i realized i was
Caption: experiencing burnout and this time i
Caption: decided to actually do something about
Caption: it so i went to my local gp i got a
Caption: referral to see a psychologist and my gp
Caption: made me take a week off work
Caption: while i had my week off work i got a
Caption: phone call from my boss who said look i
Caption: know you're off sick
Caption: can you come in anyway
Caption: and have a chat
Caption: this is clearly going to be a promotion
Caption: right
Caption: i got made redundant with a week's
Caption: notice at a time when noah's was hiring
Caption: for my role right before christmas
Caption: the next day
Caption: i
Caption: had a meeting with the psychologist i'd
Caption: been referred to
Caption: and because he had the referral he said
Caption: you're here for work stress
Caption: how's that going
Caption: and i laughed
Caption: i had no job
Caption: i wasn't entirely sure how i was going
Caption: to pay my rent
Caption: and yet somehow i felt better than i had
Caption: in
Caption: months
Caption: now
Caption: i'm a bit of a warrior
Caption: so this situation where i didn't have a
Caption: job and i didn't really know what i was
Caption: going to do
Caption: really should have been more concerning
Caption: but although i was worried i'd realized
Caption: that there is actually different there's
Caption: different kinds of worry there's
Caption: good worry
Caption: and bad worry
Caption: now the good worry is worry that is
Caption: useful
Caption: this is worry that you can actually do
Caption: something about so in my situation it's
Caption: worry where i can
Caption: apply for jobs and pick up some extra
Caption: work and maybe stop ubereating dinner
Caption: every night and
Caption: steal somebody else's netflix password
Caption: there were things that i could do to
Caption: make the situation better
Caption: from there
Caption: there wasn't anything that i was able to
Caption: do to make the situation better the
Caption: worry wasn't useful and it was turning
Caption: into bad worry
Caption: so
Caption: i taught myself what i attempted to
Caption: teach myself to stop the worry when it's
Caption: not useful
Caption: once again
Caption: this isn't something that i can just do
Caption: i don't have a switch that says okay the
Caption: good worry is done i'm gonna stop
Caption: worrying now if anyone happens to manage
Caption: to do that that would be great if you
Caption: could let us know the secret
Caption: but
Caption: there is often things that you can do
Caption: when you
Caption: when you find yourself starting to worry
Caption: so work out whether is there anything
Caption: you can do to change the situation or
Caption: is this not useful worry
Caption: this was been really useful when i gave
Caption: my first conference talk oddly enough i
Caption: was a little bit worried so i practiced
Caption: i prepared i thought of absolutely
Caption: everything that could possibly go wrong
Caption: and i worked out what i could do in each
Caption: situation i worried
Caption: and then i worked out how i could combat
Caption: my worries
Caption: after
Caption: i had done everything i could do there
Caption: wasn't anything i could do to make it
Caption: better so there was no point me worrying
Caption: once again this isn't a switch
Caption: that i can turn off
Caption: i thankfully at that point in time the
Caption: worry was able to
Caption: that worry helped me to give a really
Caption: good talk i was prepared for the fact
Caption: that there were av issues
Caption: and a bunch of things didn't work
Caption: but
Caption: there's still a whole lot of worry that
Caption: i didn't need to have afterwards
Caption: and if you think
Caption: that i've clearly learnt by now to just
Caption: stop the worrying
Caption: i invite you to organize a conference
Caption: when there's a lot of things to worry
Caption: about so if anyone thinks that i've
Caption: managed to nail this whole you know not
Caption: worrying thing
Caption: try finding a backup speaker two hours
Caption: before a session starts in case anyone
Caption: didn't catch some of our last minute
Caption: agenda changes
Caption: after
Caption: we announced that there had been last
Caption: minute agenda changes
Caption: next i want to talk about being
Caption: productive has anyone here spent a
Caption: weekend
Caption: where you get to the end of sunday and
Caption: you kind of feel like you've absolutely
Caption: done nothing at all
Caption: who here feels bad because they've done
Caption: nothing at all
Caption: cool i've done that
Caption: have you ever realized that generally
Caption: when you've had these weekends it's
Caption: usually after you've had a really
Caption: full-on week
Caption: and you're a bit knackered
Caption: and you kind of need the break
Caption: so i reframed
Caption: my thinking instead of
Caption: i wasn't productive i just watched
Caption: netflix for two days it was
Caption: actually i've been really tired i've
Caption: been really worn out i need the break
Caption: and my body needs a chance to recharge
Caption: so i made sure that i was actually
Caption: finding the time to prioritize me
Caption: and stopped feeling
Caption: like i was
Caption: lazy
Caption: or unproductive instead
Caption: prioritizing me and giving me the chance
Caption: to recharge was something that i
Caption: actually had to do
Caption: now this went a step further after i
Caption: then saw a
Caption: meetup event where someone talked about
Caption: time boxing
Caption: and the speaker actually talked about
Caption: how they time box their own personal
Caption: time these are calendar events that
Caption: cannot be moved they cannot be
Caption: overwritten and this is time that is set
Caption: aside
Caption: for
Caption: me this is me time
Caption: by making sure that i have a conscious
Caption: make a conscious effort i don't feel
Caption: like i'm being unproductive anymore and
Caption: i'm able to look after myself a bit
Caption: better
Caption: now this doesn't have to be
Caption: you know an hour blocked out it could be
Caption: five minutes before you go to bed to
Caption: read a book and have a cup of tea
Caption: work out what it is that helps you
Caption: recharge and find the time for it
Caption: i like to think of
Caption: our
Caption: energy in terms of the zelda stamina bar
Caption: if anybody is familiar
Caption: as long as you don't reach the end if
Caption: you keep resting it comes back fairly
Caption: quickly so as long as you take short
Caption: regular breaks it doesn't take long to
Caption: recharge
Caption: but
Caption: if you go all the way to the end
Caption: and run out of stamina
Caption: it takes a really long time before you
Caption: can get back into the swing of things
Caption: now this might be something different
Caption: for each of you
Caption: it might be some time alone
Caption: if you're an extrovert you might like to
Caption: have some time with friends
Caption: if you're very special like me it might
Caption: be spending time at a conference with a
Caption: thousand other people so find what helps
Caption: you recharge and schedule that in
Caption: this will also change as well i talked
Caption: about how i like to travel
Caption: so it's a little bit tricky for me to
Caption: sit down and have a cup of tea and read
Caption: a book when i'm spending a lot of time
Caption: at conferences so i've worked out my own
Caption: ways that i can recharge when i'm on the
Caption: road whether that's oddly enough staying
Caption: up until 3am catching up with friends
Caption: or watching a trashy movie on the plane
Caption: working out what helps me recharge
Caption: wherever i am
Caption: boundaries
Caption: are a word that we love
Caption: and hate
Caption: when i first started my business i
Caption: prided myself on the fact that wherever
Caption: i was at whatever time my clients could
Caption: call me and i could help them out
Caption: but as my business grew i discovered
Caption: that this isn't super scalable
Caption: i mean it's okay when i have one or two
Caption: clients but
Caption: when i have 20
Caption: i was constantly context switching
Caption: between phone calls and emails and
Caption: actually getting the work done
Caption: i wasn't getting anything done
Caption: but i saw at a meet-up event they talked
Caption: about
Caption: employee the employer employee
Caption: relationship the same as we think of
Caption: romantic or personal relationships
Caption: and so i had to think
Caption: if
Caption: you have a friend or a partner who's
Caption: constantly calling you day and night
Caption: even when you say you can't talk
Caption: who keeps hassling you and won't leave
Caption: you alone
Caption: and doesn't like you spending time with
Caption: your other friends
Caption: does this sound like a healthy
Caption: relationship
Caption: not really
Caption: so
Caption: i implemented boundaries
Caption: i let my clients know
Caption: that i would only be taking phone calls
Caption: if it was urgent
Caption: i let them know i would be answering
Caption: emails twice a day
Caption: and for the most part my clients
Caption: respected this choice they followed the
Caption: boundaries that i had set and the
Caption: working relationship continued well
Caption: the other clients
Caption: is not to say they didn't
Caption: agree to the boundaries because they
Caption: never said they didn't like them they
Caption: just ignored them completely
Caption: kept doing the exact same thing to the
Caption: point that one of them asked me to come
Caption: in and work at eight pm on a monday
Caption: night
Caption: in exchange for beer
Caption: i don't drink beer
Caption: beer doesn't pay my rent
Caption: and i know it's a monday night but i've
Caption: got better things to do so oddly enough
Caption: they're not clients anymore
Caption: as i expanded i was then able to be a
Caption: little bit pickier and apply these
Caption: boundaries and these choices to
Caption: future clients
Caption: a friend wrote a really amazing flow
Caption: chart which i know you can't properly
Caption: read on the screen but if anyone wants
Caption: it i can share it afterwards
Caption: and i was able to step through each
Caption: decision and actually work out whether
Caption: or not i wanted this work is this client
Caption: going to be a pain to deal with should i
Caption: actually do this are they going to
Caption: object my boundaries
Caption: the last lesson
Caption: and my favorite lesson of all is i read
Caption: a book that we've probably seen in
Caption: airport bookstores
Caption: quite a few times the subtle art
Caption: of not giving an f
Caption: and
Caption: while we talked about a lot of obvious
Caption: stuff it did make some really good
Caption: points including i liked one of the
Caption: points which was whether you realize it
Caption: or not you're always choosing
Caption: what
Caption: to give a about
Caption: and so
Caption: i started thinking
Caption: about how i allocate
Caption: my ducks
Caption: there might be a situation
Caption: that
Caption: you care a moderate level about
Caption: like maybe what computer your employer
Caption: buys you or what lunch option you have
Caption: at ddd
Caption: you might choose to give this situation
Caption: three ducks
Caption: ten ducks per situation give this three
Caption: ducks
Caption: maybe there's something that you care
Caption: about
Caption: a lot more
Caption: like
Caption: whether you get a ticket to ddd
Caption: you might give that situation
Caption: nine ducks nine out of ten ducks it's
Caption: pretty important situation
Caption: maybe
Caption: there's a decision but you just don't
Caption: really care about the outcome as much
Caption: you just have no ducks
Caption: left to give it all
Caption: so
Caption: i started thinking about how i'm
Caption: allocating my ducks
Caption: am i giving
Caption: too many ducks
Caption: am i giving two little ducks
Caption: am i giving ducks in places that i
Caption: shouldn't or to people who don't deserve
Caption: them
Caption: because
Caption: we need to be careful about how we're
Caption: allocating our ducks if you give too
Caption: many ducks or in the wrong places
Caption: we may end up
Caption: with
Caption: very few ducks left
Caption: we may end up
Caption: with no ducks left to give at all
Caption: but
Caption: if we're really stingy with our ducks
Caption: we may find that we have a lot of ducks
Caption: to give and nothing left to give them
Caption: on
Caption: and so on that note
Caption: i want to come back to sustainability
Caption: which is defined as the avoidance of the
Caption: depletion of natural resources in order
Caption: to main ecological balance
Caption: and now a couple of those keywords
Caption: avoidance
Caption: of the depletion of resources to
Caption: maintain
Caption: balance
Caption: have a think
Caption: about whether or not you're being
Caption: sustainable
Caption: with yourself
Caption: is the worry good
Caption: or bad
Caption: uh you prioritizing yourself effectively
Caption: and spending time with you
Caption: you
Caption: maintaining boundaries and most
Caption: importantly if you have boundaries are
Caption: you sticking to them and making clear
Caption: that this is this is not a choice these
Caption: are boundaries that are going to happen
Caption: and most importantly
Caption: have a think
Caption: about how you're managing your ducks
Caption: are you giving too many ducks
Caption: are you giving too little ducks are you
Caption: giving them in the wrong places or to
Caption: the wrong people
Caption: because we always need to make sure that
Caption: we're effectively
Caption: allocating our ducks
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: okay i'm sorry i didn't think there'd be
Caption: questions
Caption: amy will be around for the rest of the
Caption: day if you want to talk to her about her
Caption: ducks
Caption: otherwise we've got 10 minutes for
Caption: change over before our next talk begins
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: being beret uh as you can tell by the
Caption: accent i am french very very permanent
Caption: accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also got a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do and who always want
Caption: to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top level is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your career
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: hi everyone welcome back uh we are ready
Caption: to kick off here in quacker for our next
Caption: speaker we've got ben lowry talking
Caption: about offline first not offline mode
Caption: hey everybody uh so yeah talking hearing
Caption: to talk about offline first not offline
Caption: mode like carriage is set
Caption: uh if you don't have any idea what that
Caption: might be related to it's basically
Caption: talking about applications that work
Caption: offline now
Caption: it can be difficult to build an app that
Caption: works offline
Caption: there are a bunch of challenges and
Caption: stuff that we'll talk about as we go on
Caption: and obviously a lot of benefits that
Caption: come with it otherwise why would you
Caption: bother
Caption: right off the bat i want to thank
Caption: whichever ddd volunteer made this slide
Caption: uh it's really nice
Caption: uh the rest of the
Caption: talk is more like this
Caption: good old clicker fun there we go
Caption: so
Caption: nice plan don't expect the flashy stuff
Caption: you just saw
Caption: so
Caption: i'll talk a little bit about me uh i'm
Caption: ben lowry uh lead consultant at telstra
Caption: purple i've spoken i did it a few times
Caption: before
Caption: you may have seen me up there
Caption: or if you're in karen's talk just before
Caption: this i've featured pretty heavily on
Caption: that so um
Caption: you may recognize me there too
Caption: uh
Caption: i want to thank the other sponsors i
Caption: know i think one particular volunteer i
Caption: don't actually know who it was but
Caption: everyone who's volunteered and all the
Caption: sponsors who have gone into making today
Caption: happen it's a big deal
Caption: and the event doesn't happen without
Caption: them
Caption: cool so an offline application what is
Caption: an offline application uh
Caption: well it's an application that works
Caption: offline
Caption: that much is clear
Caption: uh
Caption: we're going to talk about you know why
Caption: you'd want to build one
Caption: what benefits you get from doing it and
Caption: some of the challenges
Caption: that come from that
Caption: in terms of how you'd actually do that
Caption: i'm not really going to get too much
Caption: into specific libraries or frameworks
Caption: it's more general advice mostly because
Caption: there are a bunch of people here you
Caption: might all be using different tech and a
Caption: lot of this stuff is transferable if it
Caption: went specific it'd
Caption: only work for three of you i'd say
Caption: so why won't you want to build an
Caption: offline app a big one is if you have an
Caption: app that needs to be used in remote
Caption: areas
Caption: uh this is a map of
Caption: 4g and 5g if you look for little purple
Caption: bits those are 5g
Caption: what coverage basically from telstra
Caption: so i assume that's bigger than all the
Caption: other ones but i don't know but there's
Caption: still a lot of areas in australia
Caption: particularly in wa where
Caption: you don't get any internet
Caption: so if you're working or building an app
Caption: that needs to work say on a mine site or
Caption: an oil rig or
Caption: a remote community like maybe you're
Caption: building something for water corp or
Caption: something and they need to go out in the
Caption: field and use it then
Caption: there are a whole bunch of places where
Caption: being offline but still being able to do
Caption: your job is really important
Caption: another one might be
Caption: if you have
Caption: internet outages so this graph is
Caption: basically a cloudflare outage that
Caption: happened in june
Caption: uh
Caption: basically you can see for about an hour
Caption: that
Caption: the international after they were
Caption: serving halved now given that cloudflare
Caption: serve about 20 of the internet in
Caption: general
Caption: that all of a sudden dropped to about
Caption: 10. so
Caption: 10 internet just didn't work
Caption: uh if you want to be resilient to that
Caption: and resilience is something we'll talk
Caption: about quite a bit today if you went to
Caption: derek stalking here earlier
Caption: you probably uh have some useful tips
Caption: already i might give you a few more or a
Caption: few slightly different views of that
Caption: but
Caption: what the resiliency gives you is
Caption: actually more than just when the whole
Caption: internet goes down you also get
Caption: resiliency for things like if you don't
Caption: have zero downtime deployments
Caption: or if you
Caption: just have a bug in your code where you
Caption: start returning 500 or a configuration
Caption: error or something like that it means
Caption: that users can keep doing their work
Caption: without worrying that it's not going
Caption: anywhere
Caption: so you have to build the app in a way
Caption: that is resilient but by doing that you
Caption: get a lot of benefits
Caption: [Music]
Caption: the other one is just kind of
Caption: situational
Caption: lack of internet so if anyone got the
Caption: train here this morning
Caption: you may have gone through a tunnel and
Caption: maybe your internet dropped out or i
Caption: know for me personally most of the days
Caption: i go to work
Caption: as i'm leaving my house
Caption: i'll start scrolling through spotify or
Caption: something to find something to listen to
Caption: and then as i leave my house wi-fi get
Caption: the
Caption: you know into the world i guess the 4g
Caption: or whatever then
Caption: my internet cuts out and always says
Caption: you're offline and it's a little bit
Caption: annoying that things don't work in that
Caption: period
Caption: other times you know you want go for
Caption: hiking or something you just find
Caption: yourself in a situation where you don't
Caption: have internet
Caption: it's not really your fault it's only
Caption: going to be for a short time but you
Caption: just want to keep doing your job
Caption: another reason you might want to have an
Caption: offline app
Caption: is
Caption: for security or privacy reasons
Caption: so
Caption: to use an example of something that's
Caption: been in the news a little bit recently
Caption: and the us they
Caption: changed some laws around abortions and
Caption: there were recommendations going around
Caption: to like delete period tracking apps and
Caption: that kind of thing because the data gets
Caption: stored in the cloud and you know maybe
Caption: they can go and
Caption: i don't know petition not position like
Caption: subpoena or whatever one of those apps
Caption: to get all that data
Caption: find out whatever they want to find out
Caption: i don't know nefarious things
Caption: uh if the data never leaves the device
Caption: then you don't have to worry about it so
Caption: much i mean they could still get you a
Caption: device but
Caption: it's more a targeted attack at that
Caption: point so
Caption: and then the final one that i've got
Caption: here is that it's actually oftentimes a
Caption: better experience for users it might be
Caption: faster
Caption: because you don't have to wait for it to
Caption: load all the time
Caption: you might use less battery or less
Caption: network so in
Caption: like data constrained environments
Caption: particularly in you know places like
Caption: africa or southeast asia or wherever
Caption: where data isn't cheap
Caption: that can be a benefit you know you can
Caption: do things on wi-fi and then go offline
Caption: when you're not in wi-fi
Caption: so as an example of how much that's
Caption: quicker
Caption: i have a colleague who worked on a
Caption: an app that has an offline mode
Caption: and they have a multi-step form so at
Caption: the top here we've got the offline mode
Caption: and at the bottom
Caption: offline first application sorry on
Caption: offline and then
Caption: online
Caption: so the reason that it's faster is
Caption: basically because when i click next
Caption: one on goes straight to the next page
Caption: and the other one goes cool i'll save
Caption: what you've just done
Caption: and then i'll take you to the next page
Caption: so without that spinner things get a lot
Caption: faster and and the example this
Caption: colleague gave me was
Caption: that the offline mode
Caption: took about 40 seconds to fill in this
Caption: whole form this multi-stage form or
Caption: whatever
Caption: and the online one took you know 60 or
Caption: 80 seconds or something like that so you
Caption: do get some benefits from having an app
Caption: that works offline just because
Caption: it doesn't actually do as much
Caption: now every application is different and
Caption: there are going to be different kinds of
Caption: offline applications as well
Caption: some of them
Caption: [Music]
Caption: might need to go online periodically
Caption: some of them might kind of a fallback
Caption: that works offline
Caption: and then others are going to have you
Caption: know kind of the full functionality
Caption: offline
Caption: it really does depend on what you want
Caption: to build and what your kind of users
Caption: needs are like
Caption: spotify for example probably lets you
Caption: download or your uh
Caption: or your tracks to play offline
Caption: but you can't use the search function to
Caption: go and find more stuff for example
Caption: that's a compromise they've made and
Caption: that's just what works for them
Caption: so i like to think of it as layering up
Caption: complexity
Caption: at the base level you've kind of got an
Caption: app that's never read only those are
Caption: really easy to make work offline because
Caption: you just download the data and leave it
Caption: there
Caption: the next kind of level is when you have
Caption: data that
Caption: only stays on the device it never
Caption: actually gets any further
Caption: and those again they're pretty easy you
Caption: never need to talk to the network
Caption: everything's fine
Caption: uh you might have some sort of caveats
Caption: to those where for example they
Caption: sync data to online
Caption: when you choose to so you can you know
Caption: export and import kind of stuff
Caption: one of the reasons you might want to
Caption: build one of these apps is
Caption: because it's really important that the
Caption: data is actually always available
Caption: and it's always up to date so if you
Caption: know you're not getting it from a server
Caption: somewhere then
Caption: what you've got on the device is
Caption: actually
Caption: perfect right it's it's the source of
Caption: truth that's where everything goes
Caption: but just because you're not
Caption: online doesn't mean you can't have some
Caption: of the same features that are online so
Caption: if we imagine
Caption: like a first aid app where you can
Caption: download first aid articles or something
Caption: then you go out into the bush and you
Caption: get bit by a snake so you open up your
Caption: offline first aid application and you
Caption: type into the search snake bite
Caption: and then it goes ah you're offline i
Caption: can't return your own results that's not
Caption: a great experience right so you do still
Caption: need some things to work
Caption: [Music]
Caption: the next one is
Caption: pretty classic like graceful degradation
Caption: scenario
Caption: you have an online app that works online
Caption: everything is editable whatever and then
Caption: when you go offline you lose some
Caption: functionality so you can't edit anymore
Caption: but you can still read all the data to
Caption: help you make decisions and stuff it
Caption: might be appropriate for whatever you're
Caption: building
Caption: like an example could be
Caption: a shopping list or something
Caption: where you can download a shared shopping
Caption: list
Caption: and see it but you can't actually make
Caption: changes
Caption: maybe a bad example but it's the kind of
Caption: thing you could build
Caption: the next level would be where
Caption: some data is editable so
Caption: you might only be able to create stuff
Caption: but you can't edit stuff that already
Caption: exists
Caption: and then the last level of kind of
Caption: complexity and this is what we're going
Caption: to focus most on for this talk
Caption: is those apps where
Caption: just about everything works offline not
Caption: everything everything can work offline
Caption: like you can't do video streaming or
Caption: live chat or anything like that
Caption: but if you can do all of your job you
Caption: can go around
Caption: editing things and deleting things and
Caption: completing tasks or whatever then that's
Caption: a good step at least
Caption: so broadly speaking you've got offline
Caption: only and then mixed kind of offline and
Caption: online apps
Caption: so i've got an idea let's add an offline
Caption: mode to our app
Caption: offline mode seems easy i've i've sold
Caption: you on all the benefits right so let's
Caption: go and do it i've already got a to-do
Caption: list app
Caption: how do i start
Caption: well
Caption: the first thing is that you have to
Caption: download your data to use when you're
Caption: offline
Caption: so what does that actually mean
Caption: downloading your data means
Caption: essentially you're going to keep a local
Caption: copy of that data
Caption: and then
Caption: anytime
Caption: you use the app you just read from that
Caption: local data
Caption: it's pretty easy
Caption: the other part of that will be that when
Caption: you make changes you need to sync them
Caption: back up to the server
Caption: so
Caption: there are a few ways you can do this
Caption: a lot of smart people have gone into the
Caption: effort of actually deciding what that is
Caption: there's a thing called a crdt which is a
Caption: conflict-free replicated data type
Caption: and the idea is that
Caption: every kind of local copy of your
Caption: database and the wireless server is
Caption: actually
Caption: kind of like a distributed system and
Caption: you just need to replicate changes
Caption: across them so
Caption: all your cloud providers and stuff will
Caption: probably handle this for you in terms of
Caption: like
Caption: i've got a sequel database or a
Caption: table storage or dynamodb or
Caption: something but the way they actually do
Caption: it is using these crdts so there are
Caption: three broad categories one is operation
Caption: based
Caption: which is essentially like having a list
Caption: of
Caption: operations that you've done so you might
Caption: say i've done a create task in my to-do
Caption: list
Caption: and then you save that for later and
Caption: when you've come back online you process
Caption: all of them and
Caption: go from there
Caption: another one is where you just update
Caption: the the local database you've got and
Caption: then have something that
Caption: basically just sends that up to the
Caption: server something on the server that
Caption: figures out what changed and saves it
Caption: that sounds really cool
Caption: and there are some tools that do it but
Caption: i don't
Caption: actually have much experience with those
Caption: specifically
Caption: and then the other one is just the
Caption: saving changes so you get kind of
Caption: databases that have
Caption: rather than storing the state of the
Caption: thing you just keep a list of changes
Caption: and you
Caption: and essentially send those up to the
Caption: server when you come back online
Caption: now the one i'm going to talk most about
Caption: is the queue because i feel like that's
Caption: the easiest for people to reason about
Caption: it's probably the like the entry level
Caption: kind of offline mode
Caption: it's it's just
Caption: doing what you're already doing but
Caption: saving it for later
Caption: so we'll have a little bit of look at
Caption: some code there's not a lot of code here
Caption: um hopefully it's
Caption: something you can reasonably understand
Caption: even if you don't write a lot of code
Caption: basically we have a to-do list and we're
Caption: going to
Caption: say if i'm online then call the api to
Caption: get the to-do
Caption: otherwise get it from my offline data
Caption: and then return that so
Caption: it seems okay right if you're online do
Caption: this if you're offline do that
Caption: the same kind of approach for an update
Caption: uh if we're online save that to the api
Caption: if we're offline
Caption: then update the local storage
Caption: and
Caption: queue the update essentially
Caption: so we can kind of generalize that to say
Caption: we've got an app that when you're online
Caption: goes from a to b it does x right
Caption: if you want to talk about offline load
Caption: that's saying if you're online do x if
Caption: you're offline do y
Caption: right it's not not impossible it's not
Caption: actually not that hard
Caption: but
Caption: what's the problem with it
Caption: well
Caption: firstly having two ways of doing things
Caption: means that
Caption: you have to make sure both ways work
Caption: you might forget to do one of them like
Caption: have you worked on an app
Caption: with an offline mode where someone goes
Caption: uh yeah that's done
Caption: i just need to make it work in offline
Caption: mode
Caption: or like i said how many of you have
Caption: forgotten to make a particular feature
Caption: work
Caption: offline so
Caption: there's got to be a better way
Caption: and that way is to build an offline
Caption: first app
Caption: so rather than going from the mindset
Caption: where i have an app that i want to work
Caption: offline
Caption: you say i've got an offline application
Caption: how do i make it work online
Caption: basically you're starting from the
Caption: assumption
Caption: that there is no internet and working up
Caption: from there
Caption: now this comes with a lot of benefits
Caption: [Music]
Caption: like i've already talked about
Caption: the biggest one is that
Caption: it's actually simpler to reason about
Caption: when you've got one way of doing things
Caption: so rather than
Caption: saving to the api or queueing it for
Caption: later
Caption: you basically just always queue up for
Caption: and then you have a background process
Caption: that you know saves into the api later
Caption: which you would have already had anyway
Caption: to handle offline mode
Caption: so
Caption: probably the biggest difference
Caption: between an offline first app
Caption: and an offline mode app
Caption: is that
Caption: you're not treating being offline as an
Caption: error condition it's not a special case
Caption: you need to handle it's just how it
Caption: works
Caption: now i mentioned the term graceful
Caption: degradation before that's basically
Caption: saying i've got an app that's good
Caption: and when it's offline
Caption: it can be almost as good
Caption: the other way to look at it which is
Caption: what offline thirst is is saying that
Caption: it's a progressive enhancement
Caption: so rather than having something that
Caption: gets worse you actually have something
Caption: that gets
Caption: better
Caption: so you build a good offline app and when
Caption: it's online you enhance it with other
Caption: things
Caption: that might be that when you go
Caption: to edit a particular item like in your
Caption: to-do list you go
Caption: load the to-do list from the uh from the
Caption: cache
Caption: and then hey i'm online so i might as
Caption: well go fetch it and get the new stuff
Caption: so we'll go through that little bit of
Caption: code again and we'll
Caption: try and change it to from offline mode
Caption: to offline first
Caption: now i said the big problem was
Caption: if this else that
Caption: how about we get rid of the else and
Caption: we'll see what happens
Caption: it's gone easy so now we have an online
Caption: app that fetches the data and then we
Caption: return the offline data
Caption: we've actually missed one little bit in
Caption: here so we'll make room for that and
Caption: that's basically
Caption: when we get the new data we have to
Caption: update the offline cache as well
Caption: now that's done we can target the code a
Caption: little bit get rid of some variables
Caption: because who likes variables
Caption: and the code's you know pretty simple if
Caption: you're online do this
Caption: and then always return the offline data
Caption: i mentioned before that waiting for
Caption: things actually makes it slower
Caption: so you can see these async and away
Caption: words
Caption: if you're not familiar async
Caption: just says that you can use the await
Caption: keyword and the awake keyword just
Caption: actually waits for it so
Caption: the program will stop and wait for that
Caption: thing to respond
Caption: if we just
Caption: get rid of that
Caption: it no longer waits for that response so
Caption: we don't have that issue where it's
Caption: slower because you're online
Caption: now whether or not you can actually do
Caption: this is going to depend on
Caption: probably a framework or something that
Caption: you're using
Caption: in react you might write a hook that
Caption: abstracts that away
Caption: that's primarily what i write so
Caption: i don't know all the others exactly but
Caption: other reactive frameworks like swift ui
Caption: or uh reactive ui
Caption: or spelled
Caption: i actually have similar concepts right
Caption: where you can just update this behind
Caption: the scenes and then show the new
Caption: version we can look at our update as
Caption: well
Caption: and we go
Caption: now we've got that if else but we'll
Caption: tackle it slightly differently
Caption: instead of
Caption: relying on updating this thing as it's
Caption: happening
Caption: we've already built a robust solution to
Caption: handle those background updates and the
Caption: robustness of that is very important
Caption: we'll talk more about that later
Caption: so why not just use that we can get rid
Caption: of this whole section entirely
Caption: and we're left with something pretty
Caption: simple right we update the offline data
Caption: and then we schedule the update for
Caption: later
Caption: this idea of updating the offline data
Caption: is actually really interesting
Caption: has anyone heard of optimistic ui or
Caption: optimistic updates
Caption: a couple of people so that's the idea
Caption: basically that
Caption: because it feels slow to wait all the
Caption: time let's just update this thing with
Caption: the expectation that it works
Caption: now that is something that happens in
Caption: online apps as well it's kind of
Caption: essentially an offline app because
Caption: otherwise you're always looking at old
Caption: data
Caption: but online apps do this as well to try
Caption: and feel
Caption: faster they basically want that offline
Caption: experience
Caption: where things just work you know so that
Caption: there are lots of tools now to go and do
Caption: those optimistic updates uh they get
Caption: built into query libraries like apollo
Caption: client or route query or things like
Caption: that
Caption: again i mainly work in react so those
Caption: are my examples
Caption: so i painted a pretty rosy picture about
Caption: you know how easy it is to make an
Caption: offline app and there are a bunch of
Caption: challenges
Caption: we're going to talk about them a fair
Caption: bit
Caption: after i've had a drink
Caption: so when you talk about offline apps one
Caption: of the big ones that big challenges that
Caption: people will raise
Caption: is the idea of getting a merge conflict
Caption: now developers are pretty familiar with
Caption: merge conflicts because we get them
Caption: all the time when we're writing code
Caption: and
Caption: you won't find many people in the room
Caption: who actually enjoy that process
Caption: but
Caption: it's not necessarily as big a deal as
Caption: people think it is with an offline app
Caption: so i'll just run through a little bit of
Caption: what a most conflict is because it's a
Caption: complicated idea if you're not familiar
Caption: basically emerge conflict happens when
Caption: two people change the same thing around
Caption: the same time
Caption: so
Caption: in this case we've got alice and bob
Caption: alice opens a thing saves our changes
Caption: and in that in between phase
Caption: bob has also opened the thing and he
Caption: saved some changes
Caption: now when you get to the end if they've
Caption: made different changes
Caption: you need to figure out
Caption: what to do essentially so there's a kind
Caption: of an important line we can draw in the
Caption: sand which is
Caption: when that first person saves it
Caption: the person who goes after that will get
Caption: a problem
Caption: now i've got the lines
Caption: roughly in this kind of range but really
Caption: they can be anywhere
Caption: essentially if you open it before
Caption: that dotted blue line and you save it
Caption: after that dotted blue line then you
Caption: have a problem if you open it and save
Caption: it before
Caption: the other person gets the problem
Caption: if you open it after then you're already
Caption: getting the latest updates anyway so
Caption: you're not going to get that merge
Caption: conflict scenario
Caption: the thing is for an offline app
Caption: it's not so much about when you open it
Caption: and when you save it
Caption: it's more like when you were last online
Caption: to get the version at the beginning
Caption: and then when you come back online at
Caption: the end
Caption: so the time frame for actually getting a
Caption: merge conflict when you have an offline
Caption: app it's quite a lot bigger
Caption: but the problem is existing no matter
Caption: what
Caption: you know
Caption: even if it you've got a thing that takes
Caption: 10 seconds to fill out that's still a 10
Caption: second window where someone might open
Caption: it
Caption: and hit this problem so
Caption: you already do something about merge
Caption: conflicts
Caption: you probably just haven't thought about
Caption: it
Caption: uh common things that you might find
Caption: there would be that
Caption: the last update wins
Caption: because they made the change last so
Caption: just overwrite whatever was in there
Caption: with what they put
Caption: hopefully
Caption: uh some of the changes will be the same
Caption: so it actually doesn't matter if that if
Caption: that happened or not
Caption: but there are other approaches you can
Caption: use where rather than say hey here's
Caption: this whole
Caption: thing you know here's a title and
Caption: description and some tags
Caption: on how to do
Caption: go and replace whatever was there you
Caption: could actually just say all right you
Caption: changed the description
Caption: so let's update the description
Caption: and that limits the amount of merge
Caption: conflicts you'll get
Caption: and the idea behind that's kind of like
Caption: a a patch operation
Caption: um it's a http patch keyword and a rfc
Caption: and all this fun stuff around that
Caption: but basically most conflicts are a
Caption: problem and you do need to think about
Caption: them but they're already a problem so
Caption: going offline doesn't really change it
Caption: except that you might hit it more
Caption: another one is
Caption: api
Caption: versioning and backwards compatibility
Caption: and those kind of concerns
Caption: because you may have had an app that was
Caption: you know last online
Caption: three weeks ago if you've changed the
Caption: api in that three week period
Caption: and done a breaking change then
Caption: anyone who comes back online from three
Caption: weeks ago
Caption: you know the things they're trying to do
Caption: won't work because
Caption: there might be missing required fields
Caption: or that kind of thing right
Caption: so it becomes more important that you
Caption: accept um
Caption: backwards compatible like old versions
Caption: of stuff so i don't know you add a new
Caption: field to your
Caption: to-do that's called assignee or
Caption: something
Caption: and then if you make it a required field
Caption: anyone who doesn't provide messiani
Caption: it'll fail that's kind of a problem
Caption: right so you still need a way for
Caption: someone to do
Caption: their job without that field and a
Caption: common approach to that is having api
Caption: versioning there are a bunch of other
Caption: ways as well but
Caption: again that's going to depend on what you
Caption: uh how your app works
Caption: you'll notice a common theme around
Caption: these that they're all related to
Caption: handling errors because when everything
Caption: works
Caption: everything works and everything's easy
Caption: the problem is when there are problems
Caption: so another one is things like field
Caption: validation you know
Caption: if you have
Caption: a required field that you've added
Caption: whether it existed before or exists
Caption: later
Caption: essentially
Caption: if you rely on the server to validate
Caption: these requests that you're making
Caption: before like rather than letting the
Caption: client do it that means your offline
Caption: user has to wait potentially weeks until
Caption: they actually try and do the thing
Caption: and then it fails so that's a problem
Caption: because
Caption: to go and add a required field
Caption: when you press submit is
Caption: pretty easy right
Caption: but if you're revisiting it weeks days
Caption: hours even later
Caption: it's a lot harder to to know what the
Caption: right thing to put in is the
Caption: put in there is
Caption: so i talked about the um
Caption: the offline queue or the queue of
Caption: changes to make so we've got a little
Caption: animation thing that i'm pretty proud of
Caption: that i made here basically showing that
Caption: process so this little box is going to
Caption: be our magical processor and all the
Caption: little
Caption: rectangles
Caption: uh other things we're going to do with
Caption: them so we start by pressing one and we
Caption: take the next one process that
Caption: take the next one and it's failed
Caption: so
Caption: if you went to derek's talk earlier he
Caption: talked a lot about you know retries and
Caption: timeouts and exponential back off and
Caption: those kind of things
Caption: and yeah you probably do want to retry
Caption: these requests because they might just
Caption: be intermittent errors
Caption: if they're not intermittent errors then
Caption: you retry it and it will always fail so
Caption: what do you do
Caption: if you talk about a queue then there's
Caption: this idea that you process them in the
Caption: order they came in but this one is now
Caption: stuck
Caption: so you need something to essentially
Caption: put that aside
Caption: and then
Caption: you can continue processing the rest of
Caption: them
Caption: now you're not done yet
Caption: that one that you didn't process
Caption: is still
Caption: [Music]
Caption: valid it's still something that someone
Caption: tried to do and it didn't work so you
Caption: need a way for them to resume that
Caption: it'll depend on again what the app is
Caption: and
Caption: what you expect it to do
Caption: but
Caption: basically we need to try and reprocess
Caption: it again in a different way so that
Caption: might be saying you can go back in and
Caption: edit and try again
Caption: or you
Caption: save it to some api and get an admin
Caption: team to process them
Caption: or you just roll it back and say hey
Caption: sorry we couldn't do that throw it away
Caption: again depends on what your data is
Caption: but
Caption: the kind of robustness of this process
Caption: is is really important because
Caption: it's called your app now so whereas
Caption: before in offline mode it may have been
Caption: there
Caption: and you didn't spend all of your effort
Caption: building it
Caption: you know maybe you get some problems and
Caption: and it's sort of okay because when
Caption: they're online it works
Caption: but for an offline first app this is the
Caption: only way you get those updates happening
Caption: so
Caption: again make it robust
Caption: uh you need to think about things like
Caption: having an item potency on your requests
Caption: for example if this was a delete that
Caption: failed because
Caption: the thing was already deleted you could
Caption: go well you're trying to delete it and
Caption: it's deleted so it's fine and just mark
Caption: it as successful basically
Caption: and you might also have the
Caption: dependent requests in here so let's say
Caption: this was a create
Caption: and then later i had an update that
Caption: update would also fail because it's got
Caption: nothing to update now so
Caption: they might you might finally get a few
Caption: of these things happening
Caption: uh another problem is when you have a
Caption: patchy internet connection or an
Caption: unreliable connection rather than
Caption: being just offline
Caption: that's actually kind of worse
Caption: you could look at the things like
Caption: on your device they often have
Caption: indicators that say whether you're
Caption: online or offline
Caption: but how reliable are they actually
Caption: uh you might want to put in something
Caption: like a health check endpoint on your api
Caption: where you can call that to see
Caption: like the device says i'm online but can
Caption: i actually call the apis that i need to
Caption: call
Caption: and then you know base it on that
Caption: you might want to consider
Caption: having
Caption: the app like manually try and sync up
Caption: rather than doing it automatically so
Caption: the user can say yeah i want to sync now
Caption: again that doesn't work for everyone but
Caption: it's an approach that you could take
Caption: to handle this problem so
Caption: rather than just
Caption: responding to being online you can wait
Caption: until the person
Caption: is like yeah i'm back in the office now
Caption: so i can
Caption: do this thing and it should work
Caption: another thing is when you have an
Caption: offline app
Caption: you probably need to tell your users
Caption: that it's offline and
Caption: uh
Caption: you could say something like you're
Caption: offline
Caption: but do they know what that actually
Caption: means so
Caption: rather than just say you're offline you
Caption: might want to
Caption: change it up a little and say something
Caption: like
Caption: you're offline changes will be saved
Caption: when you're back online
Caption: that kind of hints that
Caption: oh i'm not done just because i think i'm
Caption: done
Caption: there's something else i'll need to do
Caption: again you talk to whoever about the
Caption: exact wording there but
Caption: there's that kind of idea where
Caption: telling them what the state is doesn't
Caption: help tell them what they can do about it
Caption: and then as you go through you might say
Caption: we've got three changes pending upload
Caption: or uh
Caption: we've uploaded five of eight of your
Caption: changes
Caption: or you know all changes are saved at the
Caption: end
Caption: just to help the users understand that
Caption: yes you're offline
Caption: and what does it mean
Caption: for you now you know are you done yet
Caption: when you get this kind of message it's
Caption: like oh cool everything i've saved
Caption: everything i've changed has been saved
Caption: so i can go about my day everything's
Caption: normal
Caption: another one that will be affected by
Caption: having an offline app
Caption: is that
Caption: the security posture
Caption: of your app changes
Caption: um
Caption: because you're getting all this data
Caption: onto your device
Caption: it's potential that someone else could
Caption: get that data off the device
Caption: so you might want to think about things
Caption: like encryption
Caption: uh if that's important
Caption: if you do have encryption then
Caption: where do you store the encryption keys
Caption: uh if they're also on the device then
Caption: it might be a little
Caption: i don't know pointless to have the keys
Caption: stored with the data
Caption: so you think about how that's going to
Caption: work for you another big one is
Caption: if you have shared devices
Caption: let's say yeah in a workplace it might
Caption: be there's a kiosk thing that people use
Caption: to do a job
Caption: and when someone shift ends they hand it
Caption: over to someone else and they'll go do
Caption: their job too
Caption: so if there's
Caption: kind of user data on there you might
Caption: need to think about
Caption: keeping it separate from the other
Caption: user's data
Caption: it's going to depend right maybe it's
Caption: fine for them to see it maybe it's not
Caption: really user sensitive but if you're
Caption: storing
Caption: you know their name or date of birth or
Caption: something somewhere
Caption: then i don't know you might want to hide
Caption: it as well so that's where encryption
Caption: would come in and
Caption: all the other fun things
Caption: and then another
Caption: kind of complicated issue is that most
Caption: of the apps that we build especially if
Caption: you're going for you know enterprise
Caption: kind of clients or whatever
Caption: you'll need some kind of authorization
Caption: and authentication some like login
Caption: stuff
Caption: now when you're
Caption: online you can log in and get refresh
Caption: tokens and you know have a token
Caption: lifetime that lasts an hour
Caption: and then you go
Caption: and get a refreshed version every hour
Caption: so that you don't never run out right
Caption: if you're offline you can't do that
Caption: anymore so
Caption: you might need to think about how you
Caption: need to relax those those rules all
Caption: those guidelines
Caption: just to handle that scenario so
Caption: you might let people in if their token
Caption: has expired
Caption: and maybe only for a certain amount of
Caption: time
Caption: but it's probably something you need
Caption: otherwise they can't go offline for more
Caption: than an hour right so
Caption: it would depend
Caption: again
Caption: on the consultant so it always depends
Caption: but
Caption: if you think about how what it means for
Caption: you you know maybe you let people in
Caption: and then before you actually save
Caption: anything you do go and get that new
Caption: token so that it all works
Caption: but that's the sort of thing you need to
Caption: think about
Caption: another one i've i've got another
Caption: challenge is if you want to build
Caption: an offline web app so you could have
Caption: like a mobile app which has its own
Caption: challenges potentially
Caption: but a web app is probably even bigger
Caption: because the convention is that you would
Caption: download everything essentially every
Caption: time you visit the app
Caption: you know you might have caching of style
Caption: sheets and stuff
Caption: through your cdn
Caption: but if you're going to have a fully
Caption: offline app you need to have that data
Caption: saved on the device
Caption: always
Caption: so there are things to help you with
Caption: that now like if you build a progressive
Caption: web app for pwa
Caption: then you get
Caption: a lot of that stuff built in you have a
Caption: service worker
Caption: download so for later right it's not
Caption: impossible but it is a little bit more
Caption: difficult probably than a native app
Caption: because native apps let you download all
Caption: that stuff ahead of time anyway you know
Caption: you download your app from the app store
Caption: and it's
Caption: 50 megabytes or whatever it is and all
Caption: the stuff that you need there is
Caption: included
Caption: whereas on the web you download that
Caption: every time
Caption: and then the last sort of challenge
Caption: that i've
Caption: i've got to cover i guess is uh
Caption: those features that just won't work so
Caption: you know this is
Caption: video streaming right that's not going
Caption: to work you can't build
Caption: teams or
Caption: zoom
Caption: if you're going for an offline app
Caption: those features just won't work so there
Caption: are there are limits
Caption: now
Caption: we've talked a bunch about the benefits
Caption: and the challenges that have come with
Caption: this
Caption: uh
Caption: we talked about why you might want to
Caption: build one so if you want to be used in
Caption: remote areas
Caption: or
Caption: just in situational offline times you
Caption: know someone's probably got a wi-fi only
Caption: tablet or something
Caption: if you wanted to bring that here and it
Caption: didn't work because you didn't connect
Caption: to the
Caption: venue wi-fi or the venue wifi was bad
Caption: then you'd have a bad time
Caption: and the benefits i guess are that
Caption: you get a better experience for users
Caption: they can use your app
Caption: in more ways in more places
Caption: and yeah we have to acknowledge that
Caption: there are challenges with that so
Caption: i'm not saying it's easier to build an
Caption: offline app than an online one
Caption: but if you think that you're going to
Caption: build an offline app
Caption: or
Caption: you know you're going to build an
Caption: offline app or even if you just want to
Caption: build an offline app
Caption: then
Caption: it's definitely easier to adopt that
Caption: online
Caption: sorry offline first
Caption: mindset
Caption: and treat it as the normal rather than
Caption: trying to
Caption: um
Caption: trying to handle it later you know it's
Caption: easy to know upfront what you're
Caption: building and build it from the beginning
Caption: so that's all i've got today
Caption: i didn't think i'd have time for
Caption: questions but i think i actually do so
Caption: if anyone does have a couple
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: uh anybody
Caption: if not you got lunch yes
Caption: hello don't know if they might be call
Caption: out and i'll repeat
Caption: cool so the question was
Caption: how would basically how do you encrypt
Caption: data on the client side
Caption: uh
Caption: so
Caption: there are many ways to encrypt let's
Caption: assume you've got like a public private
Caption: key pair or something which is a pretty
Caption: standard way to do it
Caption: you would
Caption: essentially probably sit
Caption: rather than
Caption: getting the data
Caption: on your device
Caption: you would download it in encrypted
Caption: format
Caption: um i would expect
Caption: and then
Caption: have something on your device to decrypt
Caption: it so if you have a private public key
Caption: for example the private key can stay on
Caption: the server public key on your device the
Caption: way those two things work is that
Caption: anything encrypted by the private key
Caption: can be decrypted by the public key and
Caption: you can verify that that's where it came
Caption: from so that does kind of give you that
Caption: option to to download the data
Caption: if you're going to do something like
Caption: encryption that will
Caption: probably dramatically slow down the app
Caption: because you'll have to decrypt it
Caption: all the time and there are going to be
Caption: gaps where it's in memory and stuff so
Caption: when they talk about those kind of hacks
Caption: like um i'm trying to get the names of
Caption: them but they have all these memory
Caption: overflow like buffer overflow attacks
Caption: and stuff you're probably still gonna be
Caption: vulnerable to that kind of stuff it's
Caption: not a perfect solution but there's
Caption: something there right
Caption: cool another one
Caption: yep
Caption: yeah so
Caption: when we stopped waiting for the response
Caption: and we just kind of updated the
Caption: background
Caption: uh
Caption: yeah like like you said you would get
Caption: your style data first and then you'd
Caption: replace it with the new data when it
Caption: came in so it wouldn't always have
Caption: changed and you might see no difference
Caption: but yeah if it did change you'd have to
Caption: handle that so again that's going to
Caption: depend how you want to handle it
Caption: if you're okay with it being
Caption: you know initially stale data and then
Caption: getting the updated data i guess if you
Caption: don't fetch that data then you would
Caption: always get a stale one
Caption: yeah so the idea being that
Caption: if you
Caption: kind of do that process will you update
Caption: it after the fact that there's stale
Caption: data does it always make sense to do
Caption: that
Caption: so
Caption: yeah
Caption: so something like let's say in the top
Caption: right you've got a user avatar or
Caption: something right if that just updates
Caption: randomly it doesn't matter
Caption: if you've just clicked to open something
Caption: and that updates later like i said it
Caption: might be jarring where
Caption: everything changes on them you know
Caption: you'll have to decide what works for you
Caption: potentially you just update lists of
Caption: things like that so you see the old list
Caption: first and then the new one loads in
Caption: there are kind of
Caption: balances i guess
Caption: it depends but i hate to say that all
Caption: the time but it generally does depend
Caption: cool one more maybe hello
Caption: sorry
Caption: um
Caption: i don't have any particular thoughts on
Caption: that i guess um
Caption: if it's
Caption: capable of being offline which is
Caption: everything right they've all got an
Caption: airplane mode
Caption: um
Caption: yeah okay yep so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: if i guess there's something that's
Caption: probably meant to talk about but didn't
Caption: um
Caption: if you're gonna download gigabytes of
Caption: data then you're probably gonna have a
Caption: bad time because it's all gonna be on
Caption: the device so think about
Caption: maybe you only load the last month of
Caption: data or something like that you don't
Caption: necessarily need everything from history
Caption: um
Caption: you might just need stuff that's
Caption: relevant to do your job today while
Caption: you're offline so it could be a very
Caption: small set or it could be quite a large
Caption: set of things you actually need to
Caption: download
Caption: cool all right i think we're probably
Caption: done
Caption: it's lunch next i'll wait up there and
Caption: if you have more questions come see me
Caption: otherwise enjoy your food
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you ben
Caption: as ben mentioned we do have lunch time
Caption: now so you can head out into the foyer
Caption: the food is organized by the number
Caption: that's on your lanyard so have a look at
Caption: the sticker and you should be able to
Caption: find your queue
Caption: and we'll see you in an hour for the
Caption: panel sessions
Caption: [Music]
Caption: and then
Caption: bye
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: nerds nerding what we're doing is we're
Caption: talking to people all over the world
Caption: because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join
Caption: someone
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is
Caption: you need a professional bodyguard
Caption: delivered to your door in less than half
Caption: an hour you've got it buddy but without
Caption: an app ain't no bodyguard getting
Caption: delivered nowhere so where are we with
Caption: that uh the app is almost ready uh we
Caption: just need three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up
Caption: steven we can do this
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: do
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that when they see when they
Caption: see the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm josh nay i'm a test engineer
Caption: they call me gesture because i always
Caption: have a smile on my face whatever
Caption: situation i'm in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by jackson i am french
Caption: very very prominent accent
Caption: so the berry completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a fast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: whatever you need to progress in your
Caption: career you have got everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: god
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can't you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: is nerd's nerding what we're doing is
Caption: we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: business
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott handsome
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better and we found the perfect outfit
Caption: to wear to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um okay you can you can
Caption: see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: yes
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers
Caption: it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: alright
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: do
Caption: mark where are you mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hansman and i was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our focus
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me jester because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring be better built
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities you
Caption: know whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: so
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: what we're doing is we're talking to
Caption: people all over the world because we're
Caption: stuck in our poses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: all right
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: do
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: is nerd's nerding what we're doing is
Caption: we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our focus
Caption: like dream come true i've always wanted
Caption: to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: yes
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting we did it it's done already
Caption: yep i think our customers are gonna love
Caption: it i got a real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer oh
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our focus
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that when they see when they
Caption: see the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow
Caption: but i also got a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top line
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in
Caption: the it industry in general
Caption: top roll is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your
Caption: carrier you are in the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: good afternoon everyone and welcome to
Caption: one of two panels we've got going today
Caption: this one is the ask me anything panel
Caption: if you hadn't read that on the screen
Caption: already if you are looking for our
Caption: inclusive working panel i suggest you
Caption: have a look in the billiard or river
Caption: room at the other end of the building
Caption: i'd like to take a quick um
Caption: moment to again thank the wonderful
Caption: sponsors that have helped put on ddd
Caption: perth this year
Caption: without them we really couldn't bring
Caption: all these wonderful talks food
Caption: everything to you here today
Caption: and with that i would like to introduce
Caption: you to today's panel
Caption: we have four wonderful speakers here
Caption: today and i will let them introduce
Caption: themselves you would have met some of
Caption: them already
Caption: starting with christina
Caption: hi
Caption: hi hi oh okay there it is
Caption: i'm christine aldan i am a brand
Caption: strategy consultant based in las vegas i
Caption: work for arana software i'm a speaker
Caption: trainer mentor i'm a soon-to-be author
Caption: and it's my first time in perth and i
Caption: took a selfie with a quokka yesterday so
Caption: like i'm good like whatever happens from
Caption: there is amazing
Caption: and next up we have sam price
Caption: hello everyone
Caption: i guess at heart i'm a bit of a techie
Caption: so i've had a lot of different roles in
Caption: tech over the last 20 years a software
Caption: engineer architect manager
Caption: um now i'm currently a vp of engineering
Caption: at family zone cyber safety
Caption: but um yeah super happy to be here today
Caption: and it's amazing to see such a turnout
Caption: so thanks everyone and thanks to all the
Caption: speakers and sponsors
Caption: and next up we have julie grundy
Caption: hi there
Caption: am i on i'm on um yeah my name is julie
Caption: grundy i'm a senior digital
Caption: accessibility consultant at intopia and
Caption: head of audit practice
Caption: so for the last however long i've been
Caption: training people in accessibility mostly
Caption: dev teams
Caption: and auditing people including some
Caption: big corporations art projects uh
Caption: everything in between
Caption: and
Caption: in my copious quantities of free time i
Caption: also organize part of organizing the
Caption: local
Caption: perth web accessibility camp
Caption: and finally we have serrata lee
Caption: hi everyone my name is radha and i'm a
Caption: co-founder of perth machine learning
Caption: group
Caption: our goal is to increase the capability
Caption: of ai and machine learning in perth
Caption: our members have
Caption: come from
Caption: different background
Caption: from government
Caption: academia and
Caption: industry so we so far over 2 800 members
Caption: now so hopefully continue to grow
Caption: i used to work in
Caption: consultancy
Caption: helping companies to do the ai work and
Caption: now i focus on medical research using
Caption: computer vision for digital pathologies
Caption: so thank you very much to our four
Caption: panelists
Caption: my name is david miko i'm your chair for
Caption: this panel
Caption: for the rest of the
Caption: session here today
Caption: and i just briefly want to mention slido
Caption: which is the platform that you can go to
Caption: if you haven't already to interact with
Caption: the
Caption: panel today ask some questions have a
Caption: look at the questions that have already
Caption: been asked upvote them and that's the
Caption: way that you can
Caption: interact with these fine folks on stage
Caption: today
Caption: but given that we only have half an hour
Caption: let's kick straight into it
Caption: and our first question which i'm sure is
Caption: very topical uh given the market at the
Caption: moment
Caption: what's the software developer employment
Caption: ecosystem like at the moment if you're
Caption: wanting to hire a full-time developer
Caption: do you recruit locally do you recruit
Caption: overseas do you recruit remotely
Caption: sam you're a vp of engineering you do a
Caption: lot of recruitment what's your take on
Caption: this
Caption: so i think it really depends on the size
Caption: of the organization and the maturity of
Caption: the process of processes
Caption: so particularly if you were to consider
Caption: at the really small and
Caption: attack startup
Caption: they're going to
Caption: be very dynamic it's going to be a very
Caption: fast-paced environment so managing a
Caption: like highly remote or overseas
Caption: particularly when time zones are
Caption: involved uh workforce is going to be
Caption: extremely challenging and not really
Caption: lead to the business outcomes that are
Caption: required at that stage for that
Caption: institution
Caption: on the other hand on the other hand if
Caption: you're like companies like google or
Caption: any other kind of large organization are
Caption: more likely to have rigorous process in
Caption: place and better support for people so
Caption: i think it's sort of a bit of a
Caption: balancing act so i think the larger
Caption: organizations are going to be more
Caption: readily able to
Caption: remotely hire
Caption: and then i think you know in the middle
Caption: there's probably a bit of a mix and a
Caption: bit of a balance
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: uh on to an extremely popular question
Caption: next
Caption: should i add nfts or crypto to my
Caption: software project
Caption: if you do it accessibly i guess that's
Caption: acceptable
Caption: serrata we uh rather um christina i
Caption: believe we talked about this last night
Caption: what's what's your thoughts on this
Caption: matter um i do a lot of startup advising
Caption: and
Caption: um i'm going to say what advice i
Caption: usually give them so
Caption: you know
Caption: if you have something attached to
Caption: somebody who's really popular it's a
Caption: celebrity it's something like that you
Caption: can
Caption: trade it you can sell it you can quickly
Caption: turn it over it's while it still holds
Caption: its value then yes absolutely
Caption: um if not then it's just too risky
Caption: especially for like i said startups who
Caption: are starting these new projects or or
Caption: people who
Caption: maybe don't even quite understand how
Caption: data are transferred along the way and
Caption: the lifetime and the sustainability of
Caption: it i have somebody that i worked with in
Caption: fact who sits he's like chairman of the
Caption: board they formed a nft commission now
Caption: in las vegas and
Caption: uh he's a chairman and um
Caption: he yeah i put this art in here well okay
Caption: but you put uh
Caption: art for a famous artist that has
Caption: significant value already um a lot of
Caption: people that are coming to him are having
Caption: issues because after people pass they
Caption: can't access
Caption: their
Caption: nft they can't access their stuff and
Caption: there's not a system in place for that
Caption: and that's a lot of money that that's
Caption: been
Caption: lost we also in that
Caption: same ecosystem
Caption: had a basketball player who took in like
Caption: two and a half million dollars on their
Caption: discord server and then one day he said
Caption: you know what
Caption: this is just really stressful i'm
Caption: shutting everything down anybody who put
Caption: in fifteen hundred dollars i'm just
Caption: going to give you a signed jersey and
Caption: thanks for playing and he took their 2.3
Caption: million dollars and left
Caption: and it's there's no repercussions for
Caption: that and all of the kids that had looked
Caption: up for to him who didn't have the money
Caption: to invest in
Caption: in what he was offering
Caption: they invested it anyway because he's
Caption: like their cool idol
Caption: he took their money and left and and
Caption: those kids you know they they can't get
Caption: that money back so um i i think that if
Caption: you can turn it over quickly and if it's
Caption: attached to something that's high value
Caption: and you can get that value and extract
Caption: it
Caption: you know within 12 months or so then it
Caption: would be worth it
Caption: otherwise i don't i don't see the the
Caption: use for that we have another startup
Caption: who's trying to
Caption: attach uh grades in schools to follow
Caption: uh the the child and their progression
Caption: through their to college and um i just
Caption: don't think that's sustainable the
Caption: amount of energy and effort that's
Caption: that's required to to track all of that
Caption: it's just it's not there
Caption: and i think it's environmentally
Caption: irresponsible
Caption: well cement so
Caption: okay another really big question
Caption: where will machine learning have the
Caption: biggest impact in the next 10 years
Caption: serata
Caption: um
Caption: it's very tough question even we will
Caption: look back um in the last
Caption: last couple of months
Caption: we have such a big um breakthrough in um
Caption: generative area so i even can't imagine
Caption: how the world going to be in the next
Caption: few months so looking into you can just
Caption: type in a simple um
Caption: test message to describe the scene and
Caption: the computer can completely generate for
Caption: you and also recently just have our
Caption: competition and the machine already
Caption: beaten the human
Caption: so all these changes um
Caption: can be scary and i think one of the
Caption: speakers also talking about defects so i
Caption: think we really need to worry about the
Caption: social impacts what is real or what is
Caption: not real
Caption: and
Caption: for the longer horizons i really want to
Caption: see the medical research continue to
Caption: improve and have a big impact for our
Caption: health
Caption: from i think it's more the regulatory to
Caption: catch up the technology rather than the
Caption: the diagnosis on its own but i really
Caption: want to see that have a better
Caption: improvement in our health system
Caption: all right thank you very much
Caption: i'm going to throw this next one to
Caption: julie
Caption: so what's the first thing that you look
Caption: for when doing an accessibility audit uh
Caption: what do you do when you're building
Caption: something new
Caption: so if i'm
Caption: looking just starting out a fresh audit
Caption: the first thing that i always look at is
Caption: i open up dev tools and the elements
Caption: panel and i look at the quality of the
Caption: html
Caption: that tells you a lot about where to
Caption: pitch the rest of the testing and the
Caption: verification because good good quality
Caption: html is the the basis of what goes into
Caption: our accessibility api and then gets
Caption: passed on to assistive technology
Caption: so
Caption: you can learn so much from that part
Caption: if i'm testing i generally test heading
Caption: structure first because that has a
Caption: benefit for so many people
Caption: if i'm building something fresh i do
Caption: again start with that html
Caption: we sort of sometimes talk about the
Caption: accessibility stack
Caption: being html css javascript and aria it's
Caption: a purely front-end stack
Caption: and it's less of a stack and more of a
Caption: pyramid
Caption: with html giving you so much
Caption: accessibility for free
Caption: that if you get that right then
Caption: everything else that you're doing is
Caption: just enhancing and making more usable
Caption: and extending to a wider range of people
Caption: but that that bedrock if i could give
Caption: one piece of accessibility advice to
Caption: people who don't have time to learn
Caption: accessibility
Caption: learn html really really get into those
Caption: mdn
Caption: definitions and really get to know it
Caption: really well
Caption: okay thank you very much
Caption: i think this next one is a great
Caption: question um and i i might actually throw
Caption: it open to the panel to see um
Caption: maybe if there's multiple insights on it
Caption: but how do you convince your company to
Caption: care about privacy and i assume from
Caption: this perspective we're talking about the
Caption: privacy of its customers
Caption: i'm actually going to jump in here and
Caption: say without being a privacy expert
Caption: i have had experience with trying to get
Caption: organizations to care about
Caption: accessibility which along with security
Caption: is one of those things that seems a bit
Caption: nebulous and fuzzy
Caption: and how do you know when you're doing it
Caption: well but everybody puts it off to care
Caption: about later after they've shipped
Caption: um
Caption: we tend to
Caption: go for you you kind of need a grassroots
Caption: kind of level of support and often that
Caption: comes from one person taking it on and
Caption: becoming a champion but not
Caption: telling other people off for doing it
Caption: wrong but more praising them when they
Caption: get it right and
Caption: being a bit pesky in meetings about
Caption: like oh yes this is an accessibility
Caption: issue i assume you could do the same
Caption: with privacy this is a privacy issue we
Caption: should absolutely be thinking about this
Caption: now
Caption: um and then
Caption: buttonhole the people in charge and uh
Caption: harass them into caring
Caption: because you will not leave them alone
Caption: until they do
Caption: this
Caption: sounds very informal but it's been a
Caption: winning formula for many many large
Caption: organizations
Caption: um
Caption: this is being recorded and being sent
Caption: out so sorry to my clients
Caption: i can cheer in a little bit as well
Caption: because i deal with medical data so um
Caption: it's in view in the organization level
Caption: they already aware the importance of the
Caption: privacy but from the development side we
Caption: also
Caption: cons concerned about we put it on the
Caption: cloud service where is the location um
Caption: we share the responsibility make sure we
Caption: have the right access so
Caption: and also reminding them your your boss
Caption: if they fail to do it they will have a
Caption: big fight from their gdpr so yeah they
Caption: will make the decision
Caption: yeah that's great
Caption: i think it's a great oh sam thanks yeah
Caption: um
Caption: this is a kind of funny one but
Caption: i think
Caption: like what as julie said um
Caption: if you can hire someone whose
Caption: responsibility it is to really focus on
Caption: privacy and keep up to date particularly
Caption: from a legal perspective and what that
Caption: means to your organization and that's
Caption: sort of a huge win but then obviously
Caption: getting
Caption: executive support in that and really
Caption: creating a culture so privacy really is
Caption: a cultural issue so
Caption: it's
Caption: making everyone understand what it means
Caption: to customers
Caption: and
Caption: what it means like what's stored in data
Caption: and then
Caption: rather than i guess
Caption: to use a
Caption: perhaps important but rather than to
Caption: bore people with legal jargon
Caption: um it's really great if you've got that
Caption: champion or sort of
Caption: i guess ambassador to
Caption: sort of
Caption: re
Caption: relay what it means to individual teams
Caption: and how that like provides simple
Caption: patterns for how that they can approach
Caption: privacy in their day-to-day work
Caption: yeah great input from all of our
Caption: panelists there i'm going to change
Caption: gears slightly here and move more to
Caption: individual development and
Caption: the way that that's aligned in the
Caption: market right now
Caption: what's the best thing that i can invest
Caption: in outside of work to make myself
Caption: attractive to an employer
Caption: i do a lot of career mentorship for
Caption: developers specifically and about how to
Caption: lead from within and so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: an investment really is in yourself and
Caption: making yourself look attractive and the
Caption: way that we do that is by helping other
Caption: people and lifting them up you build a
Caption: community around you you build a a
Caption: tribe of advocates for yourself and so
Caption: they're going to be allies they're going
Caption: to be supporters they're going to be
Caption: sponsors and you become
Caption: you know this brand
Caption: that is
Caption: essentially somebody who is a leader now
Caption: you already have a brand whether you
Caption: want to admit it or not right so as
Caption: you're sitting in your team you already
Caption: are represented representing certain
Caption: values you are representing
Caption: how you present
Caption: how you are
Caption: showing up in with your
Caption: address your appearance your attitudes
Caption: you already have a brand the difference
Caption: of course is that you're just going to
Caption: be more intentional about that brand so
Caption: i would advise everybody to go home and
Caption: think about your top three to five core
Caption: values that make you tick and then start
Caption: making your choices your decisions start
Caption: living your life around those those core
Caption: values what's going to happen is you
Caption: start to attract other people who share
Caption: those core values those people
Caption: like what you have they want to start
Caption: doing what you do and in fact they're
Caption: going to lift you up when they recognize
Caption: somebody else doing those things oh you
Caption: should go talk to
Caption: to joe because you know joe does that he
Caption: loves that you should go talk to susie
Caption: susie loves doing that and so suddenly
Caption: you start to create this brand for
Caption: yourself and then you know decide to
Caption: pick two different platforms to put that
Caption: content out that represent your brand
Caption: maybe it's tick-tock maybe it's facebook
Caption: maybe it's just one-on-one speaking with
Caption: people because that's that's what works
Caption: for you maybe you send out some press
Caption: releases i don't know but you can create
Caption: yourself as a brand and you can lead
Caption: within from within you don't have to be
Caption: a leader you don't have to have a title
Caption: um because at the end of the day you
Caption: already have a reputation so it's up to
Caption: you to kind of guide those conversations
Caption: and around that reputation
Caption: yeah thank you very much christina
Caption: so let's say i've built my brand
Caption: and i've got my job
Caption: so
Caption: in perth right now um
Caption: salaries are
Caption: you know growing um there's a bit of a
Caption: certainly been a lot of
Caption: heat in the market so to speak
Caption: so i might throw this to sam first but
Caption: is this just a bubble like is this just
Caption: a temporary thing
Caption: should i be concerned if i'm an engineer
Caption: in the market right now
Caption: good question um i don't have the
Caption: crystal ball uh i think there might be a
Caption: tiny bit of a bubble but
Caption: realistically it's
Caption: my own personal take is that we don't
Caption: really need to worry too much about that
Caption: but just rather focus on ourselves and
Caption: focus on our work and really
Caption: yeah make sure that we're we're being
Caption: our best knees and and i think we'll be
Caption: okay
Caption: i wanna somewhat related note
Caption: so if you're a graduate and you're
Caption: entering the market right now um it's
Caption: obviously a bit different
Caption: for than how it would be a few years ago
Caption: even given covert and remote work and
Caption: and things like that
Caption: does the panel think that we're able to
Caption: give grads enough support in their early
Caption: years in the industry at the moment
Caption: christina what do you think
Caption: i think that if your communication
Caption: processes and the
Caption: way that you're
Caption: organizing in your teams is done well
Caption: with diversity equity and inclusion then
Caption: that's not really an issue people can
Caption: still feel connected as long as we are
Caption: creating systems that um allow them to
Caption: be connected in multiple different ways
Caption: and so uh having uh diverse voices that
Caption: feel like they're being heard if if you
Caption: have that already then you don't have to
Caption: worry about it that's that's not really
Caption: an issue i have many friends who lead
Caption: remote teams all over the world that are
Caption: have never even met in person and
Caption: they're very successful and they're very
Caption: connected and sometimes when they do
Caption: meet up at conferences they're besties
Caption: and it's awesome because they already
Caption: are very familiar with what's going on
Caption: in each other's lives they have multiple
Caption: ways for communicating
Caption: and
Caption: the nuance
Caption: in that
Caption: has to be prioritized the nuance of
Caption: communication has to be prioritized
Caption: through documentation through multiple
Caption: ways of communicating and
Caption: through respect
Caption: okay great answer
Caption: i might throw the next one to serata if
Caption: i'm an application developer but i want
Caption: to move into working with ai or ml
Caption: how best is it to make that move how do
Caption: i start
Caption: now you have the accessibility actually
Caption: really low you don't need to pay for
Caption: anything from the resources you want to
Caption: learn from to the compute power there is
Caption: no excuse not to learn and i can point
Caption: you to a performation learning group and
Caption: i follow um fast ai as well
Caption: i did it myself
Caption: and i continue following i
Caption: i
Caption: just enjoy every moment
Caption: all the new technology what i can apply
Caption: for
Caption: um is this so exciting the world is
Caption: changing so fast but in a in a good way
Caption: so
Caption: come and join us or chat with me
Caption: afterwards so i can point you to some
Caption: resources and fast ai is fantastic
Caption: community
Caption: and there's a
Caption: lot of opportunity to
Caption: contribute to open source
Caption: environments so it also can help you to
Caption: prepare yourself for your next move
Caption: okay i think the next one is a
Caption: probably a good one to throw
Caption: uh over to
Caption: well
Caption: anyone on the panel really but i might
Caption: start with julie because we were talking
Caption: about um
Caption: flying around the place last night
Caption: a number of the panelists here have you
Caption: know flown around the world and talked
Caption: in various cities
Caption: jacob asks is the perth technology
Caption: sector lacking anything in particular
Caption: compared to the eastern states or
Caption: overseas right now or is
Caption: in the era of remote work is that not
Caption: really an issue
Caption: yeah we were talking about this last
Caption: night i
Caption: i'm incredibly biased on this though in
Caption: that i
Caption: don't think that the perth sector
Caption: if there is if there are gaps and i'm
Caption: sure people can identify them i don't
Caption: think that there's anything lacking in
Caption: our capability or our capacity to grow
Caption: and fill those gaps
Caption: in terms of working remotely intopia is
Caption: a fully distributed
Caption: organization so i'm the only employee in
Caption: perth but we have people all around
Caption: australia in new zealand in america and
Caption: in canada
Caption: and
Caption: in general we've found
Caption: the quality of people
Caption: that we find to be pretty similar all
Caption: around so
Caption: again i'm the only one in perth
Caption: until loren came to visit us so um
Caption: yeah i might be incredibly biased on
Caption: that but i do think that there is a lot
Caption: of strength and a lot of resilience and
Caption: creativity in perth so
Caption: if there's any particular
Caption: language sets or skill sets that are
Caption: missing i think that's just a case of
Caption: okay fine we identify them and we fill
Caption: those gaps
Caption: but i'll pass over to people who are
Caption: possibly less biased
Caption: yeah i think it's
Caption: sort of just a function of our
Caption: population really so i think we've got
Caption: everything just in smaller amounts and
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: like
Caption: ddd for me is one of those little sparks
Caption: in the the perth sort of tech scene
Caption: um
Caption: i'd love to see more investment in tech
Caption: and more startups and growth here and
Caption: more conferences like this one
Caption: but yeah i don't think there's any
Caption: fundamental
Caption: lack of skills i just think it's a
Caption: functionality sorry just a function of
Caption: us being
Caption: comparatively small and in a relatively
Caption: isolated part of the world
Caption: okay so we've got about five minutes
Caption: left i'm going to jump around to a few
Caption: fun ones here that i've got in the list
Caption: what's a boring technology that people
Caption: or companies should use more forget
Caption: about web3 and blockchain for a moment
Caption: what's something boring we should look
Caption: at
Caption: i'm raising my mic to my mouth to get in
Caption: first html
Caption: um it's the handy dandy go anywhere
Caption: do anything kind of swiss army knife
Caption: as far as boring tech goes html is
Caption: actually pretty bloody great
Caption: okay i'll
Caption: throw out one um
Caption: any
Caption: any of the languages that are used for
Caption: infrastructure as code so cloud
Caption: formation does anyone like yaml
Caption: hcl for terraform
Caption: i don't know i'm probably going to get
Caption: murdered by a few people after this
Caption: those kinds of things but we need to do
Caption: more infrastructure as code
Caption: for me
Caption: i don't like sql
Caption: i said
Caption: i know people will
Caption: disagree with me but for me
Caption: when i have an interview and people ask
Caption: me my skill or sql and i can do other
Caption: things using other language and i don't
Caption: like sql and also it's an indicator for
Caption: me that would be a very boring and very
Caption: dirty job i'm more doing the cleaning
Caption: more than doing the machine learning so
Caption: sql for me is the keyword
Caption: okay has anyone got a fun war story to
Caption: share from the last year
Caption: in what context
Caption: not any that my clients would be happy
Caption: for me to have recorded
Caption: many war stories but none that are fun
Caption: i think i think we've all been there
Caption: okay
Caption: uh
Caption: well here's a uh here's something that's
Caption: a little bit different
Caption: what is the meaning of life as a
Caption: developer in your eyes and bearing in
Caption: mind that we all know the answer is 42
Caption: what else
Caption: do you think the meaning of life as a
Caption: developer is christina yes i'm super
Caption: excited to answer this i work really
Caption: really hard with my mentees to teach
Caption: them creative problem solving because
Caption: it's all about critical thinking and
Caption: solving problems a lot of times
Caption: the people that i work with just enjoy
Caption: working on things and chewing on things
Caption: and a lot of times they like the
Caption: accolades as well and
Caption: for me i try to help shift them to the
Caption: empathetic side right i'm the emotional
Caption: intelligence woman so i'm always looking
Caption: at how we connect our products and
Caption: services with empathy with
Caption: kindness and with innovation to to the
Caption: people that are using them and
Caption: i try to
Caption: impart into people that those creative
Caption: problem-solving skills those thinking
Caption: skills that often come so naturally to
Caption: people in our industry and they're very
Caption: very valuable and you can sometimes just
Caption: take that for granted because you're
Caption: surrounded with other people who are
Caption: doing that but if you think about the
Caption: those problem-solving skills that you
Caption: have and how you can use the tools to
Caption: really
Caption: work on solving some of these difficult
Caption: challenging problems of the world that
Caption: has a deep and and greater purpose
Caption: that's a fantastic answer so i'm gonna
Caption: i'm gonna end on one i'm gonna ask um
Caption: each of our panelists this question
Caption: uh because it is the most popular
Caption: question on left on the app right now
Caption: we've covered a little bit already so
Caption: i'm going to
Caption: i'm going to riffle a little bit so the
Caption: original question asks what's the hype
Caption: with web3 it feels like it's a waste of
Caption: time and money and has no value
Caption: i'll extend that a little bit
Caption: one of the things we criticize about as
Caption: technologists is we get distracted by
Caption: the next sort of shiny thing how do we
Caption: distinguish the next shiny thing from
Caption: something that actually has value how do
Caption: we actually dig in and understand
Caption: whether that has value uh sam i'll start
Caption: with you and then we'll go around the
Caption: panel
Caption: that's a very good question um
Caption: i'd like to believe that everything has
Caption: value and that the current form is
Caption: likely to change over time but there are
Caption: some underlying principles and so it's
Caption: really just finding that sort of almost
Caption: like product market fit where there's an
Caption: evolution and so what we see now
Caption: is
Caption: might be hard to really
Caption: understand what it's going to look like
Caption: in the future but i wouldn't be
Caption: surprised if we we see
Caption: something that resembles not the web 3
Caption: of today but
Caption: you know a particular application
Caption: going forward but certainly right now i
Caption: can understand why people would be
Caption: feeling a bit dubious about it
Caption: i definitely agree with sam about the
Caption: port and market fit and then adding
Caption: value to the problem but that means we
Caption: actually really need the domain expert
Caption: to understand the problem and apply the
Caption: technology
Caption: is a
Caption: should be a second secondary rather than
Caption: the primary we should more always focus
Caption: on solving the problem and add value to
Caption: the situation the tet is shiny and next
Caption: day they were gone so even the language
Caption: we learned today may be not applicable
Caption: in couple years so don't hang on to the
Caption: technology focused on the problem and
Caption: solving it
Caption: i think there is a
Caption: small
Caption: part of the community that is going to
Caption: enjoy spending time with their their
Caption: goggles on right and there are already
Caption: people in the metaverse who really
Caption: like certain things and and that's where
Caption: they find connection and that's great
Caption: and it's a certain subset of the
Caption: population and so i think
Caption: for that it does have value right for
Caption: people who it's valuable if you have
Caption: skins if you if you can buy certain
Caption: things if you can have okay yeah we want
Caption: to put some effort i can understand how
Caption: companies want to do marketing within
Caption: the metaverse and stuff like that i get
Caption: it but you know the reality is is that
Caption: it's like 10 000 people own a third of
Caption: the crypto and i mean at that point and
Caption: and there's something like
Caption: 50 of the wallet keys are lost like you
Caption: never will ever see them again and so
Caption: with that level there's really it's it's
Caption: not really practical
Caption: for like me what's what's the the
Caption: motivation for me to get into that when
Caption: there's there's 10 000
Caption: people who are already gonna hold it
Caption: there is a small percentage of the
Caption: population that's holding it and then
Caption: what happens is we end up having all of
Caption: these other kids again who can't afford
Caption: it this is um and they're they're
Caption: spending a lot of money and they're
Caption: doing it wrong you can do it right
Caption: though i have mentees who paid off their
Caption: mom's entire house it was you know they
Caption: had a 65 000 mortgage loan and these
Caption: kids paid it off playing esports games
Caption: they're amazing
Caption: um i i have other people who are
Caption: using it to their advantage for testing
Caption: things or for um training during remote
Caption: teams um you know that's that's a good
Caption: use of it will it take over our future
Caption: and oh my gosh everybody's going to be
Caption: into this and we all have to jump to the
Caption: next shiny thing
Caption: no i i don't think so no
Caption: i yeah tend to agree with everybody here
Caption: um
Caption: my own
Caption: thinking on this is very much about how
Caption: when i first started learning to make
Caption: websites it was very much like i can i
Caption: have i can make a thing and put it out
Caption: in the world and other people can just
Caption: show up and look at it and we don't need
Caption: rupert murdoch's permission to do so
Caption: a lot of the
Caption: extra hype comes from people inserting
Caption: themselves as a middleman in a process
Caption: so that they can extract a profit
Caption: i think the real longevity and promise
Caption: of
Caption: computing and software and the internet
Caption: comes from those underlying patterns and
Caption: principles of
Caption: openness transparency
Caption: interoperability and so if those are the
Caption: patterns and principles that you're
Caption: working with and then you learn a
Caption: language
Caption: that lets you work with that to solve
Caption: the problem that you have
Caption: and then some business people can come
Caption: along and think about market
Caption: propositions or something maybe that's
Caption: just i'm just too much of a nerd to care
Caption: about that
Caption: i'm lucky to have one of one of my
Caption: bosses cares about that very much and he
Caption: thinks about that and i don't have to
Caption: worry about it
Caption: but i think
Caption: if anyone is thinking about how do you
Caption: getting back to that question about how
Caption: do you decide between
Caption: what's worth your time learning versus
Caption: what's going to be a flash in the pan
Caption: i think i will recommend
Caption: a talk
Caption: given here in perth a few years back at
Caption: mixing called full stack anxiety full
Caption: stack anxiety by joel khalifa
Caption: and
Caption: i found that talk really useful to me in
Caption: mapping out where i am now
Caption: the goals i want to have the kinds of
Caption: things i want to build and what skills
Caption: do i need to learn
Caption: to reach that goal uh so if uh that's
Caption: for anyone it is on youtube um and you
Caption: should be able to get a hold of it so
Caption: maybe if that's a concern for you give
Caption: that talk a while
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: well with that we have run a couple of
Caption: minutes over so
Caption: it's time to
Caption: break and find our next sessions but i
Caption: would ask first that the audience gives
Caption: our panelists a big round of applause
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: so thank you everyone that concludes our
Caption: panel and our next sessions will be
Caption: starting at 3 15.
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top note
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: good night
Caption: good
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hi everyone thank you for joining us uh
Caption: we are heading into our last session
Caption: before afternoon tea and keynote uh so
Caption: it's very exciting
Caption: our next speaker is megan pusey she's
Caption: here to talk about what video games have
Caption: taught me about designing for motivation
Caption: megan is a phd candidate at murdoch
Caption: university researching video games
Caption: motivation and resilience
Caption: and she's here to tell us about what
Caption: video games have taught her about
Caption: designing for motivation so please give
Caption: her a hand
Caption: thank you all for coming
Caption: obviously a quick thank you to our
Caption: sponsors without which
Caption: ddd couldn't happen
Caption: i'm also working at ibm so i have to do
Caption: the obligatory this is my um personal
Caption: views not that representing where i work
Caption: because i have now just finished up at
Caption: redoc which is exciting
Caption: so
Caption: for those of you who don't know me my
Caption: name is megan i just finished a phd in
Caption: games user research
Caption: now doing user research at ibm for
Caption: enterprise software
Caption: i previously worked as a physics teacher
Caption: and a science communicator for places
Caption: like scitec
Caption: and so i have a bit of a
Caption: varied background
Caption: hence my
Caption: that is why my twitter handle is the way
Caption: it is
Caption: i wanted to start the talk with a little
Caption: thought experiment if i
Caption: had a very thickly
Caption: slathered piece of vegemite toast
Caption: not my ideal ratio of vegemite to bread
Caption: or toast
Caption: uh hands up just a show of hands how
Caption: many people would be quite happy to come
Caption: and eat
Caption: this lovely piece of vegemite toast ah
Caption: quite a few
Caption: keep your hands up what about if i now
Caption: offered you
Caption: five dollars to come and eat this piece
Caption: of vegemite toast anyone willing for
Caption: five dollars what about
Caption: fifty dollars
Caption: okay if you want two hundred
Caption: there's a few people still with their
Caption: hands down but i'm sure you have a price
Caption: in mind to
Caption: you know withstand the very polarizing
Caption: taste of vegemite
Caption: i wanted to use this as an example
Caption: because it's a really good love hate
Caption: relationship
Caption: and some people are more than happy to
Caption: eat vegemite for fun others need
Caption: a bit of a different type of motivation
Caption: so
Caption: things we do for fun
Caption: we have internal or intrinsic motivation
Caption: things that
Caption: we might not do for fun maybe we need a
Caption: bit of reward like money
Caption: that we call external or extrinsic
Caption: motivation and we'll come back to those
Caption: shortly so
Caption: video games
Caption: as a product or an industry
Caption: is made for leisure and as a hobby
Caption: so
Caption: they have to be designed
Caption: around intrinsic motivation and for fun
Caption: so good ux or a good player experience
Caption: is really core to
Caption: the game as a product and doing well
Caption: however
Caption: coming into
Caption: enterprise software or websites or apps
Caption: sometimes
Caption: good ux is a
Caption: nice to have that's added on at the end
Caption: and not the primary
Caption: core of the experience
Caption: but also to be fair we use them
Caption: differently they're more like a tool we
Caption: use to get a job done they're not
Caption: necessarily there for leisure
Caption: so
Caption: comparing the two
Caption: one being mostly intrinsic motivation
Caption: and one being mostly extrinsic
Caption: motivation
Caption: how could we learn some lessons from the
Caption: world of video games and apply them to
Caption: enterprise software or websites or apps
Caption: and i'll just pause here to say i'm not
Caption: going to be talking about gamification
Caption: in turning these tools into games but
Caption: more about how could we tweak them
Caption: to be more intrinsically motivating so
Caption: one of the series that i've done a lot
Caption: of work in and i won't bore you with it
Caption: but basically the theory says that
Caption: intrinsic motivation is made of three
Caption: elements so there's autonomy which is a
Caption: fancy way of saying you have choice and
Caption: control
Caption: over things
Caption: competence which means you feel skilled
Caption: at doing a particular activity or your
Caption: skill is improving you don't have to be
Caption: a master
Caption: at the activity and
Caption: relatedness which is feeling a
Caption: connection to other people or a
Caption: community of people so these three
Caption: things combining together
Caption: help make stuff
Caption: really intrinsically motivating and fun
Caption: to do
Caption: you know being a now being working in
Caption: design love a good how might we
Caption: statement so
Caption: having worked at ibm for a bit now i
Caption: thought well how might we
Caption: as a fun challenge design enterprise
Caption: software to be more intrinsically
Caption: motivating to use
Caption: again
Caption: without turning it into a game because
Caption: it is meant to be a tool
Caption: starting with our first element of
Caption: autonomy
Caption: games usually do this really well one
Caption: good example
Caption: of this is from competitive first person
Caption: tutor games usually this is a screenshot
Caption: from a fortnight menu
Caption: where the game is allowing you to
Caption: completely remap your controller you
Caption: have complete control over which button
Caption: does what
Caption: so you can
Caption: make it to your liking
Caption: not all games do this but the
Caption: competitive games usually have
Caption: do this a bit better
Caption: than others
Caption: and a good example from
Caption: other software that give you good choice
Caption: and control
Caption: is the adobe suite you can completely
Caption: move the menus around change which icons
Caption: are in your menu
Caption: i'm left-handed so if i was to do any
Caption: drawing on a touch screen i'd move all
Caption: the menus
Caption: to the right-hand side and it enables me
Caption: to do that
Caption: not all software does so that's one good
Caption: example of offering
Caption: choice and control in a non-game
Caption: scenario
Caption: another great one is slack and a lot of
Caption: other
Caption: software has a light in the dark mode
Caption: slack goes a little bit further with the
Caption: different color modes
Caption: and if you actually scroll all the way
Caption: to the bottom
Caption: dawn mentioned this in her accessibility
Caption: talk this morning as well
Caption: but there are actually
Caption: a few
Caption: color schemes specifically designed for
Caption: people with different types of color
Caption: blindness
Caption: and
Caption: offering choice and control over things
Caption: that might seem like a really small
Caption: deal to you
Caption: can have a really great added benefit of
Caption: improving accessibility for some of your
Caption: other users that you might not even
Caption: recognize when you first add this
Caption: feature in
Caption: moving on to our
Caption: second strand which is competence
Caption: lots of video games
Caption: do this really well as well because they
Caption: essentially have to teach you how to use
Caption: the game while you're in the game
Caption: one of my favorite games that i've done
Caption: used in my research which was really fun
Caption: is called untitled goose game the
Caption: premise is that you are a mischievous
Caption: goose running around an english village
Caption: causing mayhem
Caption: so in each section of the village you
Caption: get a to-do list
Caption: and as you complete the to-do list it
Caption: crosses off
Caption: that action and different tasks are more
Caption: difficult than others
Caption: so when you go shopping if you put the
Caption: toothbrush in the basket it will cross
Caption: off the just the word toothbrush
Caption: and if the toothbrush somehow comes out
Caption: of the basket it uncrosses off as well
Caption: so it's like reactive
Caption: so games do quest logs missions and
Caption: checklists like this
Caption: really really really well
Caption: and you feel a sense of progress like
Caption: you've achieved something
Caption: also really handy like me if you haven't
Caption: played the game you forget about it and
Caption: come back six months later and you can't
Caption: remember what you're up to
Caption: these quest logs and checklists can help
Caption: you get oh that's right i was trying to
Caption: steal shopping items from this poor
Caption: shopkeeper
Caption: and
Caption: one
Caption: online course i was doing recently
Caption: through the interaction design
Caption: foundation i thought did this really
Caption: well
Caption: in their website all their courses
Caption: follow this sort of layout so on the
Caption: left here we've got their clear
Caption: progression of chapters or lessons
Caption: within each lesson we've got
Caption: sub parts and as you complete them you
Caption: get a nice green tick and as you end
Caption: points by answering questions throughout
Caption: the course
Caption: the blue points sort of float up to the
Caption: progress bar up the top there so you can
Caption: clearly see
Caption: how much you've got left to go until you
Caption: get the little course certificate so
Caption: it's a nice visual reminder of the
Caption: progress you've made so far and as you
Caption: get closer and closer to the end it
Caption: becomes even more and more motivating
Caption: because you're like oh just a few more
Caption: points and i'm finished
Caption: and so yeah they're on the left um other
Caption: places do this really well i liked the
Caption: salonist example but i noticed udemy
Caption: also does this really well they'll have
Caption: a time indicator next to each step or
Caption: segment especially if it's video based
Caption: and that gives you a good indication of
Caption: how difficult or how long the task is
Caption: going to take so i know for me
Caption: if i only have a half hour or so i'm not
Caption: going to start anything too complicated
Caption: because i'm not going to get it finished
Caption: and by offering these sort of
Caption: indicators of difficulty or time
Caption: you can make a good judgment about
Caption: whether you want to start that activity
Caption: now or not
Caption: a bad example
Caption: as a researcher i like doing other
Caption: people's surveys to see
Caption: what they've done i had a professional
Caption: interest i had an etsy survey pop up as
Caption: i was browsing um you can see i was
Caption: browsing pokemon plush toy thingos
Caption: so i pressed sure i'll do your annoying
Caption: pop-up survey and uh this was the first
Caption: question but immediately i kind of
Caption: noticed well i was in the middle of
Caption: doing something
Caption: i'm doing you a favor and you're not
Caption: telling me how long this is going to
Caption: take
Caption: no indication of progress and i've used
Caption: qualtrics before
Caption: same with microsoft forms and i'm sure
Caption: many of the other ones there is always
Caption: an option there to enable the progress
Caption: bar
Caption: which just puts a little bar at the top
Caption: of the bottom to show you a percentage
Caption: of how far through the survey you are
Caption: just a small thing like that
Caption: can help motivate people to complete the
Caption: task same with retail websites and
Caption: shopping checkout baskets you often see
Caption: the steps
Caption: listed or how close you are to finishing
Caption: that purchase
Caption: so about two or three questions in in my
Caption: head and going i want to get back to
Caption: what i was doing how much longer have i
Caption: got left to go i want to quit this and
Caption: just keep doing what i was doing
Caption: i
Caption: was just curious so i kept going and it
Caption: was about five quick questions but i
Caption: could see
Caption: i imagine on the back end there'd be
Caption: quite a lot of churn or a lot of people
Caption: dropping out after that second question
Caption: because there's no indication of how
Caption: long this thing is going for
Caption: in our
Caption: third stream which is
Caption: uh an interesting one because we're
Caption: talking about
Caption: connection to other people and building
Caption: community and immediately people think
Caption: about
Caption: that as being real time or multiplayer
Caption: in the game sense but it doesn't have to
Caption: be
Caption: so i will start with a multiplayer game
Caption: because that's the obvious
Caption: uh i guess
Caption: friendship building or breaking activity
Caption: in video games um one of my favorite
Caption: genres is called
Caption: couch co-op
Caption: this is one example called overcooked
Caption: where you're working as a team of four
Caption: to finish these orders in this level
Caption: they're making burgers and usually the
Caption: levels are set out in such a way that
Caption: only certain people can do certain steps
Caption: of the process so like a team where
Caption: you've got a dev and a designer and you
Caption: can only
Caption: no one person can do everything so
Caption: you're having to yell at one another cop
Caption: the stake what are you doing hurry up
Caption: and pass me the tomatoes where's this
Caption: where's it yeah so there's a lot of
Caption: yelling but it's really fun and you're
Caption: working in this game you're working to a
Caption: clock so you have to do as many as
Caption: possible in the time limit
Caption: to pass the level so i find them really
Caption: fun other people find them really
Caption: stressful
Caption: but that
Caption: designing the levels in such a way that
Caption: one person cannot do the level alone
Caption: helps build that
Caption: teamwork
Caption: and
Caption: one tool i've been using a lot of
Caption: recently that i think has a lot of
Caption: features
Caption: to make real-time
Caption: collaboration online really good and
Caption: there's lots of tools like this one this
Caption: isn't the only one is mural it's like an
Caption: online whiteboard where you can put fake
Caption: digital sticky notes on there
Caption: some of the features i like is that when
Caption: you're all on the same mural you can see
Caption: everyone's pointers it has their name
Caption: next to it so you can clearly see where
Caption: everyone is
Caption: and what they're doing
Caption: if you're a facilitator you have
Caption: facilitator superpowers you can summon
Caption: everyone to view what you're viewing on
Caption: the screen
Caption: you can lock things down so other people
Caption: can't move and mess with your templates
Caption: when you're doing brainstorming
Caption: and so it has a lot of really really
Caption: nice features to enable you to do that
Caption: real-time stuff together really really
Caption: well and
Caption: again
Caption: linking back to choice and control a lot
Caption: of these features you can turn on and
Caption: off if you
Caption: made the mural yourself
Caption: um so often a lot of clients i'm working
Caption: with are not have never used this tool
Caption: before so
Caption: we lock down a lot of things so they
Caption: can't mess with it and
Caption: yeah get them to follow our screen and
Caption: guide them through the process so those
Caption: features are really good for that
Caption: another example of communication in
Caption: games again this is a competitive
Caption: first person sort of game but it's a
Caption: team game so you're working on a team of
Caption: five or six
Caption: and a few other games also do this
Caption: really well but i just couldn't find a
Caption: good screenshot to show it
Caption: so apex legends probably does this the
Caption: best
Caption: it's called a ping system where
Caption: very quickly you have to communicate
Caption: information very important information
Caption: to your team
Caption: so on your controller or keyboard you
Caption: can press a button and there's just a
Caption: standard menu of things and you can
Caption: customize this menu as well but these
Caption: are the most common messages you want to
Caption: share with your team and you can ping a
Caption: particular location on the map and your
Caption: whole team can then see that piece of
Caption: information very quickly
Caption: it's quicker than trying to type or say
Caption: over voice
Caption: often and if you've watched any esports
Caption: they will use a ping system quite a lot
Caption: and they'll be very short and sharp with
Caption: their verbal communication
Caption: um
Caption: the closest i could think of
Caption: like this but not in games was probably
Caption: the whole
Caption: reaction thing in social media and
Caption: in places like linkedin
Caption: it allows you to show
Caption: support or
Caption: show a sense of community quickly
Caption: without having to put effort into it so
Caption: you're like hey yeah well done yay i'm
Caption: excited without having to spend the time
Caption: typing that message in
Caption: one interesting example that i like
Caption: bringing up a lot from video games as
Caption: it's more asynchronous
Caption: is sky
Caption: which is a great game you can get on
Caption: tablets in the switch
Caption: you run around it's single player
Caption: and the dark souls games do this as well
Caption: you can leave a particular item in the
Caption: world
Caption: and attach a message to that item and
Caption: other players can then go and discover
Caption: that item and read your message
Caption: sometimes in dark souls players will
Caption: leave clues about how to defeat next
Caption: boss or watch out for a particular trap
Caption: sometimes it's jokes sometimes it's
Caption: fake information to make you go and die
Caption: in a particular place sky's a bit more
Caption: nice
Caption: as a game it's not uh dark souls is
Caption: pretty punishing
Caption: um but it's this way that they build a
Caption: sense of community and connection
Caption: without it being real time
Caption: and it's a single-player game often we
Caption: think of single-player experiences as
Caption: not being social whereas this is
Caption: a very very social single player game
Caption: i couldn't
Caption: really it took me a while to think of an
Caption: example from
Caption: non-games but i do remember in having
Caption: done some
Caption: writing
Caption: for a website called particle they used
Caption: a service called gather content and
Caption: essentially but i mean shared documents
Caption: do this as well it was really easy for
Caption: people to leave comments on my article
Caption: asynchronously i could log in and then
Caption: see what they had written and then go
Caption: and make the relevant edits or changes
Caption: that were requested
Caption: same with shared google docs or online
Caption: you know office 365
Caption: documents it's
Caption: i think this one is i see it being used
Caption: more and more it's a great way to
Caption: asynchronously work together on
Caption: something without
Caption: doing the
Caption: um track changes in word which i find
Caption: very painful um so gather content's a
Caption: great example of that as well as just
Caption: general shared collaborative documents
Caption: i did want to spend
Caption: two seconds quickly talking about
Caption: competitive
Caption: elements which often come up when people
Caption: start talking about gamification so back
Caption: to the interaction design foundation
Caption: screen they do have a ranking of your
Caption: score and i think if you get the max
Caption: score for the course you can have
Caption: multiple people sitting at first
Caption: and it goes up as you get more points
Caption: and
Caption: the best i've seen competitive done i
Caption: guess
Caption: in a
Caption: gamey kind of sense is in a non
Caption: game game is duolingo which is for
Caption: learning languages
Caption: what i liked about duolingo is that
Caption: competitive things can be really
Caption: demotivating if you're losing especially
Caption: if you have no way
Caption: to get back to the top to get back to
Caption: winning so the way that you and lingo
Caption: combat this is you get a lot of points
Caption: just by participating number one great
Caption: just for trying
Caption: and that you can see that there's a
Caption: limit on
Caption: the leaderboard so i don't know what the
Caption: time refresh time is maybe it's every
Caption: week
Caption: every week they'll refresh and restart
Caption: the leaderboards from scratch so even if
Caption: you were losing one week
Caption: next week you're in with a whole nother
Caption: shot so it's a lot more motivating to
Caption: have that refreshing leaderboard
Caption: and that ability to
Caption: get back um to be potentially winning so
Caption: i think use competitive or look at
Caption: competitive elements with a real grain
Caption: of salt because
Caption: i think you always need to consider the
Caption: losers how is it going to feel to be the
Caption: loser is if there's low stakes that's
Caption: better if there's high stakes it really
Caption: sucks to be the loser is there any way
Caption: for them to come back from losing or
Caption: think about those things as well not
Caption: just the winners motivation's really
Caption: tricky when you start making it
Caption: competitive versus collaborative
Caption: that was all i had time for today thank
Caption: you so much for choosing to come to my
Caption: session i know there was
Caption: many amazing talks on at this same time
Caption: i don't have any time for questions now
Caption: but i'm happy to answer any questions
Caption: that afternoon tea
Caption: or you can just
Caption: tweet me and i'll
Caption: hopefully respond and yeah happy to chat
Caption: but thank you for coming
Caption: thank you so much megan as you mentioned
Caption: it is afternoon tea at the moment it'll
Caption: be our last coffee break for the day uh
Caption: so make sure you're fully caffeinated
Caption: before our lock note coming up
Caption: afterwards thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their i.t needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out and it needs
Caption: to work flawlessly because because i
Caption: don't want to lose one single customer i
Caption: hear you so let's use off zero off what
Caption: now off zero it's an identity platform
Caption: fast easy logins just what the boss
Caption: wants can we make our own authentication
Caption: service come on the ultimate key master
Caption: you know we don't have that kind of time
Caption: we need to confirm identities with
Caption: passwords fingerprint scans whatever the
Caption: users like to use observer can do that
Caption: yeah but it needs to be secure we can't
Caption: have our app compromised by breaches not
Caption: a problem and it needs to scale if we
Caption: get hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you guys stop that's really distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry uh as you can tell by the
Caption: accent i am french very very prominent
Caption: accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: maya where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and joy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring be better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow but i also get a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top 10 of
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your
Caption: carrier you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials
Caption: right people and write opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for you
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: what we're doing is we're talking to
Caption: people all over the world because we're
Caption: stuck in our puppies
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: dream come poses i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: yes
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cathendra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: welcome back everybody
Caption: welcome back
Caption: just all of a sudden got very quiet
Caption: welcome back everybody we are on to our
Caption: last session for today which is our lock
Caption: note
Caption: so very shortly i'm going to hand over
Caption: to chris ferry so chris has a phd
Caption: and does
Caption: a lot of work in the science field
Caption: however he also writes children's books
Caption: now i had an opportunity to see chris
Caption: speak at ddd brisbane a similar event on
Caption: the other side of the country a few
Caption: years ago
Caption: and
Caption: i was actually super impressed with the
Caption: books and thought it was really amazing
Caption: i got one of the books on blockchain so
Caption: now i know everything about blockchain
Caption: from blockchain for babies
Caption: and i also want to say a huge thank you
Caption: to chris uh who received an email from
Caption: me on wednesday morning
Caption: to see if he could come and give our
Caption: keynotes this afternoon
Caption: today
Caption: so big thank you to chris
Caption: for saving us at the last minute when we
Caption: had a few travel difficulties so i'm
Caption: going to hand over to chris
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: yeah so thanks for the invite thanks for
Caption: giving me lots of time to consider it
Caption: um i was going to be here for the tattoo
Caption: conference anyway so
Caption: oh i thought i might as well come by
Caption: yeah so i'm chris ferry i'm an associate
Caption: professor at the
Caption: center for quantum software and
Caption: information at the university of
Caption: technology sydney and that's obviously
Caption: in sydney
Caption: and i lead a research group and we do
Caption: research in
Caption: quantum machine learning
Caption: and quantum control so we do like uh
Caption: low-level
Caption: stuff with quantum hardware and
Caption: high-level kind of blue sky thinking
Caption: about what we'll do with quantum
Caption: computers in the future
Caption: but i thought since i have you all here
Caption: i'll just read you a story
Caption: it's going to be a bit awkward for me to
Caption: try to do this with the book so
Caption: i'll just show you the book on screen
Caption: i think i'll do that
Caption: ah here we go
Caption: okay here we go the cat in the box
Caption: it did not sit well it was far too
Caption: confusing so we sat at the blackboard
Caption: the two of us musing i sat with
Caption: schrodinger dreaming of quantum theory
Caption: but the math of it all made both of us
Caption: dreary
Caption: what was it about
Caption: we were not content
Caption: the trouble came down to the
Caption: entanglement and then a knock at the
Caption: door
Caption: a box but who was it for
Caption: we looked in and saw a cat in a box we
Caption: looked in and saw a cat that talks
Caption: and it said to us
Caption: get me out of this box
Caption: i was happy to see it an extra mind
Caption: right now we needed all the help we
Caption: could find
Caption: and then an idea with the cat's great
Caption: sight it could see a single quantum a
Caption: quantum of light
Caption: an excited atom will decay
Caption: a random condition
Caption: the cat might see
Caption: a super position
Caption: schrodinger went on next we close the
Caption: lid to look in the box is what i forbid
Caption: the cat will see
Caption: and not see
Caption: an odd condition
Caption: the cat will be in superposition
Caption: schrodinger used this cat in the box to
Caption: dream up the first quantum paradox a
Caption: paradox is something that doesn't make
Caption: sense there must be an assumption that
Caption: is causing offense
Caption: the theory has failed schrodinger cried
Caption: we must start all over and swallow our
Caption: pride
Caption: but then i smiled to our own merry meant
Caption: we have the cat box and adam to do the
Caption: experiment the scientific method is to
Caption: test hypotheses so our knowledge can
Caption: grow beyond just the abcs
Caption: through all of this shaking its head the
Caption: cat quietly listened to all that was
Caption: said a quantum superposition the cat
Caption: said with the psy a silly idea and i'll
Caption: tell you why but i must teach you some
Caption: physics and where it applies
Caption: the lesson began i see your intent but
Caption: the most important thing is the
Caption: measurement when i look at the atom to
Caption: see if it's spent i create in the world
Caption: a quantum event
Caption: when measurement acts the atom itself is
Caption: forced to collapse it might stay excited
Caption: it might decay but which it will be no
Caption: one can say
Caption: but all is not lost we are not throwing
Caption: dice we can calculate some things when
Caption: science gives us advice
Caption: though nothing is certain one thing is
Caption: key
Caption: physics can tell us the
Caption: probability quantum probability a tricky
Caption: concept to use it one needs to be quite
Caption: adept but study the math and before long
Caption: the quantum tune you'll be singing along
Caption: algebra calculus and geometry
Caption: the more math you know the happier
Caption: you'll be
Caption: the cat was not done there was more
Caption: quantum physics such a rich theory can't
Caption: be taught in mere minutes the next
Caption: lesson i have is where the name comes
Caption: from i'll tell you why we call it
Caption: quantum you see said the cat when you
Caption: measure my size any number at all is due
Caption: to arise
Caption: but measure an atom and what will come
Caption: out a single quantum of energy will be
Caption: brought about
Caption: a photon of light will be let go the
Caption: atom's energy from high to low
Caption: the photons energy must be exact one
Caption: quantum of light from the atom subtract
Caption: so you see now said the box cat no
Caption: superposition no doubt about that when i
Caption: measure i break the quantum effect no
Caption: paradox at all that you should suspect
Caption: i know all of this schrodinger quickly
Caption: replied i invented this theory a fact
Caption: none deny i'm afraid it is you who is
Caption: missing a fact the best part of the
Caption: theory is due for its act
Caption: of course i am talking of entanglement
Caption: the source that is giving me such
Caption: bafflement
Caption: the box will be closed just the atom and
Caption: you a large quantum thing becomes of the
Caption: two you and the atom entanglement a
Caption: curious state it's no accident we'll
Caption: open the box and ask just one question
Caption: what did it look like the quantum
Caption: connection
Caption: i wish to resolve this deep mystery so
Caption: future scientists have less misery
Caption: the cat disagreed it's not mysterious
Caption: you have simply mixed up our experience
Caption: outside the box lies uncertainty but for
Caption: me in the box i will know what i see the
Caption: light from the atom will come or will
Caption: not and not superposed as you have
Caption: thought
Caption: but the cat could see without doubt we
Caption: were not ready ready to let it get out
Caption: so the cat agreed to stay in and wait
Caption: for the atom inside to change its state
Caption: so the trial began the atom and cat
Caption: inside the box it quietly sat
Caption: we waited too the tension was rife we
Caption: decided to wait for the adam's half-life
Caption: that is the time for the atom's decay to
Caption: reach the point of half what it may the
Caption: point of half-life was shown on the
Caption: clock schrodinger knew what went on in
Caption: the box
Caption: two possibilities at the same time but
Caption: open the box and only one we shall find
Caption: but what had gone on before the box
Caption: opened from the cat in the box it will
Caption: be spoken so we opened the box and what
Caption: was in there
Caption: the cat sitting quietly licking its hair
Caption: cat shouted schrodinger what do you say
Caption: what did you see do not delay
Caption: it is as i said i saw the photon nothing
Caption: strange at all in the box has gone on
Caption: the atom collapsed a short time ago i
Caption: measured its light as it will now show
Caption: for science to work repetition is key to
Caption: correct errors we need at least three
Caption: but more is better data is gold so
Caption: valuable it's bought and it's sold
Caption: so the cat went back in again and again
Caption: the cat was amused and did not complain
Caption: the results were in and we had to agree
Caption: there was no quantum magic for the cat
Caption: to see the light from the atom came or
Caption: did not but never them both as
Caption: schrodinger thought
Caption: now we are happy with no paradox thanks
Caption: to the cat
Caption: the cat in the box
Caption: the end
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: okay so there was lots of words in there
Caption: um they upset schrodinger
Caption: i don't know if you know who erwin
Caption: schrodinger is he's a german scientist
Caption: austrian science i can't remember
Caption: back then it didn't matter um
Caption: but he
Caption: this is what he wrote it's like this
Caption: obscure paper that he became famous for
Caption: and this was you know this isn't exactly
Caption: what he wrote because he wrote it in
Caption: german but this is the translation
Caption: so we can read that so one can even set
Caption: up quite ridiculous cases a cat is
Caption: penned up in a steel chamber along with
Caption: the following device which must be
Caption: secured against direct interference by
Caption: the cat
Caption: in a geiger counter that is the thing
Caption: that tests radioactivity there's a
Caption: little bit of radioactive substance so
Caption: small that perhaps in the course of an
Caption: hour one of the atoms decays
Caption: but also with equal probability perhaps
Caption: none
Caption: if it happens the counter tube
Caption: discharges and through a relay releases
Caption: a hammer that shatters a small flask of
Caption: hydrocyanic acid
Caption: if one has left this entire system to
Caption: itself for an hour one would say that
Caption: the cat still lives if meanwhile no atom
Caption: has decay
Caption: but the first atomic decay would have
Caption: poisoned it
Caption: the psi function which i'll tell you
Caption: about in a minute of the entire system
Caption: would express this by having in the
Caption: living and dead cat
Caption: mixed or smeared out in equal parts
Caption: um
Caption: this is like early 20th century germany
Caption: that's
Caption: probably not
Caption: uncommon
Caption: um
Caption: so i i changed it for the modern times
Caption: so we have this cool cat that doesn't
Caption: die
Caption: um
Caption: but that you know that was one paragraph
Caption: and and that's
Caption: one of the most famous things that
Caption: schrodinger or the it's the most
Caption: yeah it's what he's most famous for
Caption: although
Caption: he did
Caption: invent the schrodinger equation which is
Caption: still
Caption: the
Caption: equation that we use in quantum physics
Caption: to explain the behavior of the
Caption: microscopic world
Caption: and i'm going to tell you a little bit
Caption: about that because
Caption: today
Caption: you know at this at the center for
Caption: quantum software and places all around
Caption: the world we're trying to build a new
Caption: kind of computing technology that's
Caption: built from these things that that
Caption: schrodinger's talking about
Caption: and he was really frustrated about
Caption: quantum theory in fact he left quantum
Caption: theory to become an irish botanist
Caption: which is also true
Caption: and he wrote a book called what is life
Caption: and that became very influential to
Caption: people like francis crick who went on to
Caption: discover
Caption: dna after he stole photos from someone
Caption: so
Caption: you know he's
Caption: an odd an odd character and i think had
Caption: he stayed in quantum physics
Caption: he probably would have figured out
Caption: some of the things that i'm going to
Caption: tell you
Caption: in a little bit
Caption: okay so
Caption: what's all this stuff about atoms so
Caption: you've probably seen a picture like that
Caption: maybe you remember it from your high
Caption: school
Caption: chemistry or science class
Caption: you have this thing in the middle and
Caption: and then the electrons go around the
Caption: outside
Caption: and the further away they're away from
Caption: the center the more energy they have
Caption: so the lowest energy state is called the
Caption: ground state and the highest energy
Caption: state is called the excited state
Caption: so there's two imagine two states
Caption: ground state excited state
Caption: if
Caption: the electron goes from the excited state
Caption: to the ground state we call that decay
Caption: and when that happens
Caption: energy has to be given off there's
Caption: conservation of energy if you have high
Caption: energy then low energy then that energy
Caption: has to go somewhere
Caption: and that energy is always the same
Caption: amount and that's where the word quantum
Caption: in quantum physics comes from
Caption: and we usually associate things in
Caption: quantum physics at the fundamental level
Caption: with particles and so it's a photon
Caption: so
Caption: energy from the electron gets turned
Caption: into electromagnetic energy that we can
Caption: detect and see
Caption: we'll move closer to abstraction we'll
Caption: get rid of this picture that we draw
Caption: for
Caption: for students
Caption: and
Caption: in science we we think of like a ladder
Caption: of energy and you can step up and step
Caption: down and you need to
Caption: to
Caption: step to drop down you have to give away
Caption: energy that's the decay but you can also
Caption: have the opposite which is absorption
Caption: and so for something to gain energy to
Caption: step up
Caption: then it has to accept a photon and that
Caption: amount of energy has to be
Caption: exact
Caption: okay so the picture in the book was like
Caption: this you know artistic between ground
Caption: state and excited state
Caption: um
Caption: you know in
Caption: in
Caption: in physics we draw this energy level
Caption: diagram
Caption: and
Caption: since we're all comfortable with um
Caption: binary numbers here let's label them one
Caption: and zero
Caption: so you can see now that this atom can
Caption: encode a bit of information
Caption: in its energy levels
Caption: and
Caption: it can do more than that
Caption: and how the the secret to quantum
Caption: physics is to do this
Caption: you put little symbols around it
Caption: and now becomes
Caption: what schrodinger called a psi function
Caption: and i'll i'll tell you why we do that in
Caption: a second
Caption: okay so in the book
Caption: if the atom is excited then it hasn't
Caption: give it hasn't decayed and it hasn't
Caption: given off this photon so the cat can't
Caption: see anything
Caption: uh if it decayed then the cat
Caption: sees the photon that was given off and
Caption: the
Caption: uh the electron is in the lower state
Caption: but what about in the middle
Caption: hmm that's interesting can we do that
Caption: sure why not it's quantum physics and we
Caption: say that
Caption: it's in a superposition
Caption: so it's in both zero and one at the same
Caption: time
Caption: and
Caption: that's the sort of secret to quantum
Caption: physics so
Caption: it's
Caption: even though i've labeled it zero and one
Caption: it it doesn't encode a bit of
Caption: information anymore
Caption: technically it's a new mathematical
Caption: object it's a vector and if you know
Caption: anything about vectors then you can add
Caption: them together
Caption: so
Caption: in addition to 0 and 1 i can have any
Caption: sort of combination of zero and one
Caption: as well
Caption: so
Caption: this
Caption: is a new kind of information
Caption: that is much richer than our
Caption: conventional notion of bits
Caption: the rule is that
Caption: either when you try to
Caption: when you try to go and look at this
Caption: information you'll see
Caption: the lower state
Caption: or
Caption: the higher state and
Caption: what happens is determined by the rules
Caption: of probability in quantum mechanics
Caption: okay
Caption: but you never get to see superpositions
Caption: so that's the sort of trick
Caption: so
Caption: quantum information is richer in some
Caption: sense but it's limiting in another sense
Caption: and trying to find the balance between
Caption: those
Caption: uh is is part of the the trick of the
Caption: quantum
Caption: programmer
Caption: so
Caption: the the other thing
Caption: that was mentioned in the book
Caption: was
Caption: these correlations
Caption: so
Caption: i have
Caption: the atom being in its lower state and
Caption: the cat seeing
Caption: and i have the atom staying in this
Caption: excited state and the cat not seeing so
Caption: those two events are correlated
Caption: and those correlated events can be put
Caption: in superposition as well why not with
Caption: their vectors let's just add them
Caption: together and that's what's called
Caption: quantum entanglement it's a coral it's a
Caption: superposition of these correlations
Caption: uh
Caption: so schrodinger he was sitting outside
Caption: the box and that's what he's had in his
Caption: mind okay according to quantum mechanics
Caption: these things are correlated and i have
Caption: to describe them in this way
Caption: but i only ever see this
Caption: or this
Caption: so what does that other thing mean
Caption: right what what are these what are these
Caption: things inside this
Caption: angle bracket and straight back
Caption: back at me
Caption: um
Caption: basically his his question was what is
Caption: this psi function
Caption: so
Caption: yeah when we
Caption: when we write out arbitrary
Caption: states of quantum information we usually
Caption: use greek letters
Caption: and
Caption: we start with psi and then we run
Caption: through them all until
Caption: we run out and then we start putting
Caption: subscripts and superscripts and all
Caption: sorts of
Caption: stuff that scares people away
Caption: probably on purpose
Caption: okay
Caption: so the answer to the question there's
Caption: two answers to the question
Caption: one is
Caption: this
Caption: object
Caption: is
Caption: in one-to-one correspondence with what's
Caption: really happening it's what describes
Caption: reality
Caption: that's one way to look at it
Caption: if you follow that path it'll lead you
Caption: towards like
Caption: parallel universes many worlds the
Caption: multiverse
Caption: marvel movies that sort of thing
Caption: um
Caption: a lot of
Caption: philosophers and physicists like this um
Caption: but
Caption: in the 90s well maybe like in the 80s
Caption: people started to think about this
Caption: what if this object is really just
Caption: information
Caption: and if we think about it in that way
Caption: then
Caption: we have this we're not constrained by
Caption: uh our physical intuition
Caption: that we require when we practice physics
Caption: and so in the in the 80s
Caption: people started to think about
Caption: what we could do
Caption: with this information
Caption: it seems to be richer than
Caption: bits
Caption: um
Caption: could we
Caption: could we just simulate it
Caption: so i saw a talk just just earlier today
Caption: where someone mentioned a turing machine
Caption: so there's the famous uh church touring
Caption: thesis that basically the physical
Caption: version is
Caption: a touring computer can efficiently
Caption: simulate any physical process in the
Caption: universe
Caption: but that doesn't seem to be true of
Caption: quantum physics
Caption: so
Caption: in the 80s
Caption: they invented the
Caption: notion of a quantum turing machine and
Caption: there's a new
Caption: thesis the quantum church turning thesis
Caption: by the way
Caption: if you're ever
Caption: get into quantum physics it's just an
Caption: exercise in putting the word quantum in
Caption: front of everything that everyone else
Caption: has already worked out
Caption: um
Caption: the quantum church touring thesis says
Caption: that a universal quantum computer could
Caption: efficiently simulate every any physical
Caption: process in the universe and we don't
Caption: know we don't have an answer to that
Caption: question of if there's a gap is a
Caption: quantum computer actually more powerful
Caption: than a classical computer
Caption: you'll win a million dollars if you can
Caption: answer that question it's related to the
Caption: famous p versus mp complete question
Caption: um but you probably win a lot more stuff
Caption: if you figure that out so we don't know
Caption: but we highly suspect
Caption: that a quantum computer
Caption: is
Caption: in some sense more powerful than a
Caption: classical computer
Caption: and
Caption: in 1995 a guy named peter shore
Caption: figured out that if you could build a
Caption: quantum computer there's an algorithm
Caption: you can run on it
Caption: called shore's algorithm now
Caption: i don't think he called it shaw's
Caption: algorithm but
Caption: people after him called it shorts
Caption: alcohol
Caption: that would crack our essay
Caption: and so
Caption: 1995 was really the cusp when people
Caption: started to get interested in this
Caption: because there was money and people tend
Caption: to follow money
Caption: and
Caption: we didn't have any any device
Caption: at the time
Caption: now
Caption: we have
Caption: many commercial
Caption: available quantum computers
Caption: so at the university of perth i think
Caption: the only
Caption: commercially available quantum computer
Caption: in australia
Caption: it runs on two quantum bits called
Caption: qubits so not very impressive and the
Caption: largest device
Caption: is around 150
Caption: quantum bits
Caption: also called qubits
Caption: and you can access that for free over
Caption: the cloud
Caption: or you can pay
Caption: and
Caption: those devices have been sold to
Caption: governments around the world as well so
Caption: the
Caption: we've seen slow progress
Caption: but in some sense that's the kind of
Caption: progress you want to see for new
Caption: technology you don't want to see stuff
Caption: like web 3 or blockchain or whatever
Caption: where it's just type and then disappears
Caption: this is really new transformative
Caption: technology
Caption: that requires
Caption: a slow pace because
Caption: it's very difficult
Caption: so it's going to require a lot of effort
Caption: and now is really the time when i think
Caption: people like you in the audience
Caption: might consider getting involved because
Caption: there are devices available
Caption: and they're currently being programmed
Caption: by physicists and if you've ever seen
Caption: physicist code
Caption: you can see that this is going to lead
Caption: to a huge disaster
Caption: um
Caption: there's there's a thriving open source
Caption: uh community in quantum development um a
Caption: few my colleagues live stream on twitch
Caption: quantum development um
Caption: so it's definitely something that's
Caption: that's happening now and you can get in
Caption: early
Caption: and into this new nation exciting field
Caption: so that's all i wanted to tell you today
Caption: and i'm happy to take any any questions
Caption: uh about
Caption: quantum technology or children's books
Caption: thank you
Caption: i think there's some microphones yeah
Caption: there's one up way up there
Caption: the furthest away
Caption: go over there next
Caption: hi thank you very much that was a great
Caption: talk um
Caption: if you do you have any recommendations
Caption: on where to get started with quantum
Caption: development how to get involved in the
Caption: community anything like that because it
Caption: does sound interesting
Caption: yeah so i i i would suggest starting
Caption: with um
Caption: there's
Caption: there's this non-for-profit called the
Caption: unitary fund
Caption: and
Caption: it's it's probably the largest open
Caption: source quantum community so if you look
Caption: up unitary fund
Caption: um
Caption: and they they'll give small grants and
Caption: stuff to people who are interested in in
Caption: you know
Caption: uh you know
Caption: adding small components to existing open
Caption: source projects
Caption: yeah and and
Caption: i would say
Caption: the majority of people
Caption: don't have a background like they're not
Caption: phd
Caption: quantum physicists in that community
Caption: like they're people coming from outside
Caption: of
Caption: of the of the more traditional quantum
Caption: computing community
Caption: so it's it's a very welcoming
Caption: a very welcoming community
Caption: any other questions
Caption: i think there's one down here
Caption: how many qubits are we looking at before
Caption: rsa becomes completely useless
Caption: um
Caption: millions
Caption: okay yeah it depends on
Caption: so
Caption: the problem today
Caption: is that
Caption: qubits are very fragile so a
Caption: bit um
Caption: you know a transistor
Caption: has an error like one in a billion
Caption: right
Caption: so but if now that you have a billion in
Caption: your device they happen quite often so
Caption: active error correction is is important
Caption: but it's far more important for for
Caption: qubits
Caption: we're not at the stage where we we have
Caption: error corrected qubits we don't have
Caption: perfectly operating devices
Caption: the better we make
Caption: the physical qubits
Caption: the fewer we need like the less overhead
Caption: we need the less redundancy we need
Caption: so the estimates now are a million but
Caption: it it could be could be less
Caption: and so it's like that's the worst case
Caption: scenario
Caption: and if you look at the trend it looks to
Caption: be like a moore's law of qubits
Caption: that's maybe
Caption: 30
Caption: to 50 years
Caption: from now
Caption: so
Caption: the us government for example has moved
Caption: to post quantum cryptography already
Caption: because they have 30-year secrets
Caption: probably
Caption: so if you have a secret you need to keep
Caption: for 30 years then
Caption: maybe it's maybe it's time to to think
Caption: about post-quantum cryptography
Caption: i have 30 year old secrets
Caption: is there a question up here
Caption: oh over here sorry
Caption: in your opinion did google truly achieve
Caption: quantum supremacy
Caption: uh
Caption: yeah so there's this idea that
Caption: there's nothing a quantum computer can
Caption: do today
Caption: that
Caption: my mobile phone can't do
Caption: as
Caption: but
Caption: as quantum computers get bigger every
Caption: time you add a qubit
Caption: uh the
Caption: complexity
Caption: doubles so it grows exponentially so at
Caption: some point quantum technology will
Caption: overtake
Caption: conventional digital technology
Caption: and google claimed to had had done that
Caption: probably three or four years ago at this
Caption: point
Caption: but it's it's not something that's easy
Caption: to prove
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: i think
Caption: with hindsight we would say no that that
Caption: isn't the case because people have
Caption: improved upon existing ways to simulate
Caption: quantum computers
Caption: that can easily replicate what google
Caption: did on their devices
Caption: so it's a sort of
Caption: at the moment we're at this sort of cusp
Caption: where
Caption: increasing the capacity of quantum
Caption: technology
Caption: provides a challenge for conventional
Caption: that
Caption: may easily may be easy to overcome
Caption: because you know
Caption: this isn't something that people think
Caption: about all the time so not a lot of
Caption: effort has been put into
Caption: simulating
Caption: circuits that are built of
Caption: superconductors for example but you know
Caption: when smart people go and and try to
Caption: figure it out
Caption: it turns out that
Caption: it can be done but eventually
Caption: it'll just be impossible there will be
Caption: if you think about it this way
Caption: if you could build the device with 300
Caption: qubits
Caption: then the number of possible states in
Caption: that superposition that i showed you
Caption: would be more than the number of
Caption: particles in the universe so
Caption: we won't be able to do it with with bits
Caption: of information at some point
Caption: where that point is i don't know it's
Caption: you know it it could be now
Caption: it could have been two years ago
Caption: but
Caption: yeah
Caption: i'll also point out that
Caption: they're just trying to demonstrate that
Caption: their device can do something that
Caption: conventional technology can't simulate
Caption: like i can't use a conventional computer
Caption: to simulate what that device did
Caption: that
Caption: that thing that the device that did was
Caption: wasn't useful for anything other than to
Caption: demonstrate that one thing so
Caption: it's not like it was solving actual real
Caption: world problems or anything we're not
Caption: there yet that's going to require
Caption: thousands to millions of
Caption: qubits there any other questions
Caption: no
Caption: hi
Caption: oh
Caption: we need a microphone
Caption: there's one coming from behind you
Caption: quantum computer handle memory leakages
Caption: sorry can you say it again can a quantum
Caption: computer handle memory leakages like we
Caption: face a lot of memory leakage issues in
Caption: classical computers so can a quantum
Caption: computer handle that
Caption: um so a quantum
Caption: so
Caption: there are
Caption: there's a there's a website it's called
Caption: the quantum algorithm zoo
Caption: and it has
Caption: a couple dozen
Caption: problems
Caption: that
Caption: quantum quantum algorithms exist for
Caption: that are better
Caption: than
Caption: known classical algorithms
Caption: but
Caption: standard things like representing data
Caption: adding numbers things like that the the
Caption: overhead actually makes it worse so a
Caption: quantum computer won't be better than a
Caption: classical computer at everything
Caption: there are a few special problems for
Caption: which that kind of new data
Caption: is a more natural or better
Caption: representation
Caption: yeah
Caption: thank you
Caption: i think it was up here
Caption: hi
Caption: um thanks for the talk that was really
Caption: fascinating um so i have a question uh
Caption: realistically in the future how do you
Caption: see quantum computers are being used
Caption: will they replace all traditional
Caption: alternatives that we use now
Caption: and if so what are the top three
Caption: problems that humanity needs to solve in
Caption: order to achieve that
Caption: thank you right
Caption: so i think the way that it will progress
Caption: is
Caption: um
Caption: first we'll see
Caption: a cloud
Caption: cloud-based devices because there will
Caption: be there'll be a very few of them
Caption: and they also require
Caption: a
Caption: if we don't make
Caption: you know
Caption: basically nobel prize winning
Caption: improvements in materials
Caption: these things re require extreme
Caption: environments
Caption: so ultra high vacuum like fewer fewer
Caption: particles than you would find in outer
Caption: space
Caption: or
Caption: cools with liquid helium which makes
Caption: these
Caption: these sort of refrigerators that they're
Caption: housed in the coldest places in the
Caption: universe
Caption: you don't you don't want your average
Caption: consumer i think to have to handle that
Caption: um
Caption: so there'll be cloud-based devices
Caption: initially
Caption: um
Caption: but
Caption: even if we end up
Caption: finding a way to miniaturize it and make
Caption: it work at room temperature
Caption: they'll still be special purpose
Caption: components it'll be like
Caption: you know you have your gpu and maybe you
Caption: have your tpu and you'll have your qpu
Caption: all
Caption: you know handled by
Caption: you know your existing computer your
Caption: existing cpu will just outsource
Caption: particular calculations that it knows
Caption: will be more efficiently run on the
Caption: quantum processor
Caption: oh and you had the other question so i
Caption: don't think it'll ever be used to break
Caption: rsa because
Caption: we'll move beyond uh we'll move beyond
Caption: that
Caption: the most promising application
Caption: is
Caption: using quantum
Caption: systems to simulate other quantum
Caption: systems
Caption: so right now
Caption: it's very difficult to simulate chemical
Caption: interactions
Caption: just because again as i said
Caption: you know a chemical might have more than
Caption: 300 atoms in it and so the number of
Caption: states it can be in is
Caption: more than the number of particles in the
Caption: universe so
Caption: conventional technology has a real hard
Caption: time representing that rich data
Caption: with bits
Caption: and so when you're designing
Caption: vaccines and drugs and stuff
Caption: you're you can do some heuristic
Caption: things and you can do really coarse
Caption: grain simulations but ultimately
Caption: you have to make a guess
Caption: build the drug
Caption: stick it mice find out what happens
Caption: right
Caption: in the future if we're able to simulate
Caption: the interaction between biological
Caption: models in a virtual environment
Caption: then that will just that would be truly
Caption: transformational we'll be able to design
Caption: new drugs new vaccines new materials
Caption: all in a virtual environment before we
Caption: have to go out and spend the money
Caption: to
Caption: build the actual thing
Caption: i think that'll be the number one
Caption: uh yeah the number one application
Caption: where's the microphone i can't see oh
Caption: here
Caption: um how come you didn't say study physics
Caption: as a prerequisite to getting into
Caption: quantum computing
Caption: so
Caption: as in quantum mechanics so study
Caption: physics physics background have a
Caption: physics degree it's like studying
Caption: computer science to do programming et
Caption: cetera so fundamentals
Caption: i think i mean that's just a historical
Caption: quirk that the people who invented the
Caption: field were physicists
Caption: and so the language and jargon is all
Caption: physics jargon but that's changing so at
Caption: the university of technology sydney
Caption: you can
Caption: get a bachelor of computer science and
Caption: major
Caption: in quantum computation so i teach
Caption: introduction to quantum computation to
Caption: people who've never taken a physics
Caption: course at all
Caption: there's no physics jargon
Caption: in it and we start with programming
Caption: we build a quantum tic-tac-toe game and
Caption: we run it on a quantum computer
Caption: and
Caption: they don't need to
Caption: i mean i could do it without even using
Caption: the word superposition and entanglement
Caption: you know once you just specify the rules
Caption: and the grammar and the syntax of the
Caption: quantum programming language then it's
Caption: just like any other computer science
Caption: did the microphone
Caption: hello um so schrodinger's cat
Caption: represented an era of quantum computing
Caption: where we had leaps and bounds and
Caption: discovery and understanding but that was
Caption: like the 20s like 1920s and 1930s what
Caption: do you think is next for quantum theory
Caption: like the next big thing
Caption: oh that's a good question um
Caption: so the
Caption: you know the questions that schrodinger
Caption: raised are unresolved um
Caption: you know we don't
Caption: we don't really know what the nature of
Caption: reality is we know that quantum
Caption: mechanics is wrong in some sense
Caption: we have two main
Caption: theories in physics einstein's theory of
Caption: general relativity which works for large
Caption: scale things
Caption: and quantum mechanics which works for
Caption: small scale things
Caption: and they're completely incompatible
Caption: so
Caption: one of them's wrong or they're both
Caption: wrong which is the more likely scenario
Caption: uh
Caption: and
Caption: that's kind of what most
Caption: theoretical physicists think about at
Caption: least the ones that um
Caption: have tenure
Caption: they
Caption: they they think about
Caption: how do you bring these two things
Caption: together you know it's what einstein
Caption: spent the most of his life trying to
Caption: figure out
Caption: i mean he kind of invented both of the
Caption: theories um and then spent the rest of
Caption: his life trying to put them together
Caption: so doing that or coming up with a
Caption: completely new theory that supersedes
Caption: both general relativity and quantum
Caption: mechanics and you can get some pretty
Caption: wild speculations like the universe is a
Caption: hologram
Caption: or you know a black hole is really a
Caption: quantum computer these sorts of things
Caption: are what people talk about at
Caption: theoretical physics conferences
Caption: i
Caption: i yeah
Caption: i guess i'm not old and cranky enough to
Caption: think about that sort of stuff i still
Caption: write
Caption: i just write research grants in
Caption: children's books
Caption: any other questions
Caption: there's one down here
Caption: oh and there's one over there
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: uh thanks for your talk i was going to
Caption: change tech and talk about your
Caption: you know being an author for children
Caption: can you describe
Caption: a bit of your creative process from
Caption: being a scientist to then communicating
Caption: what are quite you know obscure or
Caption: perhaps esoteric
Caption: concepts to such a junior audience i
Caption: mean what do you
Caption: how do you even start that process
Caption: yeah so i think
Caption: the motivation obviously was
Caption: to for my to read to my own kids so i
Caption: have
Caption: four children and
Caption: i wanted to
Caption: read science books to them
Caption: and
Caption: this was maybe eight years ago
Caption: it didn't really exist
Caption: so i thought well i'll just try to do it
Caption: myself and and
Caption: what better thing to write about for
Caption: children than quantum physics and so i
Caption: wrote
Caption: i wrote quantum physics for babies and
Caption: um
Caption: and i i kind of approached it
Caption: as i would my my own sort of teaching so
Caption: i don't really
Caption: distinguish between an audience of
Caption: physicists and audience of children um
Caption: you know just
Caption: keep it simple
Caption: and use bright diagrams
Caption: um
Caption: yeah and so i did that and it seemed to
Caption: work out and some of the other like the
Caption: book here was kind of modeled um loosely
Caption: on
Caption: um you know the cat
Caption: the cat in the hat
Caption: um
Caption: although
Caption: this isn't going to go live this is oh
Caption: it is live
Caption: so if the dr seuss foundation is
Caption: listening you didn't hear that part um
Caption: so i you know as a physicist or as a
Caption: scientist you you're just
Caption: naturally attuned to taking things that
Caption: people have built
Caption: and and simplifying them or looking at
Caption: them in a different way or building upon
Caption: them
Caption: usually to make them better now i don't
Caption: want to say that i made something better
Caption: than dr seuss but
Caption: the point is
Caption: it's much easier to take something that
Caption: exists
Caption: and then put your own spin or
Caption: improvement upon it and that's kind of
Caption: what scientists do all the time nobody
Caption: just invents a theory in vacuum right
Caption: they they build upon the previous thing
Caption: it's all incremental and so for me it
Caption: seems really like it's just a natural
Caption: thing for me to do to say
Caption: take something that exists and i know
Caption: that works well
Caption: and then add my own flavor to it
Caption: um
Caption: so like we see like say a ai in the last
Caption: 10 years there's been a lot of like
Caption: debates about ethics ethical cool
Caption: problems and such is there anything any
Caption: um debates of that saw in the quantum
Caption: world
Caption: it is it's very uh there's not a lot of
Caption: people
Caption: thinking about it um
Caption: so
Caption: yeah
Caption: i think there was a white paper about
Caption: about quantum ethics
Caption: and
Caption: you know it's largely inspired by the
Caption: debate in ai
Caption: and
Caption: the argument is let's get on top of this
Caption: now or we're going to end up like ai
Caption: with a whole bunch of things to fix in
Caption: the future
Caption: um
Caption: but
Caption: you know without
Caption: i think
Caption: really you can you we're watching an
Caption: experiment right and the hypothesis is
Caption: does money talk and yes it does
Caption: so there's no money being put into that
Caption: effort
Caption: and there's money being put into just
Caption: going and moving forward as fast as
Caption: possible
Caption: so it's it's going to be a challenge
Caption: um i my suspicion is like most things
Caption: are just
Caption: we're going to forge ahead with a lot of
Caption: stuff to clean up
Caption: afterward but there is
Caption: there is
Caption: so
Caption: one of the one of the differences
Caption: is that
Caption: the promise of quantum technology
Caption: and the likely path forward is that
Caption: at some point in the future there'll be
Caption: only a handful of these devices and
Caption: they'll be extremely powerful
Caption: like they can break rsa
Caption: so
Caption: there won't be democratic access to
Caption: these these things
Caption: because of the way things are structured
Caption: and so that that's sort of the the major
Caption: difference
Caption: um in the debate
Caption: between
Caption: quantum ethics and ai ethics
Caption: but certainly
Caption: something that people think about it's
Caption: just not enough
Caption: any more questions
Caption: i see one
Caption: just kind of following up from that uh
Caption: what you're just talking about um so
Caption: what does a career like look like in
Caption: quantum computing for let's say a
Caption: student going through one of your
Caption: classes right now
Caption: what is the let's just say they're in
Caption: their 20s and they're going to spend an
Caption: entire career what do you what do you
Caption: think it would look like
Caption: yeah so the quantum industry is large
Caption: enough
Caption: at this point
Caption: that the majority of people that are in
Caption: it
Caption: don't really know anything about quantum
Caption: computing at all so
Caption: you know
Caption: a quantum computing company
Caption: say a quantum startup company
Caption: needs to have a website
Caption: so
Caption: it needs web designers right uh
Caption: and
Caption: i
Caption: i work closely with a couple quantum
Caption: startups and you need remarkably little
Caption: knowledge about quantum computing to
Caption: if you have
Caption: if you're a talented developer
Caption: then you can learn all all you need to
Caption: know on the on the job
Caption: in
Caption: so in our
Caption: degree program there's kind of two
Caption: pathways there's sort of the honors
Caption: higher education pathway so if you want
Caption: to be
Caption: like a research scientist at a quantum
Caption: company
Caption: then you still need
Caption: some some higher degree probably a phd
Caption: but then there's sort of the technology
Caption: pathway
Caption: where
Caption: you will be a computer scientist
Caption: but the quantum company won't have to
Caption: spend eight months
Caption: on some
Caption: special induction about
Caption: about quantum computing for you so
Caption: you'll already be kind of well-versed in
Caption: all of the language and lingo and
Caption: nuances that you would otherwise have to
Caption: learn on the job but i speak to people
Caption: who work at quantum
Caption: startup companies
Caption: and
Caption: they're like yeah i don't
Caption: i don't know any i don't know what
Caption: like i i i
Caption: someone told me to program this thing
Caption: and i did it but i have no idea what it
Caption: means
Caption: oh
Caption: yeah
Caption: probably like devs have you seen devs
Caption: yeah if you haven't yeah
Caption: devs is probably if you really want to
Caption: figure out what a quantum startup
Caption: is like watch the
Caption: i think it's on uh
Caption: fx in in in the us and then it's
Caption: i don't remember what what streaming
Caption: service is on here but
Caption: yeah it's it's a
Caption: it's a series
Caption: about a quantum computing startup
Caption: company
Caption: all right thank you very much chris
Caption: thank you again for joining us today
Caption: it's exciting to know that i could be a
Caption: uh i could work in quantum
Caption: computing because i find stuff on stack
Caption: overflow and have no idea what any of it
Caption: means
Caption: so thank you very much for joining us i
Caption: believe
Caption: you're going to be sticking around for a
Caption: little bit if people had any more
Caption: questions
Caption: chris would be hanging around a bit
Caption: afterwards
Caption: so now we're on to everybody's favorite
Caption: part of the day the prize draw while we
Caption: get set up who here has filled in their
Caption: treasure map
Caption: who here has given us their filled in
Caption: now is your last chance to bring
Caption: treasure maps down to the front we have
Caption: a lovely silver bowl somewhere
Caption: bring your treasure maps down and put
Caption: them in there who here has submitted
Caption: feedback
Caption: who here thinks the talks were amazing
Caption: and would like to still submit their
Caption: feedback now is your chance to submit
Caption: feedback while we get the prizes set up
Caption: just over here
Caption: there is a lovely big silver chalice
Caption: treasure maps over here
Caption: oh yeah if you if you have written your
Caption: name on it you probably have a better
Caption: chance of winning so
Caption: wooden spoon fantastic
Caption: yeah it's a price
Caption: okay so
Caption: while
Caption: it's up
Caption: while people is putting them in back do
Caption: we want to tell people a little bit
Caption: about what they're going in the draw to
Caption: win i think we've got a slide to go up
Caption: now yes yes we do
Caption: so if you can't see what's down here on
Caption: the stage
Caption: you have a picture
Caption: uh and we have a number of interesting
Caption: prizes here amy what have we got we've
Caption: got a lot of lego
Caption: what what else do we have
Caption: we have some books
Caption: by chris ferry
Caption: we have some i don't leave sorry back i
Caption: do believe those books are going to be
Caption: autographed afterwards so the winner
Caption: will get them signed uh directly to them
Caption: afterwards yes
Caption: uh we have a wooden spoon
Caption: we have
Caption: do we have a wooden spoon back we have a
Caption: wooden spoon what's that for ah
Caption: yeah this is if you put in poor feedback
Caption: no it is
Caption: the cooking professor
Caption: 300
Caption: yes
Caption: that looks pretty good
Caption: um i think we've got some kids toys here
Caption: as well
Caption: this one anybody a fan of lions
Caption: this is
Caption: two adult memberships for the perth zoo
Caption: oh
Caption: what's this what's this a little seal
Caption: perth wildlife encounters three hundred
Caption: dollars
Caption: you can go swimming with the seals with
Caption: them i think all down with the penguins
Caption: and is this buzz
Caption: i think so buzz lightyear we have 200
Caption: uh for the perth observatory
Caption: wow this is great this is great amy and
Caption: this one here i see we have the matagara
Caption: bridge climb and zipline 300
Caption: fantastic so
Caption: uh heaps heaps of prizes prize buffet uh
Caption: there is still time because we're doing
Caption: the feedback draw last so if you are
Caption: going oh
Caption: i need to submit some feedback and tell
Caption: chris how wonderful his talk was or how
Caption: wonderful another speaker's talk was do
Caption: it now
Caption: we won't be offended if we see you
Caption: looking at your phone yes okay is it
Caption: just the sessions as well bec or can
Caption: they give us feedback on our msc
Caption: capabilities we love the feedback yes so
Caption: uh if you have enjoyed the conference
Caption: today and think that it could be
Caption: improved
Caption: please tell us how
Caption: again same website conference feedback
Caption: please do so that is how we grow and
Caption: grow up yes before we do that i've just
Caption: realized we've missed a couple of these
Caption: really lovely looking golden tickets
Caption: here
Caption: golden yeah yeah golden tickets
Caption: we have a web directions in sydney
Caption: summit ticket
Caption: and and i have a yao perth ticket and i
Caption: believe that's in a couple of weeks yes
Caption: it is fantastic okay
Caption: let's do it
Caption: if you are
Caption: unaware
Caption: there
Caption: has been a few prizes by sponsors as
Caption: well yeah you might have seen that out
Caption: there on uh on so many booths um there
Caption: have been so many awesome prizes
Caption: available today and there is still time
Caption: for the majority of them
Caption: for you to submit so if you thought oh
Caption: wait i really wanted to uh to enter that
Caption: prize please do make sure you go and
Caption: visit that sponsor's website or their
Caption: social media accounts find the links and
Caption: enter those
Caption: prize draws we do have two that have
Caption: already been drawn however now the maker
Caption: x draw
Caption: for a fantastic hot rod is for beth
Caption: cooper
Caption: do we have beth here
Caption: yeah so fantastic if you want to make
Caption: your way down here
Caption: i believe
Caption: there is a representative
Caption: probably a makerx
Caption: employee meet you to give you your
Caption: wonderful lego atari and now we also
Caption: have one more which is the
Caption: aws drawer i have that one as well oh
Caption: yeah is it in your pocket it's in my
Caption: pocket yeah uh i can't i can't quite
Caption: remember who won this one
Caption: i can't quite read their handwriting ah
Caption: anton ball
Caption: uh so
Caption: uh
Caption: wonderful segway sponsors volunteers
Caption: all
Caption: um so anton ball
Caption: is he in the room he's already got it
Caption: okay he's got it so he has received it
Caption: yeah all right yeah we're able to keep
Caption: on going i was disappointed people were
Caption: um stealing prizes our prizes down the
Caption: front
Caption: okay speaker pose bingo draw is our
Caption: first one up so uh we got a heap of
Caption: entries yep do you want to draw it back
Caption: yeah i'd love to draw it yeah you might
Caption: need to hold my mic okay i'll hold your
Caption: mic while you hold the box
Caption: so we had one one entry and it was a
Caption: fantastic entry okay hayley went to so
Caption: much effort we have uh fantastic speaker
Caption: pose gifts going on everything's
Caption: available if you're on twitter you need
Caption: to follow haley and check them out so
Caption: congratulations hayley you get the first
Caption: choice so you get to make your way down
Caption: here and choose which prize you would
Caption: like
Caption: all right let's get going i'm sure this
Caption: is a good call out as well for when we
Caption: do this next year that the odds for this
Caption: one are pretty good
Caption: i love it
Caption: next up we have the treasure map prize
Caption: draw now beck how many how many draws do
Caption: we have for this one i think there's a
Caption: couple
Caption: yeah i'd say until about half the prizes
Caption: are gone sounds good okay all right do
Caption: you want i'll draw the first one yeah
Caption: from our transparent box
Caption: it's great we're developers you can't
Caption: read our handwriting anyway we can't
Caption: read anyway it's fine
Caption: i actually can't really read this one
Caption: very well um
Caption: justin bradshaw are you in the room
Caption: okay fantastic come on down
Caption: sorry
Caption: i'm just going to say we don't need to
Caption: clap for everyone no you can't you can
Caption: definitely clap for everybody um if you
Caption: don't want to come down to the stage
Caption: you're going to have to get yourself or
Caption: someone next to you to yell out which
Caption: prize you want so we can put it aside
Caption: alrighty
Caption: awesome
Caption: so
Caption: uh am i doing the next one yes you want
Caption: here i'll i'll hold the box for you so
Caption: you can do the next one
Caption: even better
Caption: okay
Caption: do we have a swastik
Caption: in the
Caption: i believe yes
Caption: fantastic
Caption: go again amy
Caption: yeah this is going to be easier if we
Caption: just crouch
Caption: i liked the invisible box better
Caption: it's really bright to stare up into the
Caption: sky
Caption: it's blinding lights okay how'd you go
Caption: do you want to read mine and i'll read
Caption: yours
Caption: i think that is radu do we have a radu
Caption: here
Caption: yes
Caption: we have alex vettel ago
Caption: no one wants our wooden spoon back no
Caption: one wants no one wants the wooden spoon
Caption: goodness okay
Caption: okay
Caption: see now you're on a time schedule
Caption: because we're going to call the next one
Caption: and yes
Caption: and if they get down here first they get
Caption: to choose before you
Caption: daryl mammaril
Caption: is daryl in the room yeah it's coming
Caption: coming down
Caption: julianne spark
Caption: yeah
Caption: okay
Caption: so now uh
Caption: some of you who have been here before
Caption: might remember that we have a little uh
Caption: spinner prize draw spinner
Caption: yeah and if you're lucky to be the first
Caption: person to be called then you are also
Caption: called second and third
Caption: yeah okay so hopefully
Caption: we have fixed that glaring bug
Caption: this year
Caption: that kind of still remains to be seen
Caption: if you see your name
Caption: please
Caption: come on down or wave or get someone next
Caption: to you to wave so that we know
Caption: you're here
Caption: okay we're ready to get started i think
Caption: there's an indecision going on down here
Caption: yeah decisions are being made
Caption: first up
Caption: praven
Caption: come on down fantastic
Caption: now is the real moment of truth uh and
Caption: it's also a great segue for us to make
Caption: sure that we
Caption: do a big call out to our amazing
Caption: volunteers
Caption: without our volunteers
Caption: proving's going to win again
Caption: and
Caption: without our volunteers we we really
Caption: wouldn't be here today we are an
Caption: entirely voluntary uh
Caption: volunteer run
Caption: conference
Caption: uh words are starting to fail me you can
Caption: see it's been a long day we're entirely
Caption: volunteer run we're entirely community
Caption: run and the only reason that we are we
Caption: are able to host this wonderful day is
Caption: because
Caption: of everyone here
Caption: who has contributed
Caption: can i please get
Caption: a round of applause
Caption: however you wish to do it for our
Caption: wonderful volunteers
Caption: i think back
Caption: we should actually probably also
Caption: acknowledge that there are not only the
Caption: amazing volunteers in the room here in
Caption: our beautiful
Caption: berry shirts
Caption: but there are a whole bunch of
Caption: volunteers who are outside having missed
Caption: our wonderful lock note having missed
Caption: the prize draw because they are helping
Caption: to set up
Caption: for what is happening next so perhaps we
Caption: need to have a super loud round of
Caption: applause for all the volunteers who are
Caption: still out there working raise this roof
Caption: now the benefit of us doing that now is
Caption: they'll all think that we're coming out
Caption: which means that they'll go extra fast
Caption: okay okay yes now we see if our
Caption: lovely volunteers have fixed it
Caption: yes it works cameron
Caption: do we have a cameron do we have cameron
Caption: in the room
Caption: all right so um
Caption: oh i think we've got if we got someone
Caption: coming down do we have some yes we've
Caption: got someone coming down that was close i
Caption: was about to give it up
Caption: okay shall we do this again i think so
Caption: yeah this is when it breaks again
Caption: yeah
Caption: ross ross
Caption: uh now
Caption: when is yao
Caption: amy it's been a couple of weeks i think
Caption: anybody know
Caption: when the yao conference is on
Caption: the 19th
Caption: 19th and the 20th of september coming up
Caption: very very soon and the web direction
Caption: summit in sydney is in december uh does
Caption: anybody know what dates that is
Caption: the first and second of december awesome
Caption: i think there's some perth people who
Caption: are going to be at web directions in
Caption: sydney as well oh are there so that
Caption: would actually probably be an amazing
Caption: experience because we've seen here today
Caption: that there are a bunch of amazing
Caption: speakers in the perth community so you
Caption: get to go all the way to sydney
Caption: and see someone present
Caption: that you could have
Caption: right here in perth without being on a
Caption: plane for six hours
Caption: all right let's do this again
Caption: emmanuel
Caption: uh now fun fact emmanuel you spoke last
Caption: year didn't you
Caption: yes at ddd perth if you want to see
Caption: emmanuel's talk
Caption: you can go to our youtube channel
Caption: because it should be there i think it's
Caption: there uh
Caption: that's a big call out actually of me i'm
Caption: not entirely sure that it's there please
Caption: choose a way emmanuel yes um
Caption: today all of our talks have been live
Caption: streamed and over the coming days and
Caption: coming weeks our volunteers will
Caption: get new batteries and they will
Caption: start back up to make sure that those
Caption: videos are all published in their own
Caption: rights instead of just as one long
Caption: stream
Caption: and now bec i've had this question a lot
Caption: how long are the talks going to be on
Caption: youtube but once they're there like
Caption: you've got a month to watch them or two
Caption: months
Caption: how long do they stay there
Caption: yeah forever for i mean maybe not
Caption: forever who knows if google's going to
Caption: be around next year no they're they're
Caption: going to be maybe they'll kill
Caption: chris
Caption: do we have a chris
Caption: there's chris in the building
Caption: see there is a lot of pressure right
Caption: yeah to choose the prize in front of
Caption: everybody yeah
Caption: coming down
Caption: maria
Caption: okay so i'm going to do another shout
Caption: out on the volunteers but i'm not going
Caption: to make you clap
Caption: thank you
Caption: um
Caption: we
Caption: did i mentioned my volunteer run yeah
Caption: i'm pretty sure i said that
Caption: if you would love to make this
Caption: conference come to life again next year
Caption: then we need you
Caption: and we need
Caption: all the help that we can get to make
Caption: this conference come to life so if you
Caption: are keen
Caption: please
Caption: get in touch with us we have many
Caption: mediums we have twitter we're ddd perth
Caption: we have insta we're ddd perth we have
Caption: facebook where
Caption: i think we're ddd perth cool and
Caption: linkedin i'm pretty sure
Caption: diddy deep adelaide
Caption: yeah maybe
Caption: that probably comes to us
Caption: let's face it yes so
Caption: you can get in touch with us through a
Caption: variety of social channels or info
Caption: dddperth.com we absolutely do want you
Caption: on board if you have the capacity to
Caption: volunteer with us we would love to chat
Caption: now back in those volunteering roles
Caption: while you're walking over there
Caption: what are some of the roles that people
Caption: could be helping in to give them an idea
Caption: of what they could do
Caption: cool so we need designers
Caption: because this neon sign
Caption: was not my doing
Caption: uh we need
Caption: web developers
Caption: uh to fix bugs that last for years
Caption: or make last last-minute changes to the
Caption: agenda
Caption: uh we need photographers on the day
Caption: we need people who are adept at
Caption: communications uh and social media
Caption: because half the tweets come from me and
Caption: that's why they're very short
Caption: what else
Caption: uh well i think we've had some people
Caption: who've done some literally very heavy
Caption: lifting today oh yes we've definitely if
Caption: anybody would like to save money on the
Caption: gym i think uh bumping in and bumping
Caption: out of ddd perth is considered an
Caption: excellent workout
Caption: and then we've got a whole bunch of
Caption: people who've just been amazing
Caption: walking back and forward and back and
Caption: forward across our very very large venue
Caption: this year fetching things and chasing
Caption: things up and checking things out so
Caption: i think there is definitely a lot of
Caption: roles available if people are interested
Caption: in volunteering absolutely we also have
Caption: a very dedicated but very exhausted uh
Caption: committee
Caption: and so
Caption: if you think you know what i would love
Caption: to see
Caption: rebecca and amy's face every month
Caption: for a committee meeting
Caption: then you should definitely get in touch
Caption: if you're good with numbers
Caption: get in touch if you
Caption: like directing things get in touch
Caption: we absolutely value everybody's
Caption: contribution
Caption: okay i'm gonna
Caption: you're gonna press the button
Caption: i didn't even look
Caption: resell are you here
Caption: oh
Caption: okay all right that's fine no i think
Caption: hi yes fantastic please
Caption: okay and the final prize goes
Caption: to michelle wilkins
Caption: michelle
Caption: fantastic okay
Caption: so i think we've said unless we want to
Caption: say thank you to volunteers again
Caption: we've said a lot of thank yous tonight
Caption: um we've also been given a directive
Caption: that we need to keep you here for as
Caption: long as possible yes did you work that
Caption: out yes
Caption: so i suppose that's a good way to segue
Caption: into if everybody has had an amazing
Caption: time at dddd perth today did you know
Caption: that we're not the only ddd conference
Caption: in australia
Caption: coming up in
Caption: this december
Caption: december 3rd
Caption: ddd brisbane is happening which i think
Caption: is the only other ddd happening in
Caption: australia this year
Caption: so can
Caption: and cfp has opened so if anybody
Caption: saw some of the amazing presenters today
Caption: and would like to give that a go
Caption: themselves cfp is open
Caption: so that you could submit and present at
Caption: ddd brisbane
Caption: so
Caption: keep that in mind
Caption: i mean we'll stay on this stage
Caption: well you're in your seats absolutely
Caption: right no we won't we'll probably keep on
Caption: chatting for a little bit uh as people
Caption: you know pack up their belongings and
Caption: get going
Caption: i don't know what about
Caption: i'm kind of lost yeah i i i think i'm
Caption: out of things as well yeah
Caption: thank you so much for coming to ddw
Caption: perth we really appreciate you being
Caption: here
Caption: thank you
Caption: thank you for joining us
Caption: we would love to see people outside
Caption: afterwards if you would like to continue
Caption: chatting otherwise we hope to see you
Caption: all next year
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: good night
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: good night
Caption: mark where are you mark
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now auth zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it we got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up
Caption: steven we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition
Caption: is hunger for success it drives us to
Caption: challenge the way things are to pursue
Caption: what seems insurmountable to keep going
Caption: when others would stop ambition is how a
Caption: global manufacturer is using ai to
Caption: empower employees with disabilities
Caption: ambition is how a company managed an
Caption: overnight transition to remote work for
Caption: 100 000 teammates ambition is how a
Caption: children's hospital built an app to
Caption: reduce stress for families ambition is
Caption: how a law firm rallied against a malware
Caption: attack to reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm josh nate i'm a test engineer
Caption: they call me gesture because i always
Caption: have a smile on my face whatever
Caption: situation i'm in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and and joy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow i also get a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top note
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they